if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
[Music]
massive dumps
ducks dumps dumps
dumps dumps
[Music]
donald trump multiple times that it was
massive dumps that led him to lose the
election which is just
dumps dumps
[Music]
tremendous amounts of water where the
water rushes out to sea
[Music]
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
cost of the election
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
[Music]
we're looking very strongly in sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
[Music]
and bathrooms
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
[Music]
is this the explanation
the big massive dumpster elements of
bathrooms
[Music]
ten times
god bless
the united states thank you
[Music]
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now costs 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't mangoes like
three boxes
that's it
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
going on
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying from the
mangoes
forcefully affected the american people
don't
[Music]
is
well welcome everybody it is 5 30 a.m on
the west coast 8 30 a.m on the east
coast and today is gonna be the first
day of questioning questioning of joe
biden's supreme court nominee
judge
katanji brown jackson and for me this is
really the most interesting day
yesterday was interesting to some degree
it was a little bit of a preview as to
which republican senators were going to
basically
be completely outrageous lunatics during
the questioning i think tom cotton is a
top contender marsha blackburn is a top
contender probably lindsey graham
um
we you know james lankford seemed to be
completely separated from reality
yesterday
um
it's going to be i think we're going to
see impressive ignorance
and extremism during today's uh hearings
but
the questions for me are really the meat
of this oh josh hawley yes josh hawley
another one
um it's gonna be wild it's gonna be wild
so i'm glad you're joining me i expect
sort of a slow start it's still very
early something about our audience
uh has a lot of our audience sleeping
before noon eastern time and so anything
anything we do before noon eastern can
be you know kind of a kind of a question
operator here asking a very fair
question via super chat did i miss
breakfast discussions no i just made
breakfast i had
some beautiful uh mushrooms sauteed
mushrooms
and then i had a fried egg with plenty
of oregano and chili pepper on it uh and
then sort of like a tomato salad i have
some you know in uh i i still am in the
phase of the year where i get little
tomatoes i don't think the big tomatoes
are good until a little bit later in the
season in in the northeast of the united
states um it has to do with the um
uh what's the what did the uh
volume uh wait no the volume area ratio
and that's why you want to really kind
of avoid the large tomatoes in the
northeast until it's really the time
when they're in season j kenji lopez alt
has a whole mathematical rant about it
um and then obviously i made a
cappuccino i mean it's it is uh
it's a day that ends in day so we we did
that as well
very strong mushrooms absolutely
it was quite a morning that's exactly
right now i've been up for eight hours
now i'm kidding i've been up for like 40
minutes
um
okay all right so anyway now that we've
gotten no mango is part of breakfast um
joe says i've officially lost 40 pounds
this morning cheers to a balanced whole
food diet no fast food congratulations
joe
um love to hear that
oh somebody had tortilla for lunch in
madrid yeah i was just in spain a couple
months ago
and my breakfast every day
was a
a coffee
and the tomato bread love the tomato
bread it's i think it's in every region
of spain
i was in northwestern spain
and one of the keys with the tomato is
number one
you don't use the skin of the tomato you
don't use the skin of the tomato and you
really want to rub garlic on the bread
and you've got to rub it vigorously i
mean this is not for the faint of heart
you really need to rub that garlic
very vigorously
friction friction is what you need on
that
um but yes the the tortilla for lunch
and one of the key things i think about
spanish tortilla is there's something
about it where
room temperature is like the i would
argue the perfect temperature
i would argue that for spanish tortilla
i'll have it hot gladly
gladly
i'm not a fan of it cold but there's
something about
just room temperature and it just works
really really well for everybody
involved oh my god i'm losing followers
like they're dropping like flies due to
this discussion okay um a couple of uh
things i i did send out a few choice
tweets about these hearings first and
foremost i asked yesterday is there any
factual basis on which judge jackson
would be unqualified to be on the court
compared to the last dozen or so
confirmed nominees
and indeed there is this i guess we
would call it a chart
and there is no factual basis on which
judge katanji brown jackson would be um
would be unqualified if we look at
who went to an ivy league law school
well everybody but amy coveted barrett
did
if we look at who has been a supreme
court court clerk jackson has and
clarence thomas alito sotomayor were not
if we look at who has been a public
defender it's it's been judge jackson if
we look at who has been on a sentencing
commission it's only jackson and breyer
who she is slated to replace if we look
at who's been a district judge it's only
jackson and sotomayor and if we look at
who has been a court of appeals judge it
is everybody but elena kagan so there is
no i mean listen
unless you want to argue as i jokingly
did yesterday that something else should
be considered like it seems possible
that judge katanji brown jackson may not
have done well in middle school health
class
we're just not being given the records
to figure it out okay that's a joke
but as you can see
there's really no factual basis
now one of the things that we may find
in today's hearings because many of the
questions are going to be about
individual
sentencing recommendations
okay
you could end up in a situation where
having been on a sentencing commission
and having been a district judge and see
that both of these are rare
uh jackson would be one of only two on
the court that has been on a sentencing
commission and one of only two on the
court that has been a district judge
that provides fodder
for people like tom cotton james
lankford josh hawley ted cruz marsha
blackburn
to
zero in on individual decisions now i i
will tell you
on this show right i've been doing this
show for so long
you could of cour if i were to run for
something imagine that i was so
uh such a glutton for punishment and
wanted to expose my entire financial and
personal life to the world for
almost like a
political colonoscopy of sorts and i ran
for something and people started
pumping through all of my clips pumping
pumping pumping right
there is no doubt that you could find
things in my background that i don't
feel best represent the political
ideology of this show over a decade
and similarly
i have no doubt that there are
individual sentencing decisions that
jackson participated in either as a part
of a sentencing commission or as a
district judge that will be isolated
and blown up
which don't represent her overall
judicious judicial philosophy and will
be basically hung out to dry today
does that mean that she is not qualified
no
uh also what does it have to do with the
most important aspect of the job per
republicans which is remaining true to
the constitution
really nothing so anyway the point is
expect that we are going to see a bunch
of that today okay and then lastly and
this is also a joke i tweeted a few
minutes ago i will be doing five
push-ups on my stream today
every time katanji brown jackson is
asked about critical race theory that's
a joke i can't do 10 000 push-ups in a
day you know i mean it's just i i i just
don't think i could do it i think that
would be very
uh dangerous to my health so that that's
just a joke we're not really going to be
doing that
um okay
welcome everybody if you're just joining
us we are moments away from the first
day of questioning for judge katanji
brown jackson's supreme court
confirmation i want to say a massive
thank you to beat spillman beat spillman
just signed up on my website
joinpackman.com and his new member
number one
our coupon code today really important
stuff today is fix the court we must
repair
the broken right wing supreme court we
must do it
we must do it
uh all right let's kick off the morning
with
a voicemail
hey dave i was wondering if trump runs
again
in 2024 do you think
he'll announce his healthcare plan
that would be great right i think
yeah we are still even though trump said
in august of 2019 we are two weeks away
from his health care plan i think he's
saving it for
when he runs in 2024 and then we are
gonna know the healthcare plan
will she tommy asks
will she be hold on a second let's see
if we can do this right
will she be asked about beer
and work out calendars
that is a really really great question
somehow i think not
yesterday during the first day of
hearings donald trump did some counter
programming with a deranged interview on
fox
business
here are uh some of the things that
happened here's what happened when
stuart varney asked trump about policy
to watch there's this discussion about
whether we should send jets mig jets to
help the ukrainian air force would you
send in that kind of help
well maybe even more to be honest with
you and i'm not
let me just explain that
putin is saying things like
don't you dare send anything in in the
meantime he's killing thousands of
thousands of people
so he's acting like we're an aggressor
if we send in some old 44 year old flame
that probably gets shot out of the sky
pretty quickly
what on earth is he talking about and
he's acting like we're terrible people
if we do that
but he's killing tens of thousands of
people far more than they're reporting
you don't knock down those buildings and
blow up those buildings and they say two
people were injured slightly right so
the question was exactly what would you
have sent in and not not answering that
question
um trump now refers to nuclear strikes
as the n-word well in hope to god you
never have to use it because it would be
that would be the tragedy of all
tragedies but if we didn't have it we
couldn't talk but i listened to him
constantly using the n-word that's the
n-word did you see stuart varney's
reaction to that that there's a very
slight
reaction from stuart varney which says a
lot when trump says the n-word
constantly using the n-word that's the
n-word
and he's constantly using it the nuclear
word
and we never
talk if we say oh he's a nuclear power
right
right here's another clip uh here's
trump saying if he were president he
would send nuclear subs nobody knows
where they are
and you should say look you if you
mention that word one more time
and we're gonna send them over and we'll
be coasting back and forth up and down
your coast you can't let this tragedy
continue you can't let these trump
sounds like he's just woke up these
thousands of people die it's gonna be
hundreds of thousands and maybe millions
of people by the
yeah so that was
something else yesterday that was a very
very odd interview
that um
that trump gave
very strange extraordinarily weird
uh okay how long is today expected to go
i don't know let's let's do the math
each senator gets 30 minutes of
questioning how many senators on
the judiciary this is the judiciary
committee right
22 members
okay let me let's see if we can do some
math here okay
22 times 30
is 660 minutes divided by 60 minutes per
hour is 11. now i probably could have
just done 22 divided by 2.
so
that sounds to me like 11 hours
but we've got to add in probably 45
minutes for lunch now 45 divided by 60
points everybody okay that's 0.75 hours
0.75
probably a couple 15 minute breaks which
would be like another half hour
so
we could be looking at oh sorry
we could be looking at it is could we be
looking at a 12-hour day is that
possible or is it possible that some of
them will not get to go today
is that
is the math maybe right on that
it's going to be long it's going to be
long needless to say yeah
uh
yep i'm just not i don't know
some may not use all of their time
that's fair that's fair that's fair
a pair from sweden says you would be
buff if i did five push-ups every time
critical race theory is mentioned yeah
we don't know what sort of uh lunch
they're going to have by the way how are
the calzones the food is here let's take
a break lunch is here pizza is here but
uh we have subway tomorrow right
right warm food around noon yep so we
will see um also it's i actually heard
that they may be bringing in different
types of beans you couldn't find black
beans you couldn't find pinto beans you
couldn't find kidney beans you couldn't
find cannellini beans you couldn't find
refried beans you couldn't find spicy
refried beans you couldn't find fava
beans okay i could go on right and i
guess they have them all there at the uh
building that's why we can't get them
oliver says can somebody please put
together a video comparing side by side
the wright's vile interrogation of judge
brown versus their shameless praise of
amy covet barrett that would be a nice
video to do
can we really trust a justice who
doesn't cry about calendars i know and
imagine if she doesn't even like beer it
would be crazy it really really would be
crazy um
okay what is today's coupon code okay
the coupon code is right above my head
the coupon code is fix the court
let's do it first person to use that
code
today gets a free item from my online
store could be a hat t-shirt hoodie
whatever
um
fix the court is the message at
joinpakman.com
yes i am giving shout outs to twitch
prime subscribers of course of course
that's a every day everybody gets a huge
thank you oh let me see if i had any
bands to adjudicate while we're waiting
um
yes there is one
okay yesterday user angel devilish was
banned from twitch
for saying i doubt this will help
bumbling biden's approval rating
katangi's nomination would be a victory
for every child porn producer out there
they were banned and simply said i did
nothing wrong
that is a
permaban now i do want to take a moment
to address something that the term child
porn i want to address the term child
porn
i have reflexively and sort of
unthinkingly
referred to explicit images of children
as child porn in the past i'm going to
make an effort not to do that anymore
and i got a couple of emails about this
pornography
is overwhelmingly
legal
and basically like a business decision
where consenting adults and producers
are making a product
okay
child porn is not that but with kids
it's really a different animal we're
talking about
criminal
child exploitation of individuals who
can't give informed consent and are
being
uh abused okay so i agree
i agree with a handful of people said
you know
child porn is not really the word you
should be using and that may be relevant
during today's hearings uh you could
argue that it's a form of trafficking
it's a form of child abuse etc so i'm
gonna make an effort to refer to this as
i guess we would call it
imagery of child exploit exploitation or
explicit
uh
i guess i need to i need to think of the
right word to use
but i do think that when you say child
porn it's not really emblematic of what
it is
uh it's not necessarily trafficking i i
recognize that i'm open to hearing from
you guys how i should refer to it maybe
it's just explicit images of children is
what we should do but it is a completely
different animal from just like
pornography so i think that it we do
need a different word for it
uh
child sexual abuse material
uh that could that could maybe work
um
yeah
sexual material of children
illegal sex yeah we need to think about
what the right term would be i think we
need to think about what the right term
would be i want to say a huge thank you
to king titus who has just got a twitch
prime subscription it's an incredible
day today is the day to get those twitch
prime subscriptions now some of you have
asked
we're expecting today to go anywhere
from 10 to 12 hours
okay
as many of you know we are all dependent
on various machines to make this stream
happen
and mike pillow
is looking to sue all machines we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines
so the question is will we be able to
stream all day
and it really comes down it's really a
legal question is mike pillow going to
be able to to end machines
uh
and uh i don't have any i don't have the
answer to that i don't know the answer
to that we're gonna have to wait
thank you to fatty mcblunts
for the uh twitch prime subscription you
were number three today and i very much
appreciate that also thank you to
ludovic syrwa
who just signed up on my website using
the coupon code fix the court
ludovic you have just gotten yourself a
free item from my online store which you
can find at davidpakman.com
gear pick an item sir pick an item also
thank you to hazel star for the twitch
prime subscription number five today
welcome ever come on in everybody uh
very very important day today here we
see senator doug jones there is senator
amy klobuchar
she is ready to go very very much ready
to go it's going to be a very
interesting day of hearings remember
yesterday i got was getting all these
super chats from people saying
when are these questions and the answer
is no those were not questions the
questions start today
questions start today uh each senator
getting 30 minutes today and 20 minutes
tomorrow
30 20 30 20 okay there is maybe the most
vile man in america ted cruz speaking to
uh presumably a member of his staff he's
gonna be disgusting today you can you
can bet your bottom dollar on that uh
welcome to trumpet of death who's a new
twitch prime subscriber i really
appreciate that couple other voicemails
do i have anything from whitney i do
here is a new voicemail from whitney
fresh off the presses from 3 46 a.m this
morning
so i found this article
and it was dated november 28th 2019.
it says uh my question says russia china
not nato allies common enemies
uh terrorism
okay there is tom cotton i would expect
him to uh give us one of the most
weaponized and disgusting lines of
questioning of the hearing for sure for
sure here's troy york he doesn't like my
coverage of tulsi
uh david pakman you're ridiculous once
again you're misinforming and lying
about tulsi gabbard and you're showing
your misogyny i could not care less
about tulsi gabbard's uh gender it makes
no difference uh she could be
uh male female non-binary trans trans
woman trans man what she says doesn't
make sense
uh regardless of her sexual identity or
sexual orientation uh makes absolutely
no difference whatsoever
troy york then calling in with some
biden conspiracy
joe
biden
part of a criminal network
that has used policy to benefit his
family
okay no evidence of that here is josh
hawley who will also be asking some
absurd questions based on his
introduction yesterday chandler davis
via super chat is asking for an obama
obama
always glad to oblige
um
yeah
see if we have any room audio
we do have a little bit
things slowly coming to order
scheduled to start right now and
not surprisingly just running a few
minutes behind a few minutes behind
there is senator richard blumenthal from
connecticut a democrat he had a very
thoughtful opening statement yesterday
now for people saying david you just
think all the republicans had bad
opening statements and all the democrats
had good ones no i mean i found patrick
leahy democrat from vermont's opening
statement
pretty kind of just dumb i mean it just
i don't know didn't really care for it
um
i found chuck grassley's opening
statement as a republican
dumb but not really weaponized in the
same way that for example lindsey
graham's was or tom cotton or so so no
it's not it's not just a it's just not
not uniquely a partisan thing
ferret queen says good morning david i'm
currently getting ready for the second
job i had to take due to rising costs
who is fighting for overworked people
like me good question ferret queen
good question
i believe that that's is that sheldon
whitehouse i don't know all senators uh
by face
was that sheldon whitehouse that just
walked by
there is senator marcia blackburn who is
horrible horrible horrible just a bad
person a bad person in every sense chuck
grassley 88 year old chuck grassley
entering the chamber with a red tie
there to the right of our screen
you see ted cruz very strongly texting
as we stand by here
uh everybody coming in asking what's
going on
this is the uh second day of the
confirmation hearings of judge katanji
brown jackson there is senator patrick
leahy nice guy i just didn't think any i
didn't think his
opening statement was particularly good
i don't dislike the guy or you know he's
fine
um
we are um
chuck grassley combing his eyebrows
there as you can see and his hair
we are accepting new members yes i don't
know i don't even know what that means
but sure why not
see if we've got one more voicemail for
us while we wait here
so i kind of have like an idea just
because there's like so much rumors and
uh paranoia and fear that i'm trying to
like analyze it and really get down to
like the nitty-gritty of what like
society is doing with the jewish people
seems just like more important than like
anything right now yep there it is
lindsay weighing in on the plight of the
jewish people
or something
thanks to copper tunes for the twitch
prime subscription spending those bezos
bucks uh that is dick durbin screen
right with the red tie dark red tie he's
the chair of the committee
here is
cory booker senator from new jersey
he had a very interesting opening
statement yesterday he's interesting to
follow on tick tock by the way he has a
presence on tick tock not as big as our
presence on tick tock to be to be
perfectly frank with you
uh but he does have a presence on tick
tock
uh this is a cameraman here front and
center holding a sony camera seems like
recently
showered um
is that mike lee i don't recognize that
senator i believe that's mike lee
i don't think i could recognize all 100
senators by face john cornyn is the guy
standing in the background there i could
probably recognize
maybe 80 or something like that would be
an interesting i wonder if there's a
website that does that
uh
name senators by picture
let's see
identify all hundred senators by picture
yeah that actually man like everything
exists huh maybe we'll play that game
during a break that sounds interesting
see if i can do it
play quiz
uh oh boy i already don't
uh
i'm just checking this out
this might be a good game for us yeah
we'll do that a little bit later
that'll be interesting
thank you to toxic princess ember there
is patrick leahy taking a photograph for
his personal collection toxic princess
ember is new member number eight
will i open the phone lines today i mean
listen it's going to be a long day
but i am willing to sacrifice myself if
we get to 100 members today
i will i will open the phone lines i
will do that
oliver says fantastic and informative
show yesterday on critical race theory i
wonder how many times it's used against
judge brown today yeah i jokingly
tweeted i will be doing five push-ups on
stream today every time judge jackson is
asked about critical race theory i'm not
really going to do that i think it would
lead to me having to do thousands of
push-ups and i just don't think i'm i
don't think i could do thousands
the real mr joshua has just grabbed the
twitch prime subscription appreciate
that
very much
expecting judge jackson any moment
any moment should be arriving here oh
hold on i think we were preferring this
feat at this point
um
this is a senator from minnesota amy
klobuchar there
we are standing by
other voicemails let's see what else
we've got
hey book boy what's up man
this is the guy who calls me book boy
which i kind of i don't find to be
insulting in any way if more people read
we probably wouldn't be in this mess to
begin with um isn't it nice that the
government can
just come together and abolish daylight
savings time
god i can't believe they can get that
priority straight like that and what i
would like to know if you can give an
answer to
why the illuminati and the freemasons
are allowed to roam free in the
government
i am not able to unfortunately i don't
have an answer to that
i don't have an answer to that
paris says we need john burkhow keeping
order absolutely i want to say a massive
thank you to juan
flores who is the newest member at
joinpackman.com
juan
welcome welcome welcome we don't do this
crazy thing of saying juan as wan
again live here on capitol hill on this
date uh we don't we just don't do that
that's not for this channel if you're
looking for channels where they say the
name juan as wan
they probably exist
they probably exist but this is not one
of them this is senator john kennedy
over here
uh not one of the democratic kennedys
he's a republican
he's a republican oh somebody found a
small fuzzy moss found the infamous
chocolate cake moment for us from the
other day i didn't think this was that
funny but a bunch of people wrote in
saying they were cracking up at this i
think you spoke
english at all this is a story i think
i've never told a big crowd like this
but
i didn't think
he spoke english
because he wouldn't even say
why is it glitching hold a big crowd
like this but
i didn't think he spoke english because
he wouldn't even say hello we had a very
good relationship until covered
and then i said
why why are these clips so glitchy does
anybody know
see if i just refresh it
i think he spoke and i said forget it
that was
a step too far but we did we respected
each other
we respected each other but i said
president we're using chocolate
anyway i didn't think it was that funny
i thought it was just kind of a
throwaway moment but a bunch of people
wrote to me and said it's great here is
judge katanji brown jackson wearing red
today a lot of people very closely
paying attention to what signals
politically are being sent by her
clothes i quite frankly could not care
less
this meeting of the senate judiciary
committee will come to order
good morning judge jackson welcome back
to you and your family
good morning mr chairman this second day
is known affectionately uh by a term
of medieval justice known as the trial
by ordeal
this will be your opportunity to speak
but each member of the committee has 30
minutes to ask
and i know that they're going to be
careful to stay within time limits
of those 30 minutes
i do want to remind my colleagues that
history has proven
that speeches don't have to be eternal
to be immortal
president lincoln learned at gettysburg
that 275 words were enough
so i hope my my colleagues and friends
will stick to the 30-minute guideline
i'll tap on the gavel if you're getting
perilously close to extending beyond
please
we'll take a few breaks throughout the
day a number of them are scheduled one
for lunch one for dinner and
several perhaps shorter ones
in the meantime
if votes are called on the senate floor
which is a possibility we'll do our best
to keep the hearing going as members go
back and forth
and as i mentioned yesterday we welcome
all of our friends in the audience and
ask that they be quiet and respectful
during the hearing so let's love that
you're here shut the f up and i'll begin
at this point judge jackson there are
two issues that came up
repeatedly yesterday from the other side
of the aisle that i want to address at
the outset
one of them was a question of judicial
philosophy
no one questions
either your
academic
law school credentials
or your service as clerk
and as federal judge
but time and again
you have been asked what is your
judicial philosophy
does it fit into
scalia's originalism
kavanaugh's textualism
is it strict construction is it liberal
is it conservative
lo and behold i've discovered the answer
it turns out that during the course of
your time as a judge you have actually
had written opinions
573 to be exact i think
maybe i'm off by one or two
and they more or less express your view
of the law as the facts are presented to
you in each one of those cases
and then some twelve thousand pages from
the sentencing commission transcripts of
deliberations on important issues
for most of us as elected senators
if people asked what what's your
philosophy we'd point to our voting
record
you have a record when it comes to court
decisions and this committee for the
fourth time
is delving into everything that you've
published
as a judge and even before
so would you like to comment at the
outset
of those who are looking for a label
what your position is on judicial
philosophy
yes thank you
mr chairman
over the course of my uh almost decade
on the bench
i have developed
a methodology that i use um
in order to ensure that i am ruling
impartially
and that i am adhering
to the limits on my
judicial authority
uh i am acutely aware that as a judge in
our system
i have limited
power
and um i am trying in every case
to stay in my lane
and so what i do um is i essentially
follow three steps
the first step
is when i get a case
i ensure that i am proceeding from a
position of neutrality
um this means that you know you you get
a case and it's about something and it's
submitted by certain parties
i am clearing my mind of any
preconceived notions about how the case
might come out i'm setting aside any
personal views
it's very important that judges rule
without fear or favor
the second step is once i've
cleared the decks so to speak in this
way
i
am able to receive all of the
appropriate inputs
for the case
that is the party's arguments they've
written briefs
sometimes we have a hearing sometimes we
hear from other parties
amiki in a case
and then there's the factual record i am
evaluating all of the facts from various
perspectives
i think my experience all of the various
experiences that i've had really helps
me
at this stage to see the perspectives of
all of the parties and to understand
their arguments
and then the third step is the
interpretation and application of the
law
to the facts in the case
and this is where i'm really observing
the constraints on my judicial authority
there are many constraints in
our system
importantly because just
judges have limited authority
and so i am first of all looking at my
jurisdiction
threshold matter in every federal case
is to make sure that you even have the
power to hear the case
um
in evaluating jurisdiction you're
looking at all sorts of things the the
text of a jurisdictional provision for
example precedent related to it
if i can get to the merits of the case
if i have jurisdiction
then i am
observing the limits on my authority
concerning the questions so if it is a
statute for example or a provision of
the constitution i'm looking at the text
the adherence to text is a constraint on
my authority i'm trying to figure out
what those words mean
as they were intended by the people who
wrote them so at this point
i'm looking at original
documents i am focusing on the original
public meaning because i'm constrained
to interpret the text
sometimes that's enough
to to resolve the issue in terms of the
merits
judges
also look at history and practice
at the time of the the
document was created if it's a statute
i'm looking at congress's purposes
because again i am not importing my
personal views or policy preferences the
entire exercise is about trying to
understand
what
those who created this policy or this
this law intended
i'm also looking at precedent which is a
another constraint on judicial authority
um i am
looking at prior cases and trying to
understand what other judges have said
uh as a lower court judge i'm bound by
the president uh and even in the supreme
court if i was fortunate enough to be
confirmed there's starry decisis which
is a binding
kind of principle that the justices look
at when they're considering precedence
so all of these things come into play
in terms of my judicial philosophy
another issue which has come up to my
surprise and i've spoken to my
republican colleagues about their
fascination with it is the notion of the
composition of the supreme court
which euphemism euphemistically is
referred to as court packing
i have said on the floor and i will
repeat here
there is exactly one living senator who
has effectively changed the size
of the supreme court
that was the republican leader senator
mcconnell
who shrank the court to eight seats for
nearly a year
in 2016 when he blocked president
obama's nomination of merrick garland
now that question on court packing was
opposed to amy coney barrett justice in
the court when she appeared before this
if you get this out early she was asked
about it
she said and i quote could not opine on
it
and on many other policy issues then
judge barrett said repeatedly she could
not share her views stating and i quote
i will not express a view on a matter of
public policy especially one that is
politically controversial because that
is inconsistent with the judicial role
i do believe we should have rules and
traditions and precedents but we
shouldn't have a separate set of rules
for republican nominees and democratic
nominees
so judge jackson
if a senator were to ask you today about
proposals about changing the current
size of the supreme court
deflating announcement
senator i agree with justice barrett in
her um
her response to that question when she
was asked before this committee
again my
north star
is
the consideration of
the proper role of a judge in our
constitutional scheme
and in my view judges should not be
speaking in to political issues
um and certainly not a nominee
it will never be up to her how many
justices are on the court so agree with
with justice barrett
let me address another issue that came
up yesterday in the opening
phase of this
nomination hearing
and it's the issue involving child
pornography
i want to turn to that issue because it
was raised multiple times primarily by
the senator from missouri
and it was he was questioning your
sentencing record in child pornography
cases
that do not involve the production of
pornographic material they're known as
non-production cases
i wanted to put some context here
the senator from missouri has in his
tweets said of your position on this
issue
judge jackson has a pattern of letting
child porn offenders off the hook for
their appalling crimes imagine chewing
gum judge and a policymaker she's been
advocating it since law school
this goes beyond soft on crime the
senator said i'm concerned this is a
record that endangers our children
i thought about his charges as i watched
you and your family
listening carefully yesterday
and what impact it might have had on you
personally to know that your daughter's
husband
parents
family and friends
we're hearing the charges that your
implementation of this law says holly
seemed to be chewing his cud children
could you tell us what was going through
your mind at that point
thank you senator
as a mother
and a judge who has had
to deal with these cases
i was thinking
that nothing could be further from the
truth
these are some of the most
difficult cases that a judge has to deal
with because we're talking
about pictures
of
sex abuse of children
we're talking about graphic descriptions
that judges have to read and consider
when they decide how to sentence in
these cases and there's a statute
that tells judges what they're supposed
to do congress has decided
what it is that a judge has to do in
this and any other case when they
sentence
and that statute
that statute doesn't say
look
only at the guidelines and stop
the statute doesn't say um
impose
the highest possible penalty for this
sickening and egregious crime
the statute says
calculate the guidelines
but also look at
various aspects of this offense and
impose a sentence that is quote
sufficient but not greater than
necessary
to promote the purposes of punishment
and in every case when i am dealing with
something like this it is important to
me
to make sure that the children's
perspective the children's voices
are represented in my sentencings
and what that means is that for every
defendant who comes before me and who
suggests as they often do
that they're just a looker that these
crimes don't really matter they've
collected these things on the internet
and it's fine
i tell them about
the victim statements that have come in
to me
as a judge
i tell them about the
adults
who are former child sex abuse victims
who tell me that they
will never have a normal adult
relationship
because of this abuse
i tell them about the ones who say i
went into prostitution i
fell into drugs because i was trying to
suppress the hurt
that was done to me
as an as an infant
and the one that was the most
telling to me that i
describe at almost every one of these
sentencings when i look in the eyes of a
defendant who is weeping because i'm
giving him a significant sentence what i
say to him is do you know that there is
someone who has written to me
and who has told me that she has
developed agoraphobia she cannot leave
her house
because she thinks that everyone she
meets
will have seen her
will have seen her pictures on the
internet they're out there forever
at the most vulnerable time of her life
and so she's paralyzed
i tell that story to every
child porn defendant
as a part of my sentencings so that they
understand what they have done
i say to them
that there's only a market for this kind
of material
because there are lookers
that you are contributing
to child sex abuse
and then i impose a significant sentence
and
all of the
additional restraints
that are available in the law
these people are looking at 20 30 40
years of
supervision
they can't use their computers in a
normal way for decades
i am imposing all of those constraints
because i understand how significant
how damaging
how horrible
this crime is
it is it should be noticed as well that
the cases which the senator from
missouri referred to yesterday all
resulted in incarceration
of some magnitude in the one case the
hilly case i want to quote what you said
on the record
this family has been torn apart speaking
to the defendant by your criminal
actions you saw it on the faces of those
women you heard it in their voices and
the impact of your acts on those very
real victims who are still struggling to
recover this day makes your crime among
the most serious criminal offense this
court has ever sentenced
and you imposed a sentence of 29 and a
half years on that defendant
so the notion that you look at this
casually or with leniency as the senator
said
your record belies that and in fact what
we're dealing with here is an issue
which even this committee and members on
the committee have been loathed to
address again
the original law was written at least
nine or ten maybe longer years ago
and the quantity of material was
relevant to the sentencing and now that
we have computer access to voluminous
amounts of material
it is raised question has it not within
the
judiciary as to the appropriate
sentencing in today's circumstances
this was a question that was raised
before the sentencing commission was it
not it was senator the sentencing
commission um has written
at least one report it did when i was
there
looking at the operation of this
guideline as you said the guideline was
based originally on
a statutory scheme and on directives
specific directives by congress at a
time
in which
more serious child pornography offenders
were identified based on
the volume
based on the number of photographs that
they received in the mail and that made
totally total sense
before
when we didn't have the internet when we
didn't have distribution but the way
that the guideline is now structured
based on that set of circumstances
is leading to extreme disparities in the
system
because it's very smart for durbin to
raise this stuff right up front for the
rest of the hearing judge jackson can
basically say like i've already
explained in answering senator durbin
but they can defuse it to the extent
that it will be possible other
republican senators are still going to
hammer on this stuff but they're
creating this foundation that she can
refer back to taking that into account
and
perhaps even more importantly courts
are
adjusting their sentences
in order to account for the change
circumstances but it says nothing about
the court's view of the seriousness of
this offense
judge the
there have been several news
organizations that have taken a look at
the senator from missouri's charges
abc news cnn news the washington post
and others have concluded that they are
inaccurate
and unfair to you and their conclusions
in fact one writer has said they are
meritless to the point
of
unacceptable levels
nationally in 2019 only 30 percent of
non-production child pornography
offenders received a sentence within the
guidelines range
fewer than 30 percent
between 2015 and 2020 in the dc district
court where you served judges imposed
below guideline sentences in
non-production cases 80 percent of the
time for the reasons you've just
explained
judges in missouri
the home state of the senator who has
criticized your record did so 77 percent
of the time
one particular judge whom the senator
supported to become a federal judge by
appointment of
president trump
uh unfortunately
has a
77 percent record if i'm i'm sorry let
me make sure that this is accurate
each senator gets up to 30 minutes today
for those asking and then up to 20
minutes tomorrow
in the united states versus class trump
appointed judge sarah pitlik
the senator's choice for the eastern
district of missouri sentenced an
individual convicted of possession of
child child pornography to 60 months
well below the 135 to 168 month sentence
recommended by the guidelines she
appears to have run into the same issue
or same challenge that you have
described here
so going forward
in terms of this issue
it seems that we at least share the
burden by your interpretation
as to define this statute in modern
terms in terms of technology as it
exists today is that the way you see it
senator
congress
is tasked with the responsibility of
setting penalties
congress
tells judges
what we're supposed to do when we
sentence
and what i'd say is that congress has to
determine
how it
wishes
uh for judges today guys people showing
up and just chatting over and over again
that the hearings are boring this is
what what
i wouldn't even be streaming if it
weren't for this just go watch something
else we're just going to block your
messages it's a very it's just it's a
stupid way to participate you know it
seems like you're desperate for
attention i guess but it's very dumb
therefore there's extreme disparity as
you pointed out there are judges who are
varying because our ultimate charge from
this body
is to sentence
in a way that is sufficient but not
greater than necessary to promote the
purposes of punishment
judge jackson we've heard criticism from
some about your previous work
representing detainees at guantanamo bay
in fact for years we've heard criticisms
leveled against lawyers who have
provided guantanamo detainees with legal
representation
this criticism misses one critical point
the right to counsel
is a fundamental part of our
constitutional sense sentence system
even for the most unpopular defendants
i want to thank senator graham
who served as an air force lawyer for
decades for offering his perspective
yesterday he said and i quote the fact
that you're representing gitmo detainees
is not a problem with me senator graham
said
everyone deserves a lawyer you're doing
the country a great service when you
defend the most unpopular people and
then judge roberts said during his
confirmation hearing it's it's a
tradition of the american bar that goes
back before the founding of the country
that lawyers are not identified with the
positions of their clients the most
famous example this is also very smart
and citing lindsey graham a republican
saying people do we have due process
people deserve defenses and again the
point that hopefully judge jackson will
make if her defense of gitmo detainees
is brought up is you know
we don't really do anything great if we
railroad people with no defense or with
a crappy defense and then imprison them
we don't look good we look good by
giving them good representation and then
when it's appropriate punishing them
those cases and what impact it's had on
you personally in terms of your rulings
on the bench
thank you senator
september 11th
was a tragic attack on this country
we all lived through it we saw
what happened and
there were many
defenses
important defenses
that americans undertook
there were americans whose
service came in the form of military
action
my brother was one of
those americans those brave americans
who um decided to join the military to
to defend our country
there are others of you in this body
who
have military service and i honor that
to protect our country
after 9 11 there were also
lawyers who recognized that
our nation's values were under attack
that we couldn't let the terrorists win
by changing who we were
fundamentally
and what that meant
was that
the people who were
being accused by our government of
having engaged in actions related to
this
under our constitutional scheme were
entitled to representation
we're entitled to be treated fairly
that's what makes our system
the best in the world that's what makes
us exemplary
i was in the federal public defender's
office
when the supreme court
excuse me right after the supreme court
decided
that
individuals who were detained at
guantanamo bay
by the president
could seek a review
of their detention
and
those cases started coming in
federal public defenders don't get to
pick their clients
they
have to represent
uh whoever comes in and it's a service
that's what you do as a federal public
defender you are
standing up for the constitutional value
of representation
and so i represented uh as an appellate
defender some of those detainees
in the early days the legal landscape
was very uncertain
uh this had never happened before not
only the attack but also the
use of executive authority to detain
people in this way and there were a lot
of questions that the court was asking
the supreme court had taken a series of
cases
to try to understand what are the limits
of executive authority which is
important all of our liberty is at stake
if we don't get it right in terms of
what the executive can do
the supreme court has recently
reaffirmed that the constitution does
not get suspended in times of emergency
and so lawyers were trying to help the
court to figure out
figure out what the executives power was
in this circumstance and as an appellate
defender
i worked on the habeas petitions
of some of these detainees my petitions
were
virtually identical because we had very
little information part of the issue
at the very beginning of these cases was
that
most of the
factual information was classified
so
defense counsel were appointed to
represent these defendants we had no
facts
and i was making legal arguments about
the circumstances
that is
what gave rise to my representation and
i
would just emphasize that that's the
role of a criminal defense lawyer
criminal defense lawyers make
arguments on behalf of their clients in
defense of the constitution and in
service of the court
judge jackson um those of us who read
about the workings of the supreme court
realize it's a
close relationship among the justices
you've seen it personally as clerk and
as an attorney yourself
i'm going to close with one question
here that
comes to my mind
i was in the house of representatives
when the war on drug
measure was passed
30 years ago or so
it was at the advent of crack cocaine
it scared the hell out of us the notion
of a cheap narcotic
highly addictive destructive to
mothers and their fetus
led us to
impose a sentencing disparity between
crack and powder cocaine that was
unprecedented a hundred to one
our notion was to come down hard make it
clear that it was a federal standard
impose that standard and stop the
advance of crack cocaine
we failed from the outset
the price of cocaine crack cocaine on
the street went down and
up instead of down
the uh i'm sorry i did that wrong down
instead of up
and the number of users went up instead
of down
and we found ourselves in a position
where we were filling the federal
prisons
uh with violations primarily for
possession of crack cocaine
hundreds of thousands being incarcerated
at the time
i came here to this committee in an
effort to try to change it negotiated a
revision of that measure from 100 to 1
to 18 to 1 with senator jeff sessions
it was passed by the committee by the
senate and by the house of
representatives and signed into law by
president obama
then you on the sentencing commission
had to consider what to do with these
new guidelines coming from congress
and you achieved a consensus i think
most people don't realize the sentencing
commission is a pretty diverse group and
very transparent
could you close in the last minute or so
and tell tell me about that effort to
find consensus on an issue that
controversial
yes senator um as you mentioned the
sentencing commission
is a
very diverse
group of people who've been appointed by
presidents of different parties by law
and at the time that i was on the
commission we had a range of
of
people
judges from different
backgrounds
who had different views about the
criminal justice system but we had a
directive from congress in so far as
congress had changed the penalties as
you mentioned related to crack cocaine
and so
um
we work together
to make a determination about whether or
not the guidelines needed to change and
if so whether or not to
impose those changes retroactively
in light of
all of the evidence that you point out
all of the
um
the congress's changes
and
[Music]
the need to
avoid unwarranted sentencing disparities
which is
exactly the charge that this body has
given to the commission
and we worked together
we reached unanimous agreement
that the change in the guidelines that
was necessitated by the change in the
statute
should apply retroactively
to people who had been
convicted and sentenced under the prior
regime and then congress followed
shortly thereafter by making it uh a
statutory change to to apply
those changes retroactively
thank you to jackson
senator grassley thank you mr chairman
welcome again to our here we go
i got home last night about eight
o'clock the first thing i heard was my
wife's opinion that you did very good in
your opening statement thank you
she didn't have anything to say about my
state
also uh besides the fact that we might
have some votes on the united states
senate just so you know i'm not being
rude to you i may have to go across the
hall to finance committee on some issues
with tariffs and down to the agriculture
committee for some issues on
care
do you
believe
well let me ask it this
way do the first amendment free speech
protections apply equally to
conservative and liberal protesters
yes senator hey
do you believe
the individual right to keep and bear
arms is a fundamental right
senator the supreme court has
established that the individual right to
keep and bear arms is a fundamental
right
could you tell me how you might go about
deciding
what a fundamental right is under the
constitution
well senator um
i don't know that i can tell you that in
the abstract in the sort of way that
that you may have posed the question
um
there is
precedent in the supreme court
related to
um
various rights that the court has
recognized as fundamental
the court has some
guys the audio is is
grassley's really far from his mic she's
really close and so neither sounds good
but it's not on it's nothing i'm doing
the the court has said that
the 14th amendment
substantive due process clause
does
support some fundamental rights but only
things that are
implicit in the ordered concept of
liberty or deeply rooted in the history
and traditions of this country they're
the kinds of rights that relate to
personal
uh individual autonomy and they've
recognized a few
things in that category
um
and that's the tradition of the court
for for
determining whether something is
fundamental in that way okay
uh on another subject uh kind of
personal me over a long period of time
and about half of this committee but
it's a controversial issue with even
within this committee
i favor allowing supreme court hearings
to be televised
what's your view on this how would you
feel about cameras in the courtroom
which
about 40 50 or
40 or 45 of our states allow
well senator i would want to
uh discuss with the other justices
their views and and understand all of
the various um
potential issues related to
cameras in the courtroom before i took a
position on it
i think that's a fair answer at this
point uh i'm going to ask you about a
bill that i got passed a long long time
ago
and it's something that at some level of
course sometimes the district court
sometime with the
circuit court and even if
once or twice at the supreme court
they tend these courts tend to do damage
to a bill
called the false claims act
this bill has brought
70 billion dollars
of fraudulently taken money back into
the federal treasury
since it's been passed
and courts of weakness and then senator
leahy and i usually find ourselves
having to pass legislation to say to the
courts you got it wrong in fact there's
a very controversial bill right now
before the united states senate on that
very subject
it's fought fraud in the department of
defense healthcare industry the
pharmaceutical industry
70 billion dollars is pretty important
so when you get
if you're approved to be on the supreme
court
and the issue of false claims comes up i
hope you think of chuck grassley
it's a question there senator
leahy
the false claims act is one of the best
tools that we have to fight against
government fraud and to recover
taxpayers money i've worked for decades
to protect whistleblowers who shine a
light on fraud waste and abuse in the
government total grandstanding a couple
questions
and i'm going to start with a former
attorney general unnamed once suggested
that ketam's suits were
in his words patently
unconstitutional and another word he
used was dangerous he argued that it
violated the appointments clause
so
understanding that you may get a case
before you on the false claims act but
maybe this appointment clause is
sound enough you could answer do
ketam suits violate the appointments
clause
so senator i'm i am not familiar with
that um could you representational
answer in writing
then well i i'd be happy to do whatever
i'm just trying to assess
i'm sorry i shouldn't have interrupted
you no no that's all right
sorry um
i am trying to
i'm not familiar with the quotation or
what the
attorney may have said
about them i know that the supreme court
has
considered
various key tam actions and has
issued opinions in the area and
has not at least today found them to be
unconstitutional but i don't know if
that issue has been squarely presented
to the court you know the case she
really needs to be asked about right
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines something i
wouldn't be able to
address let me uh
on the same subject
also
this former attorney general also argued
that ketam suits also violate a broader
separation of power principles
are the
can you tell me whether you think the
president's constitutional powers are
violated when private citizens
are allowed to sue in the name of the
united states and that's what key tam
suits are all about private citizens
going to court
um well senator it's a it is an
important concern there are statutes
that do
allow for
um the kinds of
lawsuits that you
are articulating
um
i
am not aware of impediments to those
but again you know this is the kind of
thing that um
may be litigated and
i would have to look as i do
consistent with my methodology
at any arguments that are raised
about
the constitutionality or lawfulness of
those actions
remember in about all of these suits
that involve the courts in making
interpretations of false claims act most
of them are brought by whistleblowers
and remember the government would not
even know about these fraudulent use of
taxpayers without whistleblowers coming
forth and they ought to be given some
credit for wanting the government to do
what the laws say it ought to do and
spend the money the way that the
constitution or that the congress
implies that that money be spent
i want to move on
i'd like to ask have
her she be asked about
uh whether she prefers spring water or
processed tap
junior
who dreamt of a time when quote
the sons of former slaves and the sons
of former slave owners
would be able to sit down together at
the table
of brotherhood end of quote
you talked about how quickly things in
the country then changed
including the civil rights laws over the
next few years because the civil rights
movement
you added that quote less than a decade
after dr king's words
that was the world
that you inhabited
dr king
hoped for a country where we would all
be judged by the content of our
character rather than our race
do these quotes still reflect your views
on this very important topic today
yes senator um
in that speech
i talked about
my
background my upbringing
the fact that
my parents when they were growing up in
miami florida
attended and had to attend racially
segregated schools
because by law
when they were young
white children and black children were
not allowed to go to school together
and my reality
when i was born in 1970 and went to
school
in miami florida
was completely different
i went to a diverse
public
heist junior high school high school
elementary school
and
the fact that we had come that far was
to me a testament
to the the hope and the promise
of this country
the greatness of america
that in one generation
one generation
we could go from
racially segregated schools in florida
to have me sitting here as the first
floridian
ever to be nominated to the supreme
court of the united states
so yes senator that is my
that is my belief and i think it's good
that the country had an opportunity to
hear
what you just told us about your
experience
uh
i'm going to go to something that
the chairman brought up
and i i've written down the 3.3 steps
you go through
uh
no
another question grassley's confused
also one that he brought up very
confused court packing and your opinion
i heard what you said and you said it
should be a policy question but i want
to go to something in 2013 during your
hearing to be a district court judge
senator coburn asked you whether you
believed in the theory that the
constitution is a living document
whose meaning evolves over time you said
no in 2021 however during your circuit
court nomination hearing you declined to
answer the same question when asked why
the answer uh
when asked why the answer to your
question of 2013 and not in 2021
in in written questions you noted that
you weren't a sitting judge so please
explain to me or describe for us
the difference between ethical rules for
sitting judges versus judicial nominees
who are not already judges fair question
senator i don't know that there are
ethical rules that um are different what
what i'll say is with respect to my
um approach to judging
um
there
is not a label i think that
fits what it is that i do
and and how i've approached
my role
as i
mentioned to the chairman
i'm very acutely aware of the
limitations on the exercise of my
judicial power
and
those limitations
come in the form of adherence to the
text when you assuming you even get to
that stage of the process that you have
uh you have
subject matter jurisdiction you can
reach the merits
then you are looking at the text and i
do not believe that there is uh
a living constitution in the sense that
it's changing and it and it's infused
with my own policy perspective or uh you
know the policy perspective of the day
um instead the supreme court has made
clear that
when you're interpreting the
constitution you're looking at the text
at the time of the founding and what the
meaning was then
as a constraint on
my own authority
and so i apply that constraint
i look at the text
to determine what it meant
to those who drafted it
on this same subject
i want to point out a difference between
you and a couple people that have sat on
the supreme court
justice breyer said
that a structural alteration of the
supreme court motivated by perception of
political influence can only feed
the perception
of political influence that's my
parenthetical further eroding that trust
justice ginberg also cited court packing
as being quote unquote a bad idea
court packing is creating new seats for
political purposes for a president to
appoint more judges
really an inspiring speaker miss breyer
and justice ginberg that court packing
is a bad idea before you respond i'd
like to say that
you say this question should be left to
congress as a policy issue i reiterate
that sitting supreme court justices have
spoken on that matter so i don't think
it'd be inappropriate for you to do if
other people sitting there have said
that it's a bad idea
well respectfully senator other nominees
to the supreme court
have
responded as
i will which is
that it is a policy question for
congress and
i am particularly mindful
of of not
speaking to policy issues because i am
so committed yeah it's it's actually i
mean listen guys it's like
she
if she is on the court she will not have
the opportunity to decide how many
justices are on the court no should she
nor should she so why does it matter
what her opinion is and i would
interpret your answer
and you don't have to respond to this
but i think you're saying breyer and
ginsburg should not have stated their
views on that issue
during his opening statement yesterday
one member of this committee suggested
that the supreme court has been bought
by dark money groups
do you agree that the supreme court has
been
bought by dark money groups not really a
legal question
senator i don't have any reason to
believe um
that that's the case i have only the
highest esteem for
the members of the supreme court whom i
i hope to be able to join if i'm
confirmed
um and for all of the members of the
judiciary
thank you for that answer i'm going to
go to international law
during an aba panel on international law
last year
justice breyer said that as a federal
judge quote
you can't do your job properly under
quote without considering international
law
and quote again in some cases
and it's a growing number end of quote
and i assume a growing number of
opportunities use international law
in 2018 op-ed justice breyer said that
quote the best way to preserve american
values may well be
to take account
of what happens abroad end quote
under what circumstances is it
appropriate to consider international
law when interpreting our constitution
fair question i like it thank you
senator um i have nothing but the
highest uh esteem and respect for
um my former boss who i've
spent the better pass better part of the
past couple decades calling my justice
having clerked for him
um
but i do think that
the use of
international law is very limited
in in our
scheme and in our judging
there are
certain
cases in which it is
relied upon
where congress directs or where the
standards are such
the case involves a treaty for example
and you have to interpret international
law in order to be able to
address it
um but there are very very few cases i
think in which international law plays
any role and certainly not in
interpreting the constitution good
answer
i'm i think you probably have answered
my next two questions but if you say you
have nothing to add i would still want
to ask the questions do you think it's
appropriate to look to international law
when interpreting enumerated and
unenumerated constitutional rights
uh no senator
what specific
uh again i think you've answered this
but i want to ask it anyway which
specific constitutional causes or rights
has the supreme court held that can be
interpreted by looking to international
law
i'm not aware of any
that um are
properly illuminated by reference to
international law
uh
now i want to go to a question that
senator durbin asked i'll probably
go a little more but i
remember when this is about your
judicial philosophy
and you made three points uh three steps
you take to go through a case and apply
the law
and uh
and and you say your
methodology is limited power and stay
within your lane
i'd like to ask you
well you've served on the district court
for several years
and spent eight months on the dc circuit
during yesterday's opening statement we
heard a lot about the importance of
judicial philosophy
in your own words you've described that
so you don't have to go through that
again with me
but if congress writes a law
that does not explicitly allow private
parties to sue
do you believe that the federal courts
have the authority to create implied
causes of action and i'd like to have
you elaborate if you say yes to that
i would say that as a general matter no
senator i mean our um
our obligation as judges is not to
create policy
and if congress has enacted a statute
that
establishes a cause of action or
restricts
causes of action
then as a general matter i don't think
that courts can impose one now
you know i'm saying generally because
um
there may be circumstances that i'm not
thinking of they're super i know that
the supreme court has in very
narrow circumstances at times
discussed implied causes of action
but i think the
charge of the judge is to
impose the law as written
there's 115 justices that serve before
you if you are approved by the senate
is there any of them
now or in the past
that has a judicial philosophy that most
closely resembles your own
you know i haven't studied the judicial
philosophies of all of the prior
justices i will say that
i come to
this
position to this moment as a judge who
comes from practice
that i was a trial judge and
my methodology has
developed in that context
i don't know how many other justices
other than justice sotomayor have that
same perspective
but it informs me
with respect to what i understand to be
my proper judicial role
uh
what aspect of your record as a judge do
you believe have been the most important
for the good of the country
there's a little bit of a
what was your favorite case and what was
your least favorite case vibe to this
entire section is important to some
degree because i think it clearly
demonstrates that i'm an independent
jurist
that i am
ruling in every case consistent with the
methodology that i've described
that i'm
impartial
um i don't think that anyone can look at
my record and say that it is pointing in
one direction or another that it is
supporting one viewpoint or another
um
i am
doing the work
and have done the work for the past 10
years please list six laws that you like
and
to stay within the boundaries
of our proper judicial role
let's go to immigration
um
congress gave the attorney general
quote unquote sole and unreviewable
discretion to decide whether expect
expedited renew removal
would apply to quote an alien who has
not been paroled or admitted to the
united states
you decided a case
called make the road new york
where you seem to agree that congress
gave the department of homeland security
sole and unreviewable discretion
to decide which illegal immigrants would
be
subject to expedited re
removal
but you still went on to review the
department's decision in fact you issued
a nationwide injunction blocking
the department of homeland security from
removal where are you
on curbing your dog two years
in that hearing
you told us
that if the text was clear that answered
the question
the law specifically says
that homeland security not the courts
was responsible for making the decision
could you please explain why you
believed a federal court could review
something congress called unreviewable
oh man
thank you
uh senator for allowing me to address
that opinion and my analysis with
respect to it
as you said make the road
was a
case involving a challenge
to expedited removal which was a
a way in which
congress had given the authority to
homeland
to the department of homeland security
to make a decision about how to deport
people
who are non-citizens
prior to the challenge that i heard
the department of homeland security
since it received that authority several
decades ago had decided that people who
were in this country
for up to 14 days
and are
found within 100 miles of the border
are subject to expedited removal
the challenge that
i heard involved the department's sudden
shift
to a determination
that expedited removal would be applied
to anyone who was found anywhere in the
country and who had been here up to
two years
importantly
the challenge
was
not
about the actual determination
the challenge was about the procedures
that the agency undertook to make that
determination
and so the statute said as you
rightly pointed out
that the agency had sole and
unreviewable discretion to decide
and in interpreting that i took into
account
the language of that statute and
the language of
another statute that congress has
enacted to direct agencies with respect
to the manner
in which
they exercised their discretion
so i said and i believed
that seoul
meant that the department of homeland
security
was the only agency who got to make this
determination as to how many months a
person should be in the united states
and unreviewable meant it was final
once the agency decided um
then there was no ability to review
substantively their determination and i
should say
that importantly the statute
that congress enacted
gave the agency the discretion to make
this determination between zero and 24
months
there is a limit in the statute it says
congress you i mean excuse me department
of homeland security you get to decide
where between zero and 24 months
a person
who's been in this country can be
subject to expedited removal
so i read the statute
dhs gets the sole ability to make that
decision
dhs
makes that decision and it's final
what wasn't clear to me based on that
language
was whether congress intended to
preclude
its procedural requirements for the
exercise of agency discretion and in the
dc circuit there was precedent that
indicated that even when
congress gives
a great deal of discretion to an agency
procedural requirements may still apply
it is presumptive
that the apa applies meaning that an
agency can't act arbitrarily and
capriciously when it undertakes to
exercise discretion it has to do certain
things in order to make the
determination that congress has given it
i looked at those statutes oh i'm sorry
no no
i looked at those statutes
and i've
considered
the canons of construction that say that
statutes should be read harmoniously
grassley's not even really listening to
the substance of her answer understand
that congress has directed sometimes in
more than one statute what is supposed
to happen and so i read them together
to mean
that the court could still do what it oh
almost always does
in a case
involving
a challenge to the manner in which an
agency makes its decision and in fact i
thought
as i say in my opinion
that congress intended for the apa to
imply because it had not excluded it
which it had done expressly in other
parts of the of the ina it had not
excluded it here
and
it made sense
to
uh require the agency to use its
expertise if congress wanted the agency
to act arbitrarily in picking a number
congress could have done that
congress said you can do it up to 24
months it could have randomly picked a
number
but it was giving it to the agency i
thought and reasoned precisely because
it wanted the agency to use its
expertise to do its research and to
figure out
what
amount of time
is sufficient
and so it was important i thought
to lay that out in the statute
and
i determined that both of those
statutory directives of congress should
apply
thank you
is coffee
technically
a soup
it's congratulations again on your your
nomination to our nation's highest court
you're an impressive jurors
i hope the broader party i'm stepping
away briefly we'll be back for lindsey
graham who's next
to meet your
family here yesterday and
i thought before i begin my questions i
was going to respond to something the
junior senator from
texas said yesterday
he suggested the democrats exactly the
political agenda by opposing the
nomination then judge gorsuch to the
supreme court i kind of chuckled at that
because
along with others i and
others repeatedly and clearly
stated substantive concerns with justice
scorcher's nomination
i explained my votes on the record
there's no political agenda
i contrast that with
republicans treatment of then judge
merrick garland
we're still
waiting today
and for republicans to explain on the
record what kind of substantive concerns
they had with merrick garland
that they blocked him
for over a year and would not allow
even allow a vote
on his nomination
apparently
because of a politically driven agenda
all i'm saying is let's make history
this week but let's not rewrite it
this is historical time
judge jackson one of the topics we
discussed in our meeting was
our respective experiences
you as a former
federal public defendant myself as a
prosecutor
as a federal public defender here in
washington you were assigned to and then
represented clients who couldn't
otherwise afford a lawyer one of the
valuable lessons i learned as a
prosecutor was this
for a criminal justice system to
function properly you have to have
skilled dedicated lawyers on both sides
of the issue both the prosecutor and the
defense attorney
it's equally essential for judges
to have a nuance and a balanced
understanding of our criminal justice
system if we're going to have justice
done
now
it's really concerning
it's confusing that some
feel your background as a federal public
defender or some kind of a liability
those of us who have spent time in
courtrooms know
you have to have both a
skilled prosecutor and a skilled
defender
i believe that
in fact i don't think of it as a
liability i think it's going to be a
major asset to you
i think it should be welcome uh
on the supreme court
in fact if you're confirmed to the court
as i look back over you're going to be
the first
former federal
public defender
on the court
you're going to be the first nominee
since
justice third good martial
with a significant
background in criminal defense
that's pretty impressive
so
all of us should want that
representing the supreme court
because
decisions on the supreme court can have
a lasting impact on our criminal justice
system
my question is this
i believe that your experience as a
federal public defender has made you a
better judge help you maintain impartial
and balanced perspective and criminal in
other cases
and i assume you would agree with that
yes senator um i i think that experience
in the criminal justice system
um
whether as you say on on the prosecution
side or the defense side having actual
experience
is an asset as a judge you understand
the way the system works
and as a defense counselor you have
interacted
with defendants in a way that
as a judge at least as a trial judge
i thought was very
beneficial
one of those ways
is
it helped me to develop
a sense of the need to communicate
directly with defendants
and you know it didn't change i think in
any way the outcomes
of the cases when i was a trial judge
but
i understood from my time as an
appellate defender
that a lot of defendants go through the
system and don't really understand it
and the problem with that from our
society's standpoint is that when people
go through the criminal justice system
and don't have a good understanding
they tend to not take responsibility for
their own
actions
they tend to be bitter
and feel as though the justice system
has wronged them and so while they're
doing their time rather than reflecting
on the fact
that this is the consequence that they
have to face for
actually
um
committing a crime instead of
doing the work to rehabilitate
themselves
they're you know focusing on how wronged
they are how victimized they feel and so
what i decided
as a trial judge was that i was going to
make sure that everyone who was in my
courtroom and especially the defendant
understood
all of the
procedures that we were going through
all of the steps
i spoke directly to them
i asked them do you understand what's
happening because i wanted them to know
and then even perhaps more importantly
as i said about my my child pornography
cases i focused
on the harms
of the behavior that was at issue
when i sentenced a defendant i made
clear in every case
here is the problem this is what you've
done
here is the damage to our society
and i don't know that i would have done
that um if if i had not been
a criminal defense lawyer
well and
that's sort of what you know i was
getting to the fact that you have that
experience i
also it's obvious you don't get as a
public defender you don't get the right
to you don't get to choose your clients
it's not like you're going out there
picking and choosing you're told
you're going to defend this person but
they're given that right under the sixth
amendment
and we uh we all
you're
a member of the bar or judge or public
defender you take an oath
to uphold the uh constitution
and the sixth amendment's a pretty
important part of it wouldn't you say
absolutely senator
and
it's also a pretty important part
for indigent
defendants is that not correct
that is correct especially for indigent
defendants because they
are determined to not be able to afford
counsel and as you said senator for a
judge
it is crucial
that you have arguments that are being
made and presented on both sides of the
issue
that is what allows for judges to
reach
just results in cases and it's what
makes our system
so exemplary it also guarantees that our
constitution is going to be fall
i
you know i i think it's
important you went around with uh
senator doug jones who's highly
respected
in the center and both sides of the
aisle
but you got to meet um
other other setters i i was delighted
you came to
uh
to spend time in my office and
you noted in your public remarks at the
white house when you were nominated that
you've been
your parents were married for 54 years
uh and both public servants in their own
right and they are proudly watching you
being announced by the president and
i must admit watching them to
the last couple of days they're probably
watching you here as have other members
of your
family
your younger brother became a police
officer detective in baltimore before
serving the army
two
tours of duty in the middle east
two uncles that served as police
officers
so i'm not really surprised that you
understand law enforcement the national
paternal order police
has expressed strong support for your
nomination
in fact their letter dated february 25th
they said you have considered the facts
and applied the law consistently and
fairly on a range of issues
and they went on to say there's little
doubt
do you have the temperament intellect
legal experience
and family background to earn this
appointment
and they added
we are reassured
reassured that should she be confirmed
to the approach of future cases
an open mind treat issues related to law
enforcement fairly and justly
a chair durban had asked consent that
the letter from the fraternal order
police be included in the record
objections
now
that's a statement from the largest law
enforcement
labor organization in the united states
what do you say to people say you're
soft on crime
or even
anti-law enforcement because
you accepted your duties as a public
defender
thank you senator i i would make um
i'd make three observations in response
to
those critiques
um
the first is that as
someone
who has had family members
on patrol and in the line of fire
i care deeply about public safety
i know
what it's like
to have loved ones who go off to protect
and to serve
and the fear
of
not knowing whether or not they're going
to come home again
because of crime in the community
as you said my brother
my brother patrolled the streets of
baltimore
and i had two uncles who were career law
enforcement including
one who became the chief of police of
the city of miami police department in
the 1990s
so crime
and the effects on the community and the
need
for law enforcement
those are not abstract concepts or
political slogans to me
the second
observation that i would make is
that as a lawyer and as
a citizen
i care deeply about our constitution
and about the rights that make us free
as you say criminal defense lawyers
perform a service
and our system is exemplary throughout
the world
precisely because
we
ensure that people who are accused of
crimes are treated fairly
it's very important to me in that
capacity as a lawyer and as a citizen
oh i'm sorry i was just going to say the
third thing i would say is is as a judge
as a judge i care deeply about the rule
of law
and
i know
that in order for us to have a
functioning society
we have to have
people being held accountable for
committing crimes
but we have to do so fairly under our
constitution
as a judge
who has to decide how to handle these
cases
i know it's important to have arguments
from both sides to have competent
counsel and it doesn't mean
that lawyers condone the behavior of
their clients they're making arguments
on behalf of their clients in defense of
the constitution and in service of the
court and it is a service
well i i know in our conversation i
i'd mentioned my own experience as a
prosecutor i wanted the best defense
attorney on the other side
because you want to make sure that
the trial went on everything was done
properly
and
let's talk about guantanamo bay
uh it's been controversial
and we've had two presidents one
republican one democratic who
said they wish it could be closed
but the fact is
individuals were detained there the
whole world was watching this
we
i i know i heard from
people i respect
uh throughout the world
asking questions about
guantanamo and
that's precisely
the situation we want our best and our
brightest lawyers
to step into the prey however
politically controversial we have to
make sure that we do not become uh
unmoored from our core commitments of
the rule of law but they're also both in
our own country and outside our country
people can see that we're following
that so you
were in
private practice uh when you took on
these cases
uncharted illegal waters
more
uh
what principles drove you to get
involved
with cases in such a a difficult time in
guantanamo bay
well thank you senator and i i do want
to clarify when i first started working
on these cases um i was an assistant
federal public defender
the supreme court in 2004
issued two opinions that began
this group of cases and these issues and
this was in the wake of
the tragic and terrible
attack on this country
uh in 9 11
and the executive's use of authority to
detain
enemy combatants at guantanamo bay
in 2004
the supreme court ruled
that
the executive did have the authority to
make those detentions
in one case and then in another case the
supreme court ruled
that anyone so detained could file a
legal challenge
they had habeas rights and as you know
habeas is in the constitution
in 2005 i joined the federal public
defender's office and those cases
started coming in
the requests from detainees asking for
legal representation consistent with our
constitutional scheme
to
have help to file their habeas petitions
this was very early in the days of these
kinds of legal actions there was a lot
unknown
about what these petitions could look
like what the arguments could be made
and considered by the court and and
perhaps most importantly what the facts
were related to any of these individuals
because almost everything was classified
so defense counsel was getting these
these
people in
with no information
i was in the appellate division of my
office and as an appellate defender i
worked on legal issues i was paired with
my i was assigned by the federal public
defender i was an assistant federal
public defender
and i was paired with a trial defender
who
attempted to do the fact gathering who
traveled to guantanamo bay i never
traveled there or anything like that i
worked on the law
and as you noted the law was very
uncertain this was brand new
and people were trying to figure out
what are the limits of executive
authority in this context we knew that
the constitution was not suspended
even though we had this emergency so
what did that mean with respect to these
individuals
i filed as a federal public defender
i was assigned to work on four cases
and i filed almost identical petitions
because what you're doing especially
when you have no facts is just
preserving
legal arguments for your clients that is
consistent with what
lawyers do
and then
you mention private practice so i went
into private practice in i believe it
was 2007
and by that time lots of private
practices around the country had started
taking on these cases because there were
lots of people who needed representation
and so pro bono practices
were receiving requests um usually
through non-profits
and
one of the individuals that i had
represented as a defender
ended up being assigned to my firm
unbeknownst to me
so i arrive at my firm
and the partners realize this same
person
was someone that according to the docket
i had previously represented and they
asked if i would review some of his
materials and continue the
representation that was the only person
that i represented in the context of my
private firm who was a detainee
i worked on a couple of habeas briefs
for
judges and for
a variety of ins of of nonprofits
including the rutherford institute the
cato institute and the constitution
project
who were all interested in making
arguments to the supreme court
that was considering
these very novel legal issues
you know i
i sit here and i i think of the
supreme court nominees i've gotten to
vote on over
my years here and
i
think of the remarkable praise you got
from the former republican house speaker
paul ryan
um whom most of us know well
he did mention his politics may be
different than yours but his praise for
your intellect for your character for
your integrity
is unequivocal
that's powerful praise and i think it
goes to a really
fundamental point and that's this
one doesn't have to have the same
political beliefs or ideologies
as a judicial nominee to recognize their
integrity and intellect
when i voted to confirm chief
justice john roberts of the supreme
court
i cast that vote knowing
very well that he and i would
disagree on many policy and political
issues
but
i voted yes because i believe they had
what it takes to serve
as an impartial
fair chief justice
who would uphold the rule of law
and i want to take it out of partisan
politics
now
what would you say to people whose
politics may be different than yours
like speaker ryan who has
endorsed you
what would you say to those people about
your readiness
to serve as an even-handed unbiased
supreme court justice
thank you senator
i would say that
i am committed
to serving as an even-handed
supreme court justice if i'm confirmed
by this body
and i have a record
over the past decade
that's precisely how i've treated
all of my cases
and i've been serving in the district of
columbia
both as a trial judge and as an
appellate judge and we see some of the
most
politically contentious
issues
my record demonstrates
my impartiality
well i'd go along with that because
when i
i watched this court i
i used to
go there as a young lawsuit and sit in
the back and just watch it i continue to
watch it i
see the chief
judge of the federal district court
judge barrow howe who
i
i was privileged to have her serve as my
chief counsel
on on this committee
and
learn from her then i learned from her
now
but i also
as a lawyer i hear a lot of talk about
reversal rates
now
no judge has goals without being
reversed somewhere
if they
they never reversed they haven't heard
many cases
but your time in the district
d.c district court less than two percent
of your more than 550
cases were reversed
considering the fact that
the dc circuit reverses an average of 13
percent of the cases
it
and here's
you get a pretty good record and uh
but
what is the judge who's been reversed
what do they take from that reversal
what are they what what do they or what
should they think about it
well you obviously look at it very
carefully um what it means is that um
a panel of judges who've reviewed
what you determined
for
some reason has decided differently and
there are times when
panels of judges decide
differently because they are
making new a new statement about the law
or they're
establishing a standard that um had not
previously
been the case in the area and so you
learn oh this is a new standard now that
i need to apply there are times when you
um
disagree that people can disagree about
the way in which the law works and
that's why we have panels
because people have different judges can
have different perspectives and in good
faith
reach different
results and so
obviously when you're on the trial court
the the court of appeals
uh is binding and they tell you
um in this case no we're gonna
the result is something different and so
you learn
but you know um
anytime i had an opportunity to argue
case at a power level
i don't think i ever thought about
who
nominated or appointed
the judges as before i just want to know
what
i would think about their experience
and i would think about that when i made
the argument not
i don't so leahy has just about three or
four minutes left by my account and then
it will go to lindsey graham which
should be something experience here
you served as a federal trial court
a federal appellate court
judge for almost 10 years
you clerked at all three levels
of the federal judiciary
you practiced law as a federal
public defender in private practice and
i know we uh confirmed you as
a member of the u.s sentencing
commission
this may seem like an easy question but
i just ask you
that you've had such products
experienced but they're all different
in a way
how does that uh how does that shape
your approach when deciding a case
oh
thank you senator um
as i mentioned at the beginning
i have
um
a methodology that i apply when i'm
deciding cases and maybe
my various experiences helped me to get
to the point
of
understanding the importance
of impartiality
staying in my lane as a judge
because the prior experiences
were different roles
in the system
because i saw the different
roles
um i think i have a good appreciation of
what it
means to be a judge and the limitations
on my own authority
the sentencing commission was a
policy-making branch of the judicial
branch
that the the commission
and the commissioners
develop sentencing policy
um
congress delegated that authority to
create the commission and so they're
doing the the policy work gathering data
making recommendations that is totally
different
than the work that i do
as a judge
advocacy
on behalf of your clients
making critical arguments the best
arguments you can come up with
is a service to the court but it's a
totally different thing
than operating as a judge
and so i think that having had those
various experiences i'm now
uh
really mindful
of my role and limitations in the the
judicial branch
well and and the president referred to
you as a proven consensus
builder and i think he was also thinking
of uh
your predecessor justice breyer in that
regard
and i think uh over the years how
important that is even in a body like
the u.s senate i see senator tillis here
he and i have worked together on i.p
issues
senator cornyn
and i on
freedom of information issues senator
grassley
and i and other issues than graham and i
on various issues and
um
and
usually
in the senate at least if you work
across
the ideological spectrum
you get better results
so let me ask you how would you describe
your approach to building consensus on
cases related to issues like
intellectual property
that
are less likely to break up break along
traditional uh ideological lines
thank you
um
thank you senator
one of the things that i
was able to do when i worked on the
sentencing commission
was work
with people who had very different
perspectives than i did about
the criminal justice system and
come to consensus
it's very important as you've said to
try to find common ground and justice so
guys i believe the order is going to be
if it's the same order as yesterday
it'll be lindsay next then a democrat
that i don't remember and then ted cruz
is that is that right or was ted cruz
later
um something i tried to model in my work
on the commission
that i try to model in my work as an
appellate judge and that i would model
or or
do
if i were confirmed to the supreme court
dane thank you chair jordan thank
senator leahy and now senator graham
here we go thank you uh judge
again congratulations i want to talk to
you a little bit about family and faith
because in your opinion statement
and the people who
introduce you to the committee uh that
was very glowing praise of uh you as a
person a good friend
you have a wonderful family you should
be proud and your faith matters to you
what faith are you by the way
senator i am
protestant kind of a weird question
isn't it okay um
name your religion
okay
could you fairly judge a catholic
senator i have a record of i think the
answer would be judging everyone believe
you can i'm just asking this question
because
how important
is your faith to you
senator personally
um
my faith is very important
um but as you know
there's no religious test in the
constitution under under article six and
there will be none with me and
um
what the hell
it's very important to set aside one's
personal views yeah about things
in the role of a judge i couldn't agree
with you more and i believe you can
so uh on a scale of one to ten
how faithful would you say you are oh my
god in terms of religion you know
probably three times a year how
religious are you
or do you do you attend church regularly
well senator i am reluctant to talk
about my
faith in this way just because i want to
be
mindful
of the need for the public to
have confidence in my ability to
separate out my personal views well how
would you feel if a senator up here said
your faith a dogma lives loudly within
you and that's of concern
how would you feel if somebody up here
on our side
said you know you attend church too much
for me or your faith is a little bit
different to me
and they would suggest that it would
affect your decision
would you find that offensive
what
senator i'm i'm i would if i were you
i found it offensive when they said
about judge barrett the reason i ask
these questions is i have no doubt that
your faith is important to you and i
have zero doubt that you can adjudicate
people's cases fairly if they're an
atheist
if i had any doubt i would i would say
so but the only reason i mention this
judge you're reluctant to talk about it
because it's uncomfortable just imagine
what would happen if people
on late night television called you an f
and nut
speaking in tongues because you've
practiced the catholic faith in a way
they uh couldn't quite who are found
uncomfortable
so judge you should be proud of your
faith i am convinced that whatever faith
you have and how often you go to church
it will not affect your ability to be
fair
okay i just hope going in the future
that we all can
accept that
and that judge barrett i thought was
treated very very poorly wasn't she a
member of a cult i just wanted to get
that out let's talk about family wasn't
barrett part of a cult that's roger's
brown
yes i do know her okay how do you know
her
she was a judge on
the court that i now serve we didn't
overlap and i'm
struggling to remember whether i ever
met her but she was
a judge on
circuit court right and you were a
district court judge is that right
i was but i don't know whether she had i
think you were retired are they
interrupting this they are in the same
building okay they are so you really
don't know her
i know of her yes what do you know of
her what's her reputation
um
i know that
she's
a very well respected judge on my
circuit okay
in terms of family she was the daughter
and granddaughter of
sharecroppers
she was raised in alabama under jim crow
despite this adversity she put herself
through law school as a single working
mother that's pretty impressive isn't it
yes senator your background is very
impressive ted cruz is going to have his
work cut out for him
uh if family mattered
we would not have done to her
what was done to her here in the united
states senate do you realize that she
was filibustered for two years
when she was appointed the dc circuit
a porn i didn't
know that did you know that joe biden
actively filibustered janice rogers
brown
i did not know that
did you know that he told face the
nation
if bush
nominates her for the supreme court i
can assure you that would be a very very
very difficult fight
and she probably would be filibustered
is that news to you too
yes okay
now that you know that how do you feel
about
it senator i can't speak to something
that i just learned two seconds ago and
you're okay fair enough conversation
with me fair enough um
you're in the black law school society
all right
at the
law students association okay black law
student association yes you remember at
harvard
yes
and then sometime
the mr jeffries thing do you remember
that whole dust-up
he got
only in um
preparation for this and i think
i was in college at the time it was my
senior year of college okay so you were
actually in the group when he was
invited to speak
i don't know which group um invited him
to speak i was
a black student at harvard
both
in the harvard undergraduate black
students association and the harvard
law school black students association do
you remember going to a speech
given by mr jeffries i think he's the
uncle of king jeffries i did not go to a
speech okay given by mr jeffrey are you
now familiar with her press reports
about what mr jeffrey's views are
just in preparation for this okay and
you do do you associate yourself with
those views i do not senator
as a matter of fact he's been called by
many as very anti-semitic he called you
skunk who's semenik
you don't agree with that do you i do
not senator and it would be wrong for me
or anybody else to hold his statement
against you because he spoke at some
group you're a member of right
senator i don't have
yes it was it would be yeah that that's
right that's the right answer if she
says it's not her views then why would
we talk about him
when they made a big deal about some
group he was in
that had views that he didn't agree with
and tried to call him basically a racist
and found out that senator kennedy god
rest his soul who beat the crap out of
the guy
for being part of some supper club
that was actually in some organization
called the owl
that didn't admit women so i guess the
reason i'm bringing all this up yeah
tell us is it gives me a chance to
remind this committee and america to
grant them two standards going on here
if you're an african-american
conservative woman you're fair game to
have your life turned upside down to be
filibustered no matter how
qualified you are
and if you express your faith as a
conservative all of a sudden you're a
effing nut whoa
and we're tired of it
cementing not gonna happen to you
but it just appalls me
that we can have such a system in
america that if a conservative woman
wants to stand out and say i love my
family just as much as you love yours
lindsay cannot just behave like a normal
person during these hearings have you
guys noticed that no
guy like justice alito who's in the same
type situation you're in being in a
group doesn't agree with everything they
do or what people may say at a meeting
he didn't go to all of a sudden they own
it
you know this stuff needs to stop
our people deserve better respect and i
hope
when this is over people will say you
were
at least well treated even if we don't
agree with you
uh so now let's talk about
gitmo yeah lindsay supported her last
nomination so being a
public defender
did you consider that rewarding
senator
yes
um i did because
public service
is
very important to me it is an important
family value
it is something that
now i've dedicated my career to
yes and do you think it's important to
the system that everybody be represented
absolutely it's a core constitutional
value you'll get no complaint from me
that was my job in the air force i was a
area defense counsel i represented
anybody that came in the door or i liked
them or not i did my best is that what
you did
yes sir
okay good now
so the american people deserve a system
where everybody's represented whether
you like them or not and anybody takes
up that cause
no problem with me you're just doing
your job and i think you make our
country stronger all right but there's
the other side of the story that never
gets mentioned when i talk about gitmo
the american people deserve a system
that can keep terrorists off the
battlefield
they deserve a system that understands
the difference between being at war
and a crime
do you consider 9 11 you said a terrible
tragic event would you consider it an
act of war
yes senator okay i would too i think it
was an act of war about al-qaeda and
associated groups against the people of
the united states
so as you
rightfully are proud of your service as
a public defender
and you represented get mo detainees
which is
part of our system
i want you to understand in the nation
to understand
what's been happening
at gitmo
what's the recidivism rate at gitmo
senator i'm not aware it's 31 percent
how does that strike you
that high low about right i don't i
don't know how it strikes me over yeah i
like me it strikes me it's terrible yes
that's what i was trying to say okay oh
good i found common ground of the 229
detainees
uh released from gitmo of 729 release
229 have gone back to the fight
here's some of the notables
she could also say you know you're
giving me data that i've not
independently confirmed so it's very
hard for me to really comment on numbers
i don't even know if for true
afghanistan
i don't know exactly what his job is
today but during the transition they
made him the defense minister and he was
in gitmo
of the five men we released from gitmo
as part of prisoner swap for sergeant
burgdale
here's the dolls where they're at
mohammed fazal was appointed deputy
minister of defense
noor was appointed acting minister of
borders and tribal affairs
how crazy is it like she had a couple
cases there doesn't mean she knows every
defendant at gitmo you know minister of
information culture defense wild omar
was appointed as new governor of the
southeastern province of coast
these were five people that we had in
our control that are now helping the
taliban run the country would you say
that our system in terms of releasing
people needs to be re-looked at
senator what i'd say is that
that's not a
job for the courts in this way that um
as an american or does that bother you
well
obviously senator any um
repeated criminal behavior or
repeated attacks
acts of war
bother me as an american well it bothers
me while i will not hold it against you
nor should i the fact that you represent
gitmo detainees i think it's time to
look at this system new folks when 31 of
people are going back to fight to kill
americans and
now running the taliban government we
have gone wrong somewhere
are we still at war
um
so the
aumf
the authorization for military force is
still
in effect
congress has authorized uh the use of
force against
people in um in this way
but do you personally believe that
al-qaeda what does it matter
isis-type groups are still at war with
us
wow i think
yes i mean i think we so we're still in
a state of war with certain elements of
radical islam to this very day elements
of bathroom i believe that's documented
yes okay
now
what's the process to determine whether
one's an enemy combatant under our law
well
i believe that the executive branch
makes an
assessment
of whether or not someone is taken up
arms against the united states somewhere
in the world related to all of this
okay
so it's an executive branch function
to determine whether or not this person
qualifies as an enemy combat
well i believe that they make it through
the current law under current law um i
believe that determination is made by
the executive branch and the person is
put into
is detained
um and then the question becomes
whether they
are able to bring some sort of
legal challenge to that they have that
right yes okay so the law is that the
executive branch determines if you're an
enemy combatant
and under our law
you can appeal that decision to a
federal court through habeas is that
correct i believe that's correct okay
is it your view that we can hold enemy
combatants as long as they're a threat
to the united states
um
i believe that's what the supreme court
has determined okay did you argue that
that should not be the case before in an
amica's breathe
i'm trying to think i had two amicus
briefs that i worked on or three
technically but
two different cases
um i will have another visit tomorrow
yes go back and check yes i'm pretty
sure that in your brief you argued that
the executive branch should not have the
ability to hold an enemy combatant and
definitely you need to try
through some process or release them yes
senator as you were
talking i my clients the cato institute
the rutherford institute and the
constitution project
made that argument um and asked me to
draft their brief yes well do you agree
with that argument
senator mike um responsibility was to
make my clients arguments and as a
nominee to the supreme court that's the
kind of issue the supreme court did not
address that issue they in fact
um
the case became moot so did you organize
an effort to get 20 judges to
to file a brief the supreme court on
this issue
not on that issue no on another issue
yes senator okay did you actively go out
and recruit 20 judges
to help you follow brief
on another issue regarding world war
detention
not technically
um what do you mean by that what i mean
is that
i was
at morrison in forster which was my law
firm in the supreme court and appellate
group
one of
the partners at morrison and forrester
was a
former federal judge
who
wanted to make this argument and who
said
we
i have former federal judges who are
friends of mine who would like to join
with me to make this argument
so i worked with her
the partner at my firm who was a former
federal judge
to make it was her idea to get former
judges to write this yes yours yes and
you just helped in the implementation of
that idea
so senator as a member of the supreme
court and appellate group in a law firm
that is the practice right now
yes it wasn't your idea with somebody
else yes okay
uh
so
now
there are people still held at gitmo
today
do do you understand that yes
understand
what system is in place
regarding their future
i am not
aware of the system right now
um i'm not sure exactly let me tell you
what it is yes there's a periodic review
process
and made up of an interagency
where they go through the files of these
folks
and they determine whether or not they
still present a threat to the united
states or the world at large
and i think it's six months maybe a year
but that goes on
at least on an annual basis
and if there's a determination that this
person
still represents a threat to the united
states
they're continued to be confined
that's the way the system works
are you okay with that
okay as a policy matter senator i'm i'm
not speaking to my views that that's my
understanding is that the periodic
review system is an executive branch
determination
of whether or not they're going to
continue to hold people that they that
make sense to you as a way to deal with
these detainees senator i'm not in a
position to speak to the policy or the
discretion of the executive branch
regarding how they're going to handle
detainees the reason i mentioned it is
because some more of the briefs you
argued that the executive branch doesn't
have that option
that if we if you had had your way
the executive branch could not do
periodic reviews about the the danger
the detainee presents to the united
states they would have to make a
decision of trying them or releasing
them
is that not accurate respectfully
senator it was not my argument
i was filing an amicus brief
on behalf of clients including the
rutherford institute the cato institute
and the constitution project
who what when you when you sign on to a
brief does it not become your argument
it does not senator if you are if you
are an attorney
and you are representing a client in
[Music]
uh when you were in private practice
i mean you you sign on to this brief
making this this this is it's not a
perfect analogy but it's like does does
the argument that a defense attorney
makes in a murder case literally
represent like their personal opinion of
what happened i mean like that this is
voluntary nobody's making you do this oh
senator i would i would refer you to the
same sorts of statements that chief
justice roberts made when he came before
the committee which is that lawyers
represent clients i i get that i'm not
holding the clients what an
against you the like that the people you
represent at gitmo they deserve
representation but this is a
amicus brief where you
and other people
try to persuade the court to change
policy
the policy i described is a periodic
review
if the court had taken the position
argued in the brief that you signed upon
we'd have to release these people or try
them in some of them the evidence we
can't disclose because it's classified
you're putting an america in an
untenable position this is not the way
you fight a war if you tried to do this
in world war ii they'd run you out of
town
we hold enemy combatants as long as
they're a threat there's no magic
passage of time that you got to let them
go
so my question is very simple
do you support the idea did you support
then the idea
that indefinite detention of an enemy
combatant is unlawful
respectfully senator
when you are
an attorney
and you have clients who come to you
whether they pay
or not
you represent their positions before the
court
i'm sure i'm sure
everybody at gitmo wants out now i got
that
this is an amicus brief i just don't
understand what you're saying quite
frankly i'm not holding against you
because you represented a legal position
i disagree with
i mean
that happens all the time i'm just
trying to understand what made you
join this cause and you say
it was her job
but
did you feel okay in adopting that cause
i mean
when you signed on to the brief were you
not advocating that position to the
court
senator as a judge now
in order to
determine
the lawfulness or unlawfulness of any
particular issue
i
need to receive
briefs and information making positions
on all sides
did you receive money for some of the
work you did
listen i'm not asking you to decide the
case in front of me right here i'm
asking me to explain a position you took
as a lawyer
regarding the law of war and i am beyond
confused
we can tell i know what you said in your
brief
what i agree with or not is not the
point i just want you to understand that
it's important for all of us to know
where you were coming from if that brief
had been accepted by the court
it would be impossible for us to fight
this war because there's some people
going to die in jail and get mo and
never go to trial for a lot of good
reasons because the evidence again he
doesn't agree with the argument that her
clients were making she wrote the brief
doing is saying that you engaged in
hostile activities against united states
you are an enemy combatant under our law
and you will never be released as long
as you're a danger until the war is over
or you're no longer a danger that's the
difference between fighting a crime and
a war
did you ever accuse in one of your
habeas petitions the government of
acting as war criminals
were holding the detainees
and the holding of the detainees by our
government
that we were acting as war criminals
senator i don't remember that accusation
but i will say that uh you believe
that's true
oh my god that america was acting as war
criminals this is this is painful
holding these detainees
senator the supreme court held that
the executive branch has the authority
to detain people who are designated as
enemy combatants
um for the duration of the hostilities
and
what
i was
doing in the context of the habeas
petitions at this very early stage in
the process
was making allegations
to preserve issues on behalf of my
clients
a habeas petition is like a
complaint
that
lawyers make allegations i've been a
lawyer too but i don't think it's
necessary to call the government or war
criminal in pursuing charges against a
terrorist could someone ask for her not
to be interrupted maybe i don't know why
he chose those words
that's just too far
but
we are where we are
so let's talk about um
the nomination process i think he has
like three minutes have you ever had any
interaction with a group called demand
justice
no
directly or indirectly no
uh have you ever had an interaction with
a group called american prospect
no do you know anything about uh our
our bella is that the right term
have you ever heard of a group called
arbella
i've heard of a group that i think is
arabella or something like that you're
right yes
do you know anything about them have you
had any contact with them no
well i'm still gonna attack uh in
your nomination did you notice that
people from the left were pretty much
cheering you on
a lot of people were cheering me on
something
that's true
did you know that a lot of people from
the left were trying to destroy michelle
charles did you notice that
senator a lot of people were supporting
various people for this nomination
so you're saying you didn't know there
was a concerted effort
to why would it matter disqualified
judge charles from south carolina
because she was a
union busting
unreliable republican in disguise
no senator senator i
was
i'm a sitting judge i was focused on my
cases
no i didn't know that no i didn't know
that would it bother you if sir uh that
that happened
not if it were true senator
it is troublesome that people
are or were doing things related to
i think that's the best way to say it
people have a right to speak out and
pick the person of their choice
but all i can say is that if you miss
the fact
that there was an organized effort well
here's president biden has only a
certain amount of political capital for
keeping his party united if he
needlessly angers progresses on this
have we learned anything from lindsay's
questions for him down the line jeff
houser revolving door
projects uh let's see
hmm
we've learned a lot about him yeah i
just got so many quotes
it's difficult to imagine someone with a
record like judge charles winning votes
from criminal justice advocates like
your view is that the hearing is to
assess
this nominee's qualifications what third
parties said about someone who wasn't
nominated doesn't seem relevant to her
let's just let's see
picking her child's would demoralize the
base side with corporate america the
fact that lindsey graham is vouching
bearer should give the white house pause
our revolution
joseph
jerivanji or whatever his name is i'm
sorry about that joseph he's bernie
sanders pac director
you didn't know that all these people
were declaring war on judge charles
senator i did not okay
well
no i'm i'm not saying you did and you
said you didn't know i should say i'm
here to to give my views on my
qualifications has nothing to do with me
what is your judicial philosophy
so i have a methodology that i use in my
cases in order to ensure that i am
uh ruling impartially you should repeat
the same three points your judicial
philosophy is to rule impartially no my
judicial philosophy is to rule
impartially and to rule consistent with
the limitations on my authority as a
judge and so my methodology
actually helps me to do that in every
case so you wouldn't say that you're an
activist judge
i would not say that okay
and so we'll have a 20 minutes more
later on but here's what i would say
every group that wants to pack the court
that believes this court is a bunch of
right wing nuts are going to destroy
america that's true that considered the
constitution trash
all wanted you picked
and this is all i can say
is the fact that so many of these
left-wing radical groups that would
destroy the law as we know it declared
war on michelle chiles and supported you
is problematic for me
thank you
thank you senator graham let me mention
a few points here
congressman jim clyburn was a strong
supporter of michelle childs and now i
believe he is publicly supporting your
nomination
and michelle childs has been nominated
by president biden
to be a circuit judge and she will be
considered by this committee as quickly
as possible
on the issue of guantanamo there are
currently 39 guantanamo detainees
remaining
the annual budget for guantanamo is 540
million dollars per year
which means each of these detainees
is being held at the expense of 12 or 13
million dollars per year wow if they
would be incarcerated at florence
colorado the super max prison federal
prison the amount would be dramatically
dramatically less
since 911 nearly 1 000 convicted in the
united states on terrorism charges
since 2009
with the beginning of the obama
administration the recidivism rate of
guantanamo detainees released is five
percent
mr chairman according to the department
director of national intelligence is 31
somebody is wrong here if you're going
to talk about what i said i'm going to
respond to what you said if we close
gitmo and move them to colorado do you
support indefinite detention under the
law of war for these detainees i would
just say uh i'm giving the facts and the
answer is no i want to make sure that
it's clear the 31 you referred to goes
back to the year
2000 what does it matter when it goes
back to we had them and they got loose
and they started killing people did not
lose i could just say that if you're one
of the people killed in 2005 does it
matter to you when we release
that the president of your own party
released him and
i'm suggesting the system has failed
miserably and advocates to change this
system like she was it
was was advocating would destroy our
ability to protect this country we're at
war we're not fighting a crime this is
not some passage of time event as long
as they're dangerous i hope they all die
in jail if they're gonna go back and
kill americans it won't bother me one
bit if 39 of them die in prison that's a
better outcome to let them go and if it
costs 500 million to keep them in jail
keep them in jail because they're gonna
go back to the fight look at the
freaking afghan government it's made up
of detainees
[Music]
this whole
thing by the left about this war ain't
worth it
let me also note that larry thompson who
served as deputy attorney general under
president todd what a clown
what a clown counsel
viet den who served as assistant
attorney general for legal policy in the
george w bush administration john
bellinger and former d.c circuit judge
associate general and independent
counsel ken stone i think he just rage
quit prominent conservative lawyers
signing a letter defending attorneys who
represented guantanamo bay detainees
i don't believe that
we should associate
uh that activity as being inconsistent
with our constitutional values
we are going to represent are going to
this point recognize senator feinstein
and then take a break after she has
completed her questioning senator
feinstein thank you very much all right
everybody i'm going to step away briefly
i'll be back during the break and we'll
talk and hear from some of you guys then
we'll get to ted cruz but we will
continue here a bit of a tough place so
a judge
one of the issues that i often discuss
with nominees particularly to the
supreme court is the issue of abortion
i've asked the three most recent supreme
court nominees about this issue and so
i'd like to discuss it a bit with you
today
in 2017 i asked justice gorsuch about
this during his confirmation hearing i
asked him to expand on a comment he had
made about his belief that precedent is
important because it adds stability to
the law
in response justice gorsuch reiterated
his belief that precedent is important
because and i quote once a case is
settled that adds to the determinancy of
the law end quote he also stated that
roe has been reaffirmed many times
i also spoke with judge kavanaugh about
this issue in
i asked him whether he believes that roe
was settled raw
and if so whether it was correctly
settled
justice kavanaugh said
that roe quote is settled as a precedent
of the supreme court end quote
he said that row quote has been
reaffirmed many times over the past 45
years
and most prominently most importantly
reaffirmed in planned parenthood v casey
end quote and he described casey as
having the value of a precedent on
precedent end quote i most recently
spoke about this issue with justice
barrett in 2020
i asked her whether she agreed with
justice scalia's view
that roe was wrongly decided
she committed to quote
obey all the rules of starry decisis end
quote
if faced with the question of whether to
overrule casey she said she had quote no
agenda to try to overrule casey end
quote so here's the question
do you agree
with justice kavanaugh that roe v wade
is settled as a precedent
and will you like justice barrett commit
to obey all the rules of starry decisis
in cases related to the issue of
abortion end quote
thank you senator
i do agree
with
both justice kavanaugh and justice
barrett on this issue
roe
and casey are
the settled law of
the supreme court concerning the right
to terminate a woman's pregnancy
they have established a framework that
the court has reaffirmed
and
in order to revisit
as justice barrett said
the supreme court
looks at various factors because
starry decisis is a very important
principle
it provides and establishes
predictability stability
it also serves as as a restraint in this
way on the exercise of judicial
authority
because the court
looks at
whether or not
precedents are
relied upon whether they're workable
um
in addition to whether or not they're
wrong
um and and other factors as well so i
agree with
uh both of those statements that you
read
well let me add one to that and then
we'll move on
um
i'm particularly interested in the case
of roe v wade
roe was decided by nearly nearly 50
years ago
and it's been reaffirmed over a dozen
times since then
so my question is this
does roe v wade have the status of being
a case that is a super precedent and
what other supreme court cases do you
believe have that status
well senator
all supreme court cases are presidential
they're binding
and
um they their principles and their
rulings have to be followed
rowe
and casey um as you say have been
reaffirmed by the court and
um
have been relied upon and reliance is
one of the
factors that the court considers when it
seeks to
revisit or when it's asked to revisit
revisit a precedent and in all cases
those the precedents of the supreme
court would have to be
reviewed
uh pursuant to
those factors because starry decisis is
very important
thank you
if you are confirmed you would be one of
only two justices who has also served on
a federal district court the other being
justice sotomayor
in your eight years as a trial judge on
the d.c district court you wrote nearly
600 opinions and presided over nine jury
trials and three bench trials
as you know from your service on the
district court it's important for
appeals courts and especially the
supreme court to be clear in their
decisions the clarity is necessary as
you well know for trial judges to
effectively do their job and properly
apply legal precedents that are fair and
consistent
as a district judge you were responsible
for applying precedent
from the supreme court and the courts of
appeal to your case and now as a judge
in the d.c circuit you're drafting those
precedents
your experience as a trial judge
is one of your most significant assets
and i just want to add a personal
comment this is a tough place
and you are handling it very well
and i appreciate your directness
uh and think that's important here's a
question i have two related questions
how did you make sure
that you were properly applying the
relevant precedence as a district court
judge and if you're confirmed to the
supreme court what would you do
to make sure your opinions are clear
so they could be applied correctly by
district courts
thank you senator
as you noted
in my time as a district court judge i
had
the opportunity to
apply
precedents that
were handed down by the court of appeals
and the supreme court
uh the district court is bound by the
law as stated
by those other tribunals and
i was
very
focused on making sure
that i found the right precedence and
applied them faithfully
as i mentioned with respect to my
methodology
part of the process is receiving
information from the parties
in a case and the parties write briefs
and uh in most cases they identify
the precedents that they at least
believe are applicable
and then
the court does its own legal research as
well
to
determine whether all of the relevant
cases have been identified
and then
you
look to see
whether there's anything that directly
controls and if it does that's your
answer
in many cases
the precedence might be
a little bit different in certain ways
and you are assessing the party's
arguments and determining within your
proper role
whether what the appellate courts have
said
provides the law of decision for the
case
but what's important as you've mentioned
is
the clarity by which
courts of appeals in the supreme court
need to operate and so so that the lower
courts can actually follow
the precedence and i'm very conscious of
that as you said as someone who has
had to follow precedent
and i would
think carefully about that and
use um
use my communication skills to ensure
that
the precedents are clear so that lower
courts can follow them
thank you
um i'd like to
discuss quickly a letter this committee
received in support of your nomination
from the international association of
chiefs of police
and as you know this is the world's
largest professional association of law
enforcement leaders
and the letter states
judge jackson has several family members
in law enforcement and we believe this
has given her a deep understanding of
and an appreciation for the challenges
and complexities confronting the
policing profession
during her time as a judge she has
displayed her dedication to ensuring
that our communities are safe and that
the interests of justice are served and
so mr chairman i'd like to put this
letter in the record if i may
without objection thank you
i understand that your brother served
with the baltimore police department for
several years
so here's the question
how if at all
has having several family members in law
enforcement
impacted your understanding of the law
or your approach to your judicial
service
thank you senator
some of my
earliest memories in addition to
my father at the kitchen table with his
law books
um
were of my uncles two of my uncles were
career law enforcement
and um
one was a detective
uniform detective one was
city of miami police department
officer patrol officer for a long time
before he became the chief and
i remember very well
we would go to my grandmother's house on
sundays and
she would make a big dinner for our
family and my uncles would sometimes
come
off of their shifts
so i see in my mind their uniforms
coming in
and they would always
they'd be carrying their weapons and
they'd take them off and put them way up
high on the china cabinet so the kids
couldn't get to them and i remember
feeling very proud of them and the
service that they
um provided and i think it's probably
what led my brother
who is 10 years younger than i am to
decide that after he graduated from
college he would want to also be in law
enforcement so i'm
very familiar
with
law enforcement the important service
that they provide
the perils
of
being
out on the street protecting and serving
and having a family that cares about you
and worries
about your
safety
and so this is not something that is
that is unfamiliar and i'm very
gratified by
the support of
the group that you mentioned in other
law enforcement groups
as i go through this process
i joined this committee in january of
and a few months later we considered the
nomination of ruth bader ginsburg to the
supreme court
justice ginsburg's confirmation
made her only the second woman to ever
serve on the supreme court after justice
sandra day o'connor so we have come a
very long way since then though still
not far enough
women now make up
about 35 percent of active judges on the
federal district bench and 37 percent of
active judges on the federal appeals
courts
judge jackson if confirmed you would
become the sixth woman to ever serve on
the supreme court
you would join justices sotomayor kagan
and barrett on the bench this would be
the nearest we have ever come to gender
equity on the supreme court there would
be four women on a court with nine
justices
so i have my own thoughts about why
gender balance is important on our
nation's courts but i'd really like
you to tell us all what are your
thoughts
on what it means for our country to have
women serve in meaningful members
meaning
meaningful numbers on the federal bench
and in particular what it would mean to
have four women serving on the supreme
court for the first time in history
thank you senator um
i think it's extremely meaningful
one of the things that
having
diverse members of the court
does is it provides for the opportunity
for role models
since i was nominated to this position
i have received so many notes and
letters and
photos from
little girls around the country
who
tell me
that they are so
excited
for this opportunity and that they have
thought about the law in new ways
um
because i am a woman because i am a
black woman
all of those things
people have said have been really
meaningful to them and and
we want i think as a country for
everyone
to believe that they can do
things like sit on the supreme court and
so having
meaningful numbers of
women and
people of color i think matters
i also think that it it
it supports public confidence
in the judiciary
when you have
uh different
people because we have such a diverse
society
well i just want to say thank you very
much
this is often a hard place
and how you go through those hard times
i really think
is
the most important thing
and it's pretty clear to me that you go
through hard times by holding your head
up high and doing well so i thank you
very much thank you senator
thank you uh senator feinstein we're
going to take a break uh let's see let's
take 15 minutes starting now and then
we'll return to more questions we'll
have a lunch break this later this
afternoon
in the earlier part of the afternoon
okay
oh
[Music]
every hour
are you happy
okay
[Music]
right what are you here
so the first of a number of breaks we're
expecting today during the second day of
the confirmation hearing for judge
katanji brown jackson each committee
senator getting 30 minutes to question
the nominee
and we'll resume with our live coverage
after this recess which should last
about
another 10 minutes or so
with questions from senator john cornyn
so while this break is underway
republicans have voiced concerns about
judge jackson's record on sentencing of
child pornography criminal criminals
here's what she had to say earlier today
in response to that issue as posed by
judiciary committee chair dick durbin
another issue that came up yesterday in
the opening
phase of this
nomination hearing
and it's the issue involving child
pornography
i want to turn to that issue because it
was raised multiple times primarily by
the senator from missouri
and it was he was questioning your
sentencing record in child pornography
cases
that do not involve the production of
pornographic material they're known as
non-production cases
i wanted to put some context here
the senator from missouri has in his
tweets said of your position on this
issue
judge jackson has a pattern of letting
child porn offenders off the hook for
their appalling crimes both as a judge
and a policy maker
she's been advocating it since law
school
this goes beyond soft on crime the
senator said i'm concerned this is a
record that endangers our children
i thought about his charges as i watched
you and your family
listening carefully yesterday
and what impact it might have had on you
personally to know that your daughters
husband
parents
family and friends were hearing the
charges that your
implementation of this law sentencing
endangered children
could you tell us what was going through
your mind at that point
thank you senator um
as a mother
and a judge who has had
to deal with these cases
i was thinking
that nothing could be further from the
truth
these are some of the most
difficult cases that a judge has to deal
with because we're talking about
pictures
of
sex abuse of children
we're talking about graphic descriptions
that judges have to read and consider
when they decide
how to sentence in these cases and
there's a statute
that tells judges what they're supposed
to do congress has decided
what it is that a judge has to do in
this and any other case when they
sentence
and that statute
that statute doesn't say
look
only at the guidelines and stop the
statute doesn't say
impose
the highest possible penalty for this
sickening and egregious crime
the statute says
calculate the guidelines but also look
at
various aspects of this offense and
impose a sentence that is quote
sufficient but not greater than
necessary
to promote the purposes of punishment
and in every case
when i am dealing with something like
this it is important to me
to make sure that the children's
perspective the children's voices
are represented in my sentencings
and what that means is that for every
defendant who comes before me and who
suggests as they often do
that they're just a looker that these
crimes don't really matter they've
collected these things on the internet
and it's fine
i tell them about
the victim statements that have come in
to me
as a judge
i tell them about the
adults
who are former child sex abuse victims
who tell me that they
will never have a normal adult
relationship
because of this abuse
i tell them about the ones who say i
went into prostitution i
fell into drugs because i was trying to
suppress the hurt
that was done to me
as an as an infant
and the one that was the most
um
telling to me that i
describe at almost every one of these
sentencings when i look in the eyes of a
defendant who is weeping because i'm
giving him
a significant sentence what i say to him
is do you know that there is someone who
is written to me
and who has told me that she has
developed agoraphobia she cannot leave
her house
because she thinks that everyone she
meets
will have seen her
will have seen her pictures on the
internet they're out there forever
at the most vulnerable time of her life
and so she's paralyzed
i tell that story to every
child porn defendant
as a part of my sentencings so that they
understand what they have done five six
seven eight nine ten
nine eight seven six five four three two
one
and that testimony from earlier today
the hearing in a break now it will
continue in about four minutes or so at
about 11 45
nbc news reporter sahil kapoor
highlights and tweets this senator
patrick leahy casually noting that he
has voted on 20 supreme court nominees
over his time in the senate his first
one was for john paul stevens a gerald
ford nominee back in 1975. senator leahy
is 81 years old and he did announce last
november that he'll be retiring at the
end of this term
senate judiciary committee questioning
of supreme court nominee judge katanji
brown-jackson expected to resume here
shortly on c-span we'll hear questions
next posed by texas senator john cornyn
and a right reminder that you can also
watch on our website cspan.org or via
our
c-span now mobile app
um
all right
it is now
once again
um
wow
all right so this is actually not the
main lunch break apparently this is just
a short break and i believe that cancun
ted cruz is next so we are going to
um stand by here correct me if i'm wrong
i again i believe that that's the order
um
very nice super chat from danny who says
thank you for streaming this event just
signed up for my third annual membership
on your website this year
per my own new year's resolution what
you do matters
and you're my favorite content creator
thank you i really appreciate that and i
want to say thanks to everybody who's
been supporting the stream jen here
and merklist
the real mr joshua and all of these
great great people over on my website
there it is danny thompson using today's
coupon code fix the court we must fix we
must repair the court and i really
appreciate it today is our second day of
coverage of the confirmation hearings of
judge kitanji brown jackson and
expecting it to get even wackier when we
hear from ted cruz marsha blackburn josh
hawley tom cotton
is james lankford on this committee i i
keep forgetting lankford
judiciary committee let me see if he is
um
yeah i believe he is yeah
okay yeah so that's all happening and i
invite you i invite you
to sign up today at
joinpackman.com it really does make a
difference it's our number one source of
funding and we provide the daily program
commercial free
six hours earlier six hours earlier to
our members than to everybody else isn't
is there anything better than everybody
else getting screwed and of course
that's a joke that's the exact opposite
of course of my uh
political uh ideology
and philosophy
but sometimes we make jokes on the uh on
the channel
let's see
do we have
any other voicemails that have come in
that are relevant
no we don't unfortunately i have 1210
unlistened to voicemails this is the
most we've ever had at one time
um on the on the voicemail line and it
is what it is folks it is what it is
i mean listen whitney just left this
voicemail i don't think it has anything
to do with the hearings
so i was reading about ukraine
supporting notary
um
hillary is like on the side of like
transfect because
i just feel like if you support like
trans rights the same as like supporting
child molesters
it actually by the way it might be mike
lee who's next i don't remember if it's
lea cruz
and i just don't support it because like
they're mutilating little kids like i
saw a little boy i don't know what that
that's about
robert says sir just a mental health
check on how the ukraine war images
affected you
i i don't think i was any more affected
by them than anybody else so i mean i
don't know
they were obviously horrifying images
but
let's see what else i've got here
um yeah there's a lot of
hold on
yeah there's a lot of stuff here
let me just see if i can get my
media twitter up
here for us
uh oh boy
here's a republican rapid response on
the hearings
crt wow
wow
very special
blackburn oh let's see what she
previewed she serves on a school board
and has lauded progressive education
now
for some of the women that i talk to
that is a red flag they want answers on
that so we'll as i said yesterday in my
opening we will discuss this with her
that should be interesting listen
these republicans are
bringing in lines of questioning that
are truly wacky
but
judge jackson has to be prepared and she
did stumble a little bit like lindsay
lindsay's questions were absurd
but she needs some lines to be able to
explain why they're absurd why they're
hypocritical and why they are completely
irrelevant to her qualifications to be
on the court okay so
important that this that's the way it
needs to go
break for lunch
somewhere around an hour from
senators cornyn and white house will be
recognized in succession first senator
cornyn oh cornyn's going first okay
thank you mr chairman
judge i won't want you to do me a favor
um will you nerd out with me a little
bit uh-oh
uh please pursue
we'll we'll start with starry decisis
yes and i've never figured out why
lawyers speak in latin rather than
starry decisis is the less well-known
counterpart to starry night the very
famous painting
but would you agree with me that um even
under
an appropriate starry decisis
uh
analysis that dred scott and plessy
versus ferguson were appropriately
overruled by the supreme court
well senator um
i'm not engaged in the actual analysis
but i think it is well established
now
um that the cases
um that overruled
uh dred scott and plessy were um
correctly decided
yeah i mean there is the means by which
the courts can correct their mistakes
correct by overruling
previous decisions
if the various considerations that the
supreme court has
uses to make that determination
satisfied have you ever heard a federal
judge talk about super
duper president or super president
i have not i've never seen it either in
any opinion i've heard it here in the
judiciary committee on a number of
occasions when somebody has a favorite
case or outcome that they don't want to
see the supreme court revisit
um
let me ask a minute obviously you're uh
nomination by president biden is
historic
and i congratulate you again
congratulated you previously and i think
it's been long overdue
when clarence thomas
the second african-american
who was nominated to and confirmed by
the supreme court
was nominated the court did you
celebrate that as a historic event
i'm trying to remember where i was at
the time i believe i did yes
when we're talking about staying in your
lane
uh and i appreciate
your responses to a number of the
questions even though i'd love to get
your answer to the question but where
you've deferred answering saying you
want to stay in your lane and not be
seen as a policy maker
would you agree with me that one of the
most important questions under our
constitutional form of government and
the separation of powers is
who decides
in other words some questions are
appropriately decided by judges who are
elected or unelected excuse me serve for
life
i'm going to refresh once just for the
purposes of the sink if it's still
unsynced just refresh my feed guys left
up to the legislative branch because
they are
we are accountable to the people who can
vote for us they can vote against us uh
if they don't like the policies that we
that we enact in legislation would you
agree with that who decides is an
important
question
in terms of determining the appropriate
role for both the judiciary and the
legislature
as a general matter i agree it rarely
comes
directly like that as an issue it's it's
it's usually not a jump ball between
um between the legislature and i get it
you don't get a lot of easy
easy questions
um but you as a general proposition you
won't uh disagree with me
what i'd say is that
the courts
are properly tasked with resolving legal
questions and cases are controversies
right exactly in every case and
congress is not similarly constrained we
can pass broad policies comprehensive
legislation
changing policy but
the difference is one of the differences
is the voters can unelect us if they
don't like what we're doing
that is true
i want to ask you what did you study
under lawrence tribe when you were at
harvard i did not
well as you know justice breyer your
mentor wrote a little book called active
liberty
and um
lawrence tribe
who uh was a formerly a law professor at
harvard wrote a review of that book in
the new york times review of books
and the title of it is politicians and
robes
are you familiar with that article i am
not
well
in the article
professor tribe accuses
justice breyer of engaging in what he
calls a noble lie
and he said
he talks about the morality of resorting
to falsehoods
and delusions to conceal usually from
the masses
but sometimes from oneself the truths
whose revelation would wreak havoc or at
least do more harm than good
professor tribe goes on in criticizing
justice breyer's book
he says in his stubborn stubborn of a
vowel that the court
even with its current far-right super
majority judge if there were really two
of every animal on noah's ark what did
the carnivorous animals eat
but noble
you've talked about
staying in your lane not making policy
decisions not being seen as political do
you agree with justice breyer that
or with professor tribe
senator um
i believe that judges are not
policymakers that
we have
a constitutional duty
to decide only cases and controversies
that are presented before us and within
that framework
uh judges
exercise their authority to
interpret the law and not make the law
so you would you would agree with me
that which of these two opinions the one
from a book you didn't read or an
article you didn't read do you agree
with
let me talk to you a little bit about
some of the
decisions that have been made by the
supreme court over many years starting
perhaps with dred dredd scott
that
adopts the
substantive due process
argument
to determine the constitutionality
of
various laws
perhaps the most recent
decision by the supreme court that was a
dramatic departure from uh from previous
laws in the states and in the nation
was the oberfeld case
which uh dealt with same-sex marriage
in the opinions that were written there
it was noted that here we are 200 at the
time 234 years
after the constitution had been ratified
135 years since the 14th amendment had
been ratified
that
the supreme court articulated a new
fundamental right
which is a right to same-sex marriage
you're familiar with that case aren't
you
i am
at the time it was noted that 11 states
including the district of columbia had
had passed laws
sanctioning same-sex marriage
but also at the same time there were 35
states
who put it on the ballot and 32 of those
decided to maintain the traditional
definition of marriage between a man
and a woman oh boy
do you agree with me that marriage is
not simply a governmental
institution it's also a religious
institution
well senator um
marriages are often performed in
religious institutions
so the answer here is as it pertains to
government's involvement it is it is not
a religious consideration
christianity judaism
judaism
embrace a traditional definition of
marriage correct yeah
only the most orthodox jewish
congregations so even the framing is
dishonest
in a traditional way
wow
lunatic do you um do you see that when
the supreme court
makes a
dramatic pronouncement about the
invalidity
of state
marriage laws
that it will inevitably set in conflict
between those who ascribe to the supreme
court's edict and those who have a
firmly held religious belief
that marriage is between a man and a
woman
well senator
these
issues are being litigated as you know
throughout the courts as people
um
raise
issues and so it's i'm limited in what i
i can say about them i'm aware that
there are
cases
i'm not asking you to decide a case or
predict how you would decide in the
future i'm just asking isn't it apparent
that when the supreme court
decides that
something that is not even in the
constitution
is a fundamental right and no state
can pass any law
that conflicts with the supreme court's
edict
particularly in an area where people
have sincerely held religious beliefs
doesn't that necessarily create a
conflict between
what people may believe is a matter of
their no religious doctrine churches can
still consider marriage whatever they
want but legally same-sex marriage is
the law of the land
well senator that is the nature of a
right that
when there is a right
it means that
there are
limitations on regulation even if
people
are regulating pursuant to their
sincerely held religious beliefs
you agree with marriage is not mentioned
in the constitution is it
it is not mentioned directly no and um
religious
freedom and
um
is mentioned in the first amendment
explicitly correct it is the government
recognizing gay marriage doesn't violate
anyone's religious freedom do you share
my concern that when the
court
takes on the role of identifying
an unenumerated right in other words
it's not mentioned in the constitution
and creates a new
right
declaring that anything conflicting with
that is unconstitutional that it creates
a circumstance where those who may hold
traditional beliefs like
something as important as marriage
that they will be
vilified
as unwilling to assent to this new
orthodoxy vilified is not a legal
question so senator i understand that
concern and because there are cases that
are addressing these sorts of issues i'm
not in a position to comment about
either my personal views or whether i'm
not asking and i'm not asking you to um
i mean
justice alito in the
in the oberfeld
case
wrote he said i assume those who cling
to the old beliefs will be able to
whisper their thoughts in the recesses
of their homes
but if they repeat those views in public
they will risk being labeled as bigots
and treated as such by government that's
the case either way and schools
so the oberfeld case we
to nerd out with you again
was um was decided under a doctrine
known as substantive due process correct
if memory serves i um yes substantive
due process and i think there might have
been equal protection concerns and
the court the supreme court has uh
applied that some
how mis
fairly mysteriously
by saying it's
created by the confluence of the fifth
amendment
and the 14th amendment
to the united states constitution
but historically it's been applied
in ways that
seem to sanction
explicit policymaking
by the courts
for example
the the lochner versus new york case
which i know you talked to senator lee
about in particular
which it was a new deal case which set
limitations on how long bakers could
work in new york
the supreme court struck that down and
said that violated the right of free
contract
now lochner as you know was overruled
30 something years later but it's also
been applied in a number of different
circumstances
for example
it's been suggested that dred scott
which treated
slaves as chattel property
was a product of substantive due process
justice hugo black
has criticized the doctrine of
substantive due process
as the arbitrary fiat
of the man or men in power
or the court declaring a law invalid
because it shocked the consciences of at
least five members
of the court
please proceed we went on to say this
use of judicial review
thus subverts the liberty of government
by the people
overturning laws and enacted by
legislators legislatures who are ansible
to the electorate rather than a majority
of the supreme court
finally he said
finally for the purpose of my question
he said the adoption of such a loose
flexible
uncontrolled standard for holding laws
unconstitutional if ever it is finally
achieved
will amount to a great unconstitutional
shift of power to the courts which i
believe
justice black that is
and am constrained to say will be bad
for the courts and worse for the country
judge justice jackson why isn't
substantive due process analysis
just another form of judicial
policymaking
which you've suggested policy making is
not
in your lane or and you strive to be
apolitical something i
i applaud but why is isn't substantive
due process just another way for judges
to hide their policy making under the
guise of interpreting the constitution
well senator
the justices have interpreted
the due process clause of the 14th
amendment
to include a substantive provision the
the
the rights
to due process they have interpreted
that
to me not just procedural rights
relative to government action
but also the protection of certain
personal
rights related to
intimacy and autonomy they include
things like
the the right to rear one's children
i believe the right to travel
the right to marriage
um
interracial marriage
the right
uh to an abortion
the contraception treating uh treating
slaves as chattel property
i'm i don't quite remember the basis for
the
dred scott opinion but but i'll trust
you that that's what the the fact is is
it not that you can use substantive due
process to justify basically any result
well the court whether it's conservative
or liberal libertarian or
conservative whatever you would like to
call it's just a it's a mode of analysis
by the court that allows the court to
substitute its opinion
for the elected representatives of the
people and um
and
would you agree
the court
has
uh identified standards for the
determination of rights under the 14th
amendment substantive due process and
who who gives them the right to to do
that
if it's not mentioned in the
constitution
where does the right of the court to
substitute its views for that of the
elected representatives of the people
where does that come from
well the court has interpreted
the 14th amendment to include this
component
the unenumerated
right to substantive due process and the
court has said that
that the kinds of things that qualify
are
implicit in the concept of order ordered
liberty liberty excuse me
or deeply rooted in our nation's history
and tradition
um those are standards that identify a
narrow
set of
activities well judge judge the
in the oberfeldt case
justice roberts in his dissent noted
that
the court invalidated marriage laws of
more than half the states and orders the
transformation of a social institution
that has formed the basis for human
society for millennia
so
that was the
basis for
the institution of marriage is the
practice
for millennia
and the recognition that
marriage was between a man and a woman
now don't get me wrong i'm not arguing
the merits or lack of merits of same-sex
marriage i believe the states no about
that and the elect
and the voters can choose what they will
and that's their prerogative and i think
that's legitimate but when the court
overrules
the decisions made by the people as they
did in 32 of the 35 states that decided
to im
to uh to
recognize only traditional marriage
between a man and a woman
uh
that is a act of judicial policy making
is it not
senator the supreme court has
considered that to be an application of
the substantive due process clause of
the 14th amendment right and it doesn't
the scot the
constitution doesn't mention anything
about substance when it talks about due
process the fourth
14th amendment and the fifth amendment
don't talk about substantive due process
it talks about due process of law
correct correct
well
one of the things that concerns me is
here is an example
of
the courts finding a new fundamental
right
that is mentioned nowhere
in the document of the constitution
that's the product of simply court made
law
that we're all supposed to salute
smartly
and follow because nine people
who are unelected
who have lifetime tenure
whose salary cannot be reduced while
they serve in office
they do sounds like he's not a big fan
of the supreme court way the world
should be
what other unenumerated rights
do you believe exist
and how
could we possibly anticipate what those
might be for example
the ninth amendment
says the enumeration in the constitution
of certain rights shall not be construed
to deny or disparage
other rights
retained by the people
which suggests to me that there are
other as yet unidentified
rights out there and somehow some
someday
some court is going to tell us we've
identified an unenumerated right and
we're going to reject the right of the
american people to determine what the
policies ought to be
as regards that right because we
the nine people sitting on the supreme
court have decided
we've discovered a new unenumerated
right and it shall be the law of the
land and no legislature
can pass any law that conflicts with it
what other unenumerated rights are out
there
or can you say
senator i can't say um
it's a hypothetical that i've
not i'm not in a position to comment on
insane questions
the the rights that the supreme court
has
recognized as
substantive due process rights
um
are established in in its case law
your honor this is not a trick question
oh i understand okay i'm just not i'm
just not in a position to speak to
the what can you understand right to
ring pop senator i mean what the hell do
you want her to say
ordinary folks
wonder
who do these people think they are
and where does this authority come from
i think the authority comes
from
we the people that's the source of
legitimacy of government but when the
courts decide to identify an
unenumerated right
and negate
anything that conflicts with it can't
you see how
they might just might feel that this is
illegitimate
she's not creating the court she's just
potentially going to be a justice
that you have
disavowed
by saying that you don't want to make
policy you want to stay in your lane can
you understand the concern
absolutely senator i do understand it
and how do you
and how because i believe the court's
legitimacy is very important
that's why i agree with justice breyer
that notwithstanding what anybody else
says
that that should be an aspirational goal
of the judges because
we're all concerned about the legitimacy
of our institutions
and particularly i would say the
institution of our judiciary
so how do how do you as a judge when you
are approaching
your decisions
how do you
try to avoid
being seen as a policy maker by
embracing doctrines like
substantive due process which is
essentially gives judges carte blanche
to do whatever they want
well senator i've
not had that particular situation but i
do
i have a methodology that is designed to
avoid
my
importation of
policy perspectives
the judges
are constrained in our system that's
part of the constitutional design
and so
in all cases i am
looking
neutrally at the arguments of the
parties and presumably in a case like
this there would be arguments made on
both sides of the issue
your honor if you'll forgive me yes
one reason
i think the supreme court's different
it's because in your previous capacity
as a trial judge of course you were
bound by circuit court precedent
and on the circuit court you're bound by
the supreme court president
but as a member of the united states
supreme court you will be bound by
nothing the answer to just about every
question is if amy covet barrett and
kavanaugh are on the court then i can be
on the court too so
you said you can well respectfully
senator i mean
yes so
you're not going to be able to find the
answer in some law book somewhere you're
going to be presented with a case and
the argument's going to be made this is
an unenumerated fundamental right
and the voters
whatever they've said is irrelevant
because we five members of the supreme
court are going to decide what the law
of the land should be and anybody who
disagrees this is worse than my callers
at getting to the actual question
or be accused of discrimination
even if those their beliefs happen to
flow from sincerely held religious
conviction like the definition of a
of a marriage between a man and a woman
but you've already told me that you
unders you see why the this is a concern
i see why it is a concern and i would
just say that although the supreme court
is not
you know
bound in the sense of having to apply
prior precedent there is starry decisis
in our system
there are now standards in the starry
decisis world that the supreme court
applies
when it
when it's it's asked to
um
well thank goodness
the supreme court has been willing to
revisit its precedent
or we'd still be living
with plessy versus ferguson
or dred scott right you know one of the
things senator whitehouse and i agree on
is
he he and others frequently ask nominees
for the supreme court do you think
brown versus board of education has
settled law
and believe it or not some nominees
won't answer the question
i mean it boggles the mind
i tend to think that uh nominees from
both parties tend to be over coached
and not uh and told you can't be
if you don't answer the question you
have a better chance of being confirmed
but some of these things are
obviously settled
and i wish we had a more candid
conversation about the the source of the
power that unelected lifetime tenured
judges have to basically rule
rule america when they decide that
something is an unenumerated
fundamental right
let me uh
in the minute 48 seconds i have
asked you about a specific case
you remember u.s versus brown
this was a guilty plea
and where you were asked to
assess a punishment
and at one point in you in the
proceedings you said i'm going to state
for the record however that this court
has a long-standing policy disagreement
with the criminal history guidelines
with respect to the application of the
two-point enhancement do you remember
when you said that
i don't remember that particular um
statement how is that policy
disagreement different from
other disagreements ah where you said
that you're not gonna get out of out of
your lane you're not gonna get into the
policy submit an answer in writing
senator um
the supreme court
in the sentencing realm
has
made the guidelines the sentencing
guidelines
uh advisory they used to be
mandatory judges used to have to
calculate the guidelines for sentencing
purposes and then
essentially apply a sentence within the
guideline range
in a case
called
united states versus booker
the supreme court determined that the
guidelines were our advisory now so they
don't have to be
applied in every case you have to
calculate them
but judges have more freedom
to give effect to congress's
the various provisions in the statute
related to sentencing
in booker
and in the in its progeny the supreme
court made clear that judges at
sentencing judge i only have i only have
a limited amount of time so um not even
an answer close on one other question
didn't even get the answer and forgive
me for interrupting you but but
she literally was not yet able to
provide any substance all right i was
trying to get to the point let me just
let me just ask
i don't know you well it's crazy i've
been impressed by
our interaction and you've been gracious
and charming
why in the world would you call
secretary of defense rumsfeld and george
w bush war criminals because they are
you know legal filing because they are
it seems so out of character for you
it's accurate
senator you may have been talk are you
talking about briefs that i or habeas
petitions that
talking about when you were representing
a member of the taliban
and uh the department of defense
identified him as an intelligence
officer for the taliban and you referred
to the secretary of defense and the
sitting president of the united states
as war criminals they were why would you
do something like that it seemed so out
of character they were senator i don't
remember that particular reference and i
um
was
representing my clients and making
arguments um
i'd have to take a look at what you
lawyers have clients i did not um
intend to
disparage the president or the
the secretary of defense you kind of did
and that's okay well being a war
criminal has uh huge ramifications you
could be subject to the jurisdiction of
the international criminal court and
hall before
that international tribunal they should
have been war crimes they should have
been it's not a casual comment i would
suggest
thank you thank you senator cornyn
senator whitehouse and we will
good to be with you again good to be
with you um
i know that a
great many people are
extremely proud that you are here today
um i don't know that there are a great
many who are prouder
than bruce celia
and so with your permission i'll take a
moment and offer into the record
some of his comments about you and then
maybe give you a chance to reciprocate
with a word about him but
yesterday in my opening remarks i
mentioned the boston globe article
in which so they're going to throw some
bouquets at each other here i'm going to
have my lunch now so that then during
their break which is coming up we can
you know get messages from you guys and
etc the stream continues straight to
judicial temperament
i see some of the same qualities in her
that i saw in ruth bader ginsburg
humility the ability to inspire others
in a quiet way not at the top of her
voice
some people have the capacity to inspire
by example in the force of their reason
intellectually she is very smart
very well informed and she's very
hardworking and focused
she gets the big picture masculine arms
consent that the globe article be
admitted to the record without objection
but he didn't stop there your honor he
went on to wpri
local station in rhode island and
said about you
she's worked hard
she deserves it
and i literally don't think that the
president could have made a better
choice
i think she'll be a terrific addition to
the supreme court
she listens to what other people have to
say
but makes up her own mind
she has a very scholarly approach toward
the law
she has a very winning personality
she's kind to the people she comes in
contact with
and she has a certain humility that i
find very attractive in people
may ask unanimous consent that the
statement from uh wpri be put into the
record without objection
um judge tell you went on law 360
and said
i sense that she you
she has the same sort of desire to
achieve consensus and a pragmatic streak
that has characterized some of justice
breyer's work
i think she will be quite balanced
i have not found her to be an ideologue
she understands what the job of being a
judge or being a justice is she wants
very much to do it in the right way
and she will bend her considerable
talents to that direction and won't get
distracted by any extraneous
considerations or side issues
i think the country will appreciate that
and will appreciate that this is a woman
who understands the importance of the
position
and will give 100 of her talents every
day to do that job in the right way
and in accordance with her oath of
office
unanimous consent that that be put into
the record without objection and then
finally the providence journal our home
state newspaper
uh katie mulvaney uh in an interview uh
heard
judge celia say
i think it's a terrific appointment
she's a very thoughtful person and
wonderfully well qualified
i'm happy not only for her
but for the whole country
she listens well she gets the whole
picture
has great respect for the rule of law i
think she's got the whole package
unanimous consent that article be put in
the record that objection
so
any reflections on judge celia oh
well um
that was very moving thank you
senator for reading his
lovely remarks
um it's exactly who i know judge celia
to be
always
eloquent always insightful
and i'm so flattered by his
um
by his admiration because he is someone
that i
have admired my entire
professional life
he he taught me how to
look at issues
very carefully
how to write in a lot of ways because of
the way in which he's so fastidious with
his
opinions and he's been an extraordinary
mentor and role model for me well we are
very proud of him in rhode island as you
know he's on senior status and when he
went on senior status
um we're able to recommend the
uh rosary thompson
to succeed him of whom i think rhode
islanders are
equally proud and she has now gone on
senior status and mr chairman i hope
we'll be considering shortly and
equally impressive biden nominee for for
her position
um on an unrelated subject and
um
it relates to yesterday's activities
uh you can relax a moment your honor
this will not be a question for you but
a lot was said in this room yesterday
about dark money
by our republican friends to the point
where
um one of the headlines about yesterday
read republicans hammer dark money
groups
and i'll be the first to concede that
there is dark money on both sides
and i hope very much we can get rid of
it on both sides shortly by legislation
but there is a difference i believe
between
a dark money interest rooting for
someone
and right-wing dark money interests
having a role
in actually picking
the last
three supreme court
justices
now how do we know that they had a role
in doing that well we know because
everybody involved said so
it was pretty
straightforward stuff
president trump said we're going to have
great judges conservative all picked by
the federalist society
that's pretty plain
uh senator orrin hatch former chairman
was asked some of was said some have
accused president trump of outsourcing
his judicial selection process to the
federalist society i say
damn right
the co-founder of the federalist society
said
that
the administration is relying on the
federal society to come up with
qualified nominees
and then don mcgahn who ran the
operation for trump in the white house
said
i've been a member of the federal
society since law school
still am so frankly it seems like that
role has been in sourced
so
there's pretty clear and pretty broad
agreement that
that selection process
took place out of the public eye
and it appears to have been informed
heavily by dark money interests
they were not alone
in saying this here's
laura ingram on fox news
concerned about
abortion cases coming up before the
court we have six republican appointees
on this court after all the money that's
been raised the federal society all
these big fat cat dinners if this court
with six justices cannot do the right
thing then i think it's time
to circumscribe the jurisdiction of this
court that's the way to change things
finally
so we have people who are in a position
to know what was going on behind the
scenes describing the six republican
appointees on the court who got there
after all the money that has been raised
the federalist society
and all these big fat cat dinners and
threatening that they don't do what she
considers to be the right thing
they'll be punished by circumscribing
the jurisdiction
of the court
that's pretty big talk but it's backed
up by pretty big dollars
if you go back to before this enterprise
got underway
the uh money that came into the federal
society from
what's called donors trust
which has been described as the dark
money atm of the right a koch brothers
affiliated operation
back say in 2002 it got five thousand
dollars
no big deal
by 2019 when this operation was in full
swing
it got 7 million dollars
we don't know who the real donor was
because that's the job of donor's trust
is to de-identify
the donor
to launder the identity off the donation
so you can't connect the dots any longer
but seven million dollars i think is
quite a lot of money
and unfortunately the federal society
was not alone
right down the hallway
is something called the judicial crisis
network its offices on the same hallway
of the federal society in the downtown
washington building
although jcn's website and tax filings
list a mailing address at a different
location an address shared by multiple
companies
and right down that hallway at that
judicial crisis network there's even
more money pouring
and here's how much
poured into the last three nominations
via the judicial crisis network
21 million dollars related in time to
the gorsuch nomination 17 million
dollars to the kavanaugh
nomination 14 million dollars to the
barrett
nomination
and of course we don't know who the
actual donor is could be the same donor
who knows
and because we don't know who the donor
is we don't know what business they
might have had before the court
and i think it matters when people are
seeking to influence the makeup of the
court
that the public understand
what business they may have before the
court
and anonymity hides all of that
and they didn't stop
with
the
trump nominees
they got up on the air
a dark money group
using dark money
to accuse
biden's supreme court nominee
at that point a player to be named later
judge jackson had not been selected at
this point
of being a tool or stooge of
liberal activist dark money this is a
screenshot from their advertisement
paid for
by
the judicial crisis network
so it's worth understanding for a moment
what the judicial crisis network is and
where it lies
and it lies in a network of
organizations
the um
prevailing way that political mischief
is accomplished these days is with a
paired 501c3 and 501c4
organization the 501c3 gets the tax
deduction the 501c4 gets to participate
in political activity
and sure enough there's an 85 fund and a
concord fund that are twinned together
as a 501c3 and 501c4 organization
and they filed under virginia
corporation law to operate under what
they call fictitious names
that's the term of law under which
they file fictitious names and there's
the judicial crisis network
one of the fictitious names
of the concord fund it has a parallel
judicial education project
that is a fictitious name of the 85 fund
if you're interested in voter
suppression you can move down to the
honest elections project
action
another fictitious name
and it's 501c3 twin the honest elections
project
and they've even got new ones that are
less active free to learn action and
free to learn so these are eight
organizations that are essentially one
organization
as lawyers we think from time to time
about piercing the corporate veil
that's corporate veiling that you could
pierce
with a banana
and it runs back and forth with three
groups
called crc advisors crc strategies and
crc public relations that take and send
money to these organizations
as part of the sort of planning element
you might say that crc advisors crc
strategies and crc public relations this
trio
is the
command center
and this is the
operational torso of the creature
so i show this all because it
shows considerable effort when somebody
goes to that much trouble
to create that many organizations
to hide how much money they've spent
to control
the nomination process to the court
and it's no small amount of money
in the original washington post research
they pegged it at 250 million dollars
further research led to testimony in my
court subcommittee
that um the number was actually 400
million dollars
and we have a recent report that we have
in fact checked that the number is
actually even higher than that so i may
amend this number
upward once we're done with our
fact checking 400 million dollars
funding conservative activists
behind the scenes campaign
to remake the nation's courts
that
operation
is a very different thing
than a group rooting for somebody
and i want to make sure that that
difference is clear
since
our friends on the republican side have
made dark money such a big focus of
their attention already
there is a
drastic difference
between rooting for somebody
and
controlling the turnstile
that decides who gets on the court
controlling the funding
of the political campaigns that pursue
the folks on the court
and actually once you get on the court
we're working now with the judiciary
itself
to try to clean up the mess of that same
anonymous money appearing before the
court
through phony front groups that file
amicus griefs and little flotillas
or if it's an important enough case and
a full armada
of
dark money-funded front groups
so that bears not at all on
this nominee but because this is a very
public forum and because we've heard all
that so-called hammering
of dark money groups i wanted to make
sure that it was clear to everybody how
this game is played
and what the difference is
in the way the two sides play it
the um
so now
back to our business
judd jackson um
you
have served as a
um trial court judge
i have you have served as an appellate
court judge i have and with any luck you
are on your way to serve as a supreme
court justice
now
one of the things that is very different
about trial court judges
and appellate court judges
is
what their role is with respect to
fact-finding
it's my
belief from my time spent as a
practicing lawyer
that the role of fact-finding belongs at
the trial court level that's where you
can look the witnesses in the eye that's
where the evidence can be
amassed that's where the trial judge has
the responsibility of sifting through it
if there's a jury then the jury of
course is the ultimate fact fact-finder
but if you're in a non-jury trial the
trial judge is the fact-finder
then the case goes up on appeal and it
comes up with a record
a record of fact
in the case
and in my view
that record of fact that comes up to the
appellate court
is actually a constraint
on the power of the appellate court to
go wandering off
the court is obliged
to consider the appeal based on the
factual record that was adduced
in the district court
so
you having lived in both of those houses
the
trial courthouse and the appellate court
house
tell me a little bit about what that
change meant to you as you went from
being
a trial judge
to an appellate judge
thank you senator um it is a really big
difference
as you mentioned
at the trial court
you are on the ground level
parties have filed the case
you have all of the issues usually um at
the trial level because
you'll have the complaint if it's a
civil case and
um there'll be a lot of litigation
about the development of the facts in
the case
in civil cases you have a period of
discovery in many cases that
is really about the development of the
record what actually happened
in this case
sometimes there's even a trial
and that too is a part of the
development of the facts in the case
because a jury will
be charged with the responsibility of
determining
what happened who's guilty for example
if it's a criminal case or who's liable
um if any
if it's a civil case and sometimes there
are even
questions presented to the jury
that they have to determine the facts
at the appellate level as you said there
is um already a record and the court is
looking primarily at the law the legal
principles that guided the decision
below
based on the factual record and
importantly at the appellate level
there are standards of review
that the court of appeals
applies when it decides
how to
uh review whether or not to reverse or
affirm
the judgment of the lower court
and i've um been very mindful especially
as a trial judge of the standards of
review when i was prepping lawyers for
oral argument before appellate courts
i would often say
please don't quarrel with the facts
unless you have
a knock down case
because if you want to get the appellate
court to relitigate the facts you're up
against the harshest standard of review
available the clearly erroneousness test
and clear error is no small thing
outside of that narrow finding by an
appellate court that somehow the
district court got it wrong
filtered through that clear error
standard are there other circumstances
in which
it's proper
for
appellate courts
to do their own independent fact-finding
outside of the record of the case that
they're reviewing
i am not aware of any uh there might
there may be but um in my experience
the fact-finding is done at the trial
level the court of appeals only looks at
facts
under standards like clear error
um and so therefore the record is
usually
set and established by the time you get
to the court of appeals yeah
and i think that um it's actually one of
the constraints on the judiciary
that they don't get to go and do free
range
fact-finding
they have to be tethered to the record
of the actual case before them it's
related to the case or controversy
requirement
that is correct senator
and in that regard um civil juries are
i think um
something that americans have prided
themselves on for a long time
you go back to the colonial days
and the civil jury was one of the
immediate imports from england every
colony set up civil juries
when the crown tried to interfere with
the
civil juries in the colonies it became
castle's bellai for the revolution it
was in the declaration of independence
of what the king had done wrong that
offended
the colonists and caused the revolution
and the
documents around the founding
and around the creation of the
constitution all reflect
passionate belief in the importance of
the jury including the civil
jury
which as you may know from your
experience in
the
trial court
is getting to be a rarer and rarer
creature
um and in fact there are trial judges
who
have written about how do we serve how
do we keep the civil jury alive
and i'd like to hear your thoughts about
whether there's more to the civil jury
than just a fact-finding appendage
of the trial judge
whether it was seen by the founders and
whether it belongs in our constitutional
structure
as a part of the
responsible self-governance
that was established by our constitution
uh yes senator um
it
is
part of our ordered liberty it is
um
a mechanism by which
citizens
can participate
in
governance they can
be called upon by the court to
[Music]
sit in judgment of other
people in the community
and it was something that
was a part of the democratic
vision
of the founders from from the very
beginning
blackstone was one of the
legal
experts
um
who the
early lawyers of the united states
relied on i suppose there were lords who
had nothing but blackstone's
commentaries in the bible on their shelf
and blackstone described the jury as
having a role
to make sure that the
power
and clout
of
big and powerful interests
could be protected against
that it was a
refuge
from the power of what he called the
more powerful and wealthy citizens
there was long experience in government
of corruption
whether it was getting to a chief
executive and getting them to
do things your way for improper reasons
or whether it was controlling
a legislature a legislative body
but the jury is fundamentally different
because they don't stick around they're
there for one case in one case only and
then they disappear
you can't fix them so that they
decide your way over time
and if in that one case you try to fix
them you've likely committed a criminal
offense
tampering
with the jury is a pretty significant
thing is it not
it is if anybody tampered with a jury of
yours how would you respond oh very
seriously good so the jury lives in a
protected environment from a lot of the
political power
and the
danger of corruption
that
the elected branches
um often suffer
and
do you have thoughts about the
importance of the civil jury
in that regard
as the bastion where
people can go
where they'll get
a square deal from regular citizens
and can stand toe to toe with the
lawyers for however big or mighty an
opponent they may
have with
almost no danger let's put it that way
little danger lessen danger
of the fix being put in
well certainly the jury
system is designed in that manner
that citizens are brought in from
the community
um
when we
pick juries
we ask as judges do any of you in this
pool have any connection
to anyone
you know i've i've so you screen them
for conflicts of interest you screen
them
heavily that's part of the
what we call the void or the sort of
we don't do that with people who come to
congress
well in in the courts they come with
their conflicts of interest often right
on their lapels
sometimes hidden in their back pockets
but jury is not so correct not so and in
fact that would be a reason to exclude
someone from the jury and we even ask
um you know do any of you as judges we
say do any of you know me
um and if you do you'll have to let me
know and and be removed because the idea
as you've indicated is to get people
from the community who have no
connection to the case
and can
hear the evidence that's presented in
the courtroom and the arguments of of
the lawyers
and make a decision
um that is unconnected to any sort of
personal interest they might have
protecting the jury
against the dangers of bias or
corruption
giving the parties before it
a clean and fair shot
yes senator
so
with any luck
you will be on the
supreme court before long and i hope you
will
remember all of this
because it seems to me that the court
has been on something of a campaign to
deprecate and diminish
the
civil jury
including by allowing big corporations
to build into their
standard contracts buried way down in
the fine print
that
folks often don't read and even if they
do read it they'll never get through the
phone tree
to find somebody to complain about it
try to strike it out of the contract
it's a take it or leave it
adhesion proposition
and they build into that
that you've given up
your right to a jury
your seventh amendment right to a civil
jury it's right actually in the bill of
rights
and i cannot think of another right that
the court pays less attention to
or throws more readily under the bus
if you read
the mandatory arbitration cases
there's rarely a mention of the seventh
amendment
and it seems to me that it flies in the
face of the purpose of the jury
to allow the citizens of the greatest
power and wealth or today corporate
citizens
to actually be able to take on the
ability on their own through contracts
that the
customer has no chance
to negotiate the employee has no chance
to negotiate to actually take away that
right
that was at the heart of our founding
without a squeak
of objection or even notice
by the court and i think it's created a
dramatic shift
in power towards big corporations
and i think it has harmed innumerable
employees
and customers
so i am extremely happy that you have
been able to answer these questions with
such clarity
about the role and the history and the
value of the civil jury and its
importance not just as your
fact-finding adjunct but is an important
part of our constitutional structure
part of our structured liberty as
americans i wish you well i'll see you
again tomorrow and uh thanks so much for
your patience with all of us here today
thanks senator whitehouse and let me
just say a positive word to follow up
this committee
in the last few weeks has passed
legislation signed into law by president
biden which in cases of sexual
harassment
provide that individuals who are
complaining have the option of a jury
trial
despite
efforts to steer them into mandatory
arbitration it is the decision of the
complainant
the venue that they will seek
i think that is a step in the right
direction and with passed out of this
committee on a bipartisan basis and so
i'd like to ask everyone to consider
returning promptly at 1 30 for the much
anticipated senator lee of utah
um
[Music]
uh
um
[Music]
i'm korean
come here
[Music]
yes
and so the senate judiciary committee
slated to return in about 40 minutes to
continue their questions for supreme
court nominee judge katanji
brown-jackson if confirmed she would
replace retiring supreme court justice
stephen breyer who will leave the court
at the end of this term
when they return utah senator mike lee
will resume questioning
washington post reporter sun min kim
cited this in a tweet
kataji brown jackson in the first
question of the day describes her
approach to the law quote i'm acutely
aware that as a judge in our system i
have limited power and i'm trying in
every case to stay in my lane
and a lighthearted comment from
republican senator chuck grassley he
said at the start of today's session the
first thing he heard after he went home
last night was his wife's opinion that
katanji brown jackson did very well in
her opening statement he adds she didn't
say anything about my opening statement
so while this break is underway early on
judge jackson faced questions from
senator lindsey graham on religion
previous judicial hearings and
guantanamo bay
here's a look
thank you judge
again congratulations i want to talk to
you a little bit about family and faith
because in your opening statement
and the people who uh introduced you to
the committee
uh there was very glowing praise of you
as a person a good friend
you have a wonderful family you should
be proud and your faith matters to you
what faith are you by the way
senator i am um
protestant mm-hmm
okay um non-denominational okay
could you fairly judge a catholic
senator i have a record of i think the
answer would be yes judging everyone
believe you can i'm just asking this
question because how important
is your faith to you
senator personally
my faith is very important
but as you know
there's no religious test in the
constitution under under article six and
there will be none with me and
um
it's very important to set aside one's
personal views yeah about things
in the role of a judge i couldn't agree
with you more and i believe you can
pac-man
uh on a scale of one to ten
how faithful would you say you are
in terms of religion you know i go to
church probably three times a year so
that speaks poorly of me
or dude do you attend church regularly
well senator
i am reluctant to talk about my
faith in this way just because i want to
be
mindful
of the need for the public to
have confidence in my ability to
separate out my personal views well how
would you feel if a senator up here said
your faith a dogma lives loudly within
you and that's of concern
how would you feel if somebody up here
on our side
said you know you attend church too much
for me or your faith is a little bit
different to me
and they would suggest that it would
affect your decision
would you find that offensive
senator i'm i'm i would if i were you
i found it offensive when they said
about judge barrett the reason i asked
these questions is i have no doubt that
your faith is important to you and i
have zero doubt
that you can adjudicate people's cases
fairly if they're an atheist
if i had any doubt i would i would say
so but the only reason i mention this
judge you're reluctant to talk about it
because it's uncomfortable just imagine
what would happen if people
on late night television called you an f
nut
speaking in tongues because you've
practiced the catholic faith in a way
they uh couldn't relate to or found
uncomfortable
so judge you should be proud of your
faith i am convinced that whatever faith
you have and how often you go to church
it will not affect your ability to be
fair
and i just hope going in the future that
we all can
accept that
and that judge barrett i thought was
treated very very poorly
so i just wanted to get that out let's
talk about family
uh do you know janice rogers brown
yes i do know her okay how do you know
her
she was a judge on
uh the court that i now serve we didn't
overlap and i'm
struggling to remember whether i ever
met her but she was a judge on the
circuit court right and you were a
district court judge is that right
i was but i don't know whether she had i
think you were retired are they in the
same building they are in the same
building they are so you really don't
know her
i know of her yes what do you know of
her what's her reputation
um
i know that
she's
a very well-respected judge on my
circuit okay
in terms of family she was the daughter
and granddaughter of
sharecroppers
she was raised in alabama under jim crow
despite this adversity she put herself
through law school as a single working
mother that's pretty impressive isn't it
yes senator your background is very
impressive
you seem to have a great family
uh if family mattered
we would not have done to her
what was done to her here in the united
states senate do you realize that she
was filibustered for two years when she
was appointed the dc circuit
i i didn't
know that did you know that joe biden
actively filibustered janice rogers
brown
i did not know that
did you know that he told face the
nation
if bush
nominates her for the supreme court i
can assure you that would be a very very
very difficult fight
and she probably would be filibustered
is that news to you too
yes okay
now that you know that how do you feel
about it
senator i can't speak to something that
i just learned two seconds ago and
you're okay fair enough conversation
with me fair enough um
you're in the black law school society
all right
at the
law students association okay black law
student association yes you remember at
harvard
yes
and then sometime
the mr jeffries thing do you remember
that whole dust-up
he got
only in um
preparation for this and i think i was
in college at the time it was my senior
year of college okay so you were
actually in the group when he was
invited to speak
i don't know which group um invited him
to speak i was a black student at
harvard
both
in the harvard undergraduate black
students association and the harvard
law school black students association do
you remember going to a speech
given by mr jeffries i think he's the
uncle of king jeffries i did not go to a
speech okay given by mr jeffrey are you
now familiar with her press reports
about what mr jeffrey's views are
just in preparation for this okay and
you do do you associate yourself with
those views i do not senator as a matter
of fact he's been called by many as very
anti-semitic he called you skunk who
stink up the place
you don't agree with that do you i do
not senator and it would be wrong for me
or anybody else to hold his statement
against you because he spoke at some
group you're a member of right
senator i don't have
yes it was it would be yeah that's right
that's the right answer i thought that
was the right answer with judge alito
when they made a big deal about some
group he was in
that had views that he didn't agree with
and tried to call him basically a racist
and found out that senator kennedy god
rest his soul who beat the crap out of
the guy
for being part of some supper club
that was actually in some organization
called the owl
that didn't admit women so i guess the
reason i'm bringing all this up
is it gives me a chance to remind this
committee in america there are two
standards going on here
if you're an african-american
conservative woman you're fair game to
have your life turned upside down to be
filibustered no matter how
qualified you are
and if you express your faith as a
conservative all of a sudden you're a
effing nut
and we're tired of it
and it's not going to happen to you
but it just appalls me
that we can have such a system in
america that if a conservative woman
wants to stand out and say i love my
family just as much as you love yours
and my faith means just as much to me as
it does you that all of a sudden there
come some kind of weirdo
a guy like justice alito who's in the
same type situation you're in being in a
group doesn't agree with everything they
do or what people may say at a meeting
he didn't go to all of a sudden they own
it
you know this stuff needs to stop
our people deserve better respect and i
hope
when this is over people will say you
were
at least well treated even if we don't
agree with you
uh so now let's talk about
gitmo
being a
public defender
did you consider that rewarding
senator
yes
um i did because
public service
is
very important to me it is an important
family value
it is something that
now i've dedicated my career to
yes and do you think it's important to
the system that everybody be represented
absolutely it's a core constitutional
value you'll get no complaint from me
that was my job in the air force i was a
area defense counsel i represented
anybody that came in the door or i liked
them or not i did my best is that what
you did
yes sir
okay good now
so the american people deserve a system
where everybody's represented whether
you like them or not and anybody takes
up that cause
no problem with me you're just doing
your job and i think you make our
country stronger
but there's the other side of the story
that never gets mentioned when i talk
about gitmo
the american people deserve a system
that can keep terrorists off the
battlefield
they deserve a system that understands
the difference between being at war
and a crime
do you consider 9 11 you said a terrible
tragic event would you consider it an
act of war
yes senator okay i would too i think it
was an act of war about al-qaeda and
associated groups against the people of
the united states
so as you rightfully are proud of your
service as a public defender
and you represented get mo detainees
which is
part of our system
i want you to understand in the nation
to understand
what's been happening
at gitmo
what's the recidivism rate at gitmo
senator i'm not aware it's 31 percent
how does that strike you
that high low about right i don't i
don't know how it strikes me over you're
all like me strikes me as terrible yes
that's what i was gonna say okay good we
found common ground of the 229 detainees
uh released from gitmo of 729 release
have gone back to the fight
here's some of the notables
uh
former gitmo detainee zakir
was named the interim defense minister
of afghanistan
i don't know exactly what his job is
today but during the transition they
made him the defense minister and he was
in gitmo
of the five men we released from gitmo
as part of prisoner swap for sergeant
bergdahl
here's what here's where they're at
mohammed fazal
was appointed deputy minister of defense
noor
was appointed acting minister of borders
and tribal affairs
waziki was appointed as acting
intelligence director
care again acting minister of
information culture defense
omar was appointed as new governor of
the southeastern province of coast
these were five people that we had in
our control they're now helping the
taliban run the country would you say
that our system in terms of releasing
people needs to be re-looked at
senator what i'd say is that
that's not a
job for the courts in this way that um
as an american or does that bother you
well
obviously senator any um
repeated criminal behavior or
repeated attacks
acts of war
bother me as an american well it bothers
me while i will not hold it against you
nor should i the fact that you represent
gitmo detainees i think it's time to
look at this system new folks when 31 of
people are going back to fight to kill
americans and and now running the
taliban government we have gone wrong
somewhere
are we still at war
um
so
the
aumf
the authorization for military force is
still
in effect congress has authorized uh the
use of force against
people in um in this way
but do you personally believe that
al-qaeda
isis-type groups are still at war with
us
i think
yes i mean i think we so we're still in
a state of war with certain elements of
radical islam to this very day
i believe that's documented yes okay
now
what's the process to determine whether
one's an enemy combatant under our law
well um i believe that the executive
branch makes an assessment um of
whether or not someone is taking up arms
against the united states somewhere in
the world related to all of this okay so
it's an executive branch function to
determine whether or not this person
qualifies as an enemy combat
well i believe that they make it current
law under current law
i believe that determination is made by
the executive branch and the person is
put into
is detained
and then the question becomes
whether they
are able to bring some sort of
legal challenge to that they have that
right yes okay so the law is that the
executive branch determines if you're an
enemy combatant
and under our law
you can appeal that decision to a
federal court through habeas is that
correct i believe that's correct okay
is it your view that we can hold enemy
combatants as long as they're a threat
to the united states
i believe that's what the supreme court
has determined okay did you argue that
that should not be the case before
in an amica's breathe
i'm
trying to think i had two amicus briefs
that i worked on or three technically
but two different cases
um i will have another visit tomorrow
yes go back and check yes i'm pretty
sure that in your brief you argued that
the executive branch should not have the
ability to hold an enemy combatant
indefinitely you need to try
through some process or release them yes
senator as you were
talking i my clients the cato institute
the rutherford institute and the
constitution project
made that argument
and asked me to draft their brief yes
well do you agree with that argument
senator my
responsibility was to make my clients
arguments and as a nominee to the
supreme court that's the kind of issue
the supreme court did not address that
issue they in fact
um
the case became moot so did you organize
an effort to get 20 judges to
to file a brief the supreme court on
this issue
not on that issue no on another issue
yes senator okay did you actively go out
and recruit 20 judges
to help you file a brief
on another issue regarding law of war
detention
not technically
um what do you mean by that what i mean
is that
i was
at morrison in forester which was my law
firm in the supreme court and appellate
group
one of
the partners at morrison and forester
was a
former federal judge
who
wanted to make this argument and who
said
we
i have former federal judges who are
friends of mine who would like to join
with me to make this argument so i
worked with her the partner at my firm
who was a former federal judge
to make it was her idea to get former
judges to write this yes yours yes and
you just helped in the implementation of
that idea
so senator as a member of the supreme
court and appellate group in a law firm
that is the practice right now
yes it wasn't your idea with somebody
else yes
okay uh
so
now
there are people still held at gitmo
today
do you do you understand that yes okay
what system is in place
regarding their future
i am not
aware of the system right now
um i i'm not sure exactly let me tell
you what it is yes there's a periodic
review process
and made up of an interagency
where they go through the files of these
folks
and they determine whether or not they
still present a threat to the united
states or the world at large
and i think it's six months maybe a year
but that goes on
at least on an annual basis
and if there's a determination that this
person
still represents a threat to the united
states
uh they're continued to be confined
that's the way the system works
are you okay with that
as a policy matter senator i'm i'm not
speaking to my views that that's my
understanding is that the periodic
review
system is an executive branch
determination
of whether or not they're going to
continue to hold people that they that
make sense to you as a way to deal with
these detainees senator i'm not in a
position to speak to the policy or the
discretion of the executive branch
regarding how they're going to handle
detainees the reason i mentioned it is
because some more of the briefs you
argued that the executive branch doesn't
have that option
that if we if you had had your way
the executive branch could not do
periodic reviews about the danger the
detainee presents to the united states
they would have to make a decision of
trying them or releasing them
is that not accurate respectfully
senator it was not my argument
i was filing an amicus brief
on behalf of clients including the
rutherford institute the cato institute
and the constitution project
when you when you sign on to a brief
does it not become your argument
it does not senator if you are if you
are an attorney
and you are representing a client in
america is that your position
uh when you were in private practice
i mean you you sign on to this brief
making this argument but you say
it's not your position i mean
why would you do that if it's not your
position
why would you take a client that has a
position like that this is voluntary
nobody's making you do this oh senator i
would i would refer you to the same
sorts of statements that chief
justice roberts made when he came before
the committee which is that lawyers
represent clients i i i get that i'm not
holding the client's views against you
like that the people you represent at
gitmo they deserve representation but
this is a amicus brief where you
and other people
try to persuade the court to change
policy
the policy i described is a periodic
review
if the court had taken the position
argued in the brief that you signed upon
would have to release these people or
try them in some of them the evidence we
can't disclose because it's classified
you're putting an america in an
untenable position this is not the way
you fight a war if you tried to do this
in world war ii they'd run you out of
town
we hold enemy combatants as long as
they're a threat there's no magic
passage of time that you got to let them
go
so my question is very simple
do you support the idea did you support
then the idea that indefinite detention
of an enemy combatant is unlawful
respectfully senator
when you are
an attorney
and you have clients who come to you
whether they pay
or not
you represent their positions before the
court
i'm sure i'm sure
everybody at gitmo wants out now i got
that
this is an amicus brief and i i just
don't understand what you're saying
quite frankly i'm not holding against
you because you represented a legal
position i disagree with
i mean
that happens all the time i'm just
trying to understand what made you
join this cause and you say
somebody hired you
but
did you feel okay in adopting that cause
i mean when you signed on to the brief
were you not advocating that position to
the court
senator as a judge now
in order to
determine
the lawfulness or unlawfulness of any
particular issue
i
need to receive
briefs and information making positions
on all sides
i got what a judge is all about listen
i'm not asking you to decide the case in
front of me right here i'm asking me to
explain a position you took
as a lawyer
regarding the law of war and i am beyond
confused
i know what you said in your brief
what i agree with or not is not the
point i just want you to understand that
it's important for all of us to know
where you were coming from if that brief
had been accepted by the court it would
be impossible for us to fight this war
because there's some people going to die
in jail and get mo and never go to trial
for a lot of good reasons because the
evidence against them is so sensitive we
can't disclose it to the public that
we're not charging them with a crime
what we're doing is saying that you
engaged in hostile activities against
the united states that you are an enemy
combatant under our law and you will
never be released as long as you're a
danger until the war is over or you're
no longer a danger that's the difference
between fighting a crime and a war
did you ever accuse in one of your
habeas petitions the government of
acting as war criminals
for holding the detainees
and the holding of the detainees by our
government
that we were acting as war criminals
senator i don't remember that accusation
but i will say that uh you believe
that's true
that america was acting as war criminals
and holding these detainees
senator the supreme court held that
the executive branch has the authority
to detain people who are designated as
enemy combatants
for the duration of the hostilities
and
what
i was
doing in the context of the habeas
petitions at this very early stage
in the process
was making allegations
to preserve issues on behalf of my
clients
a habeas petition is like a
complaint
that
lawyers
make allegations i've been a lawyer too
but i don't think it's necessary to call
the government a war criminal in
pursuing charges against a terrorist
i just think that's too far i don't know
why he chose those words
that's just too far
but
we are where we are
so let's talk about um
the nomination process have you ever had
any interaction with a group called
demand justice
no
directly or indirectly no
uh have you ever had an interaction with
a group called american prospect
no do you know anything about uh our
our our bella is that the right term
have you ever heard of a group called
arbella
i've heard of a group that i think is
arabella or yeah
you're right yes
yeah do you know anything about them
have you had any contact with them no
okay
uh in
your nomination did you notice that
people from the left were pretty much
cheering you on
a lot of people were cheering me on
something that's true
did you know that a lot of people from
the left were trying to destroy michelle
chiles
did you notice that
senator a lot of people were supporting
various people for this nomination
so you're saying you didn't know there
was a concerted effort
to
all right welcome back everybody we are
moments away from the resumption of
today's uh second day of supreme court
hearings uh i the next person to ask
questions is a republican i don't
remember i'm trying to remember it's the
same order as yesterday it's either
it's either ted cruz or mike lee does
anybody remember who was next after
white house
it's lee okay guys this isn't live this
isn't live people saying unmute it this
is from earlier we already saw this it's
not live it's not live they're in a
break it's not live you could just go
back earlier and look earlier if you
want to see this again
uh cruz is not next okay it's mike lee
mike lee should be fairly weaponized as
well all right let's do a little bit we
said we would do this of like how many
of the senators can i recognize by face
let's uh let's try it okay so that's
mcconnell nobody could mistake that
turtle face for anything else
this is um
that's blumenthal right
yep
oh no it wasn't wait hold on who was
that
isn't this blumenthal
no who is this
oh this is why i didn't widen okay all
right so anyway i got it wrong i got it
wrong um oh man who is this guy i don't
know who this guy is
this is uh is this an old picture of
mike lee
who is this guy
it's no it says i was wrong
mike lee it's not accepting it
lee
i don't know this is kind of weird
um
no idea who that is
okay so that's cornyn
uh this is sherrod brown
yep
man i don't know who that is
oh this is um man i forget this guy's
name
that's a republican
this is king
got that one
this is scott
that's feinstein
i have no idea who this is either man
okay
that's mansion
no idea who this guy
is okay kelly
warnock
barrasso
yep
this is uh
i don't know who that is i'm not looking
at the chat obviously
this is um
wait is this white house this seems like
an old picture
yes it was okay
lankford
don't know who that is
man i don't know who this is either
i don't know who this is
or this guy
or this guy wow i'm terrible at this
there's bernie that's sanders okay
uh damn i don't this guy i don't
recognize either
okay this is blumenthal
there we go
wow no idea who that is
that's maisie hirono
that is tammy duckworth
no idea
no clue
i don't recognize this guy either
uh i could have sworn i already saw a
picture of this woman but i don't i
still don't know who it is
yeah i don't know any of these people
are these even senators
i don't know
yeah the i i'm starting to think this is
a joke
i don't recognize any of these people
okay there's grassley
who is that i don't
even know
no clue
okay that's rubio
this is uh oh the florida guy uh wait or
is it jersey menendez
yep
no clue who that is
that's collins
that's lindsay
i don't remember who this guy is
hello we're not missing anything are we
no we're not okay actually they're
starting to come back in okay so we'll
stay over here there it looks like we're
about to resume
um okay
thank you to the freak and raided roy
for the twitch prime subscriptions i
really appreciate that also i want to
say a big thank you to
meredith wythe
meredith wife
who is number 16 today
please consider consider
getting a membership on my website
joinpackman.com
or uh if you have amazon prime you can
get a free twitch prime subscription
um over on twitch it's a very very
exciting day we're about to resume
festivities i believe with mike lee
that's what the audience thinks is next
um
let's see
what else we have
whitney did call in during the break
so i saw some rumors online um
like uh
bridget
macron's wife
was like a transgender or something
and um
uh emmanuel macron's wife is not trans
and we're gonna get away from that
pretty damn quick pretty damn quick oh
if utah is next then indeed it is mike
lee yeah that's that's uh that's
absolutely correct
super chats he delete delegitimizes the
supreme court by framing their decisions
as being made up yeah what was notable
about john cornyn's line of questioning
was it just sort of seemed like really
his issue is with how the supreme court
works
and that's not really judge jackson's
fault nor responsibility
nor within her ability to change so it
was it was odd it was a very very odd
line of questioning
and for the most part the republicans
are grandstanding they're complaining
about the treatment of people who were
not nominated they're complaining about
the treatment of former
nominees they're complaining about you
know all sorts of different things that
just don't really have to do with
evaluating
uh judge jackson's abilities and her
knowledge to be on the court that's all
and and of course i mean why wouldn't
they
they don't really
have much to use against her because
listen agree with her politics or not
she's as qualified as anybody else
currently on the court and we looked at
that earlier and we're going to look at
it again
tomorrow
uh thanks to black white rook for the
twitch prime subscription welcome and
thank you i really appreciate that
um
let's see what else we have going on
today
on the voicemail line
let's see
hi david i recall you saying that you
were interested in getting back into the
debate game i strongly support this as i
think we need more substantive
conversations between
intelligent people who have strong
disagreements on political issues so i
just want to give a few recommendations
of people in the online political
commentary space who i think would make
good guess on your show
the first is sean fitzgerald of the
youtube channel actual justice warrior
he focuses mainly on criminal justice
good topic a good topic of discussion
would be critical race theory being
taught in schools and whether or not
systemic racism is actually a major
issue in the criminal justice system
another one is peter schiff he's
demonstrated a willingness to talk to
pretty much anyone as long as he's
invited on their show a good topic of
debate with him would be like
regulations entitlements taxation
deficit spending and the national debt
uh the last would be ben shapiro now i
know you've said before that you don't
think he's interested in talking to you
but i mean honestly i think if you reach
out to him and his team to invite him on
your show i'm pretty sure he'd be
willing to talk so we've done it he no
he does not seem interested no that's
that's uh unfortunately not accurate
um let's see what else we've got here
uh voicemails voicemails um let's see
mr packman given uh donald trump's tough
stance
against cuba venezuela and china
i really doubt that he has any
authoritarian communist
sympathy all right
i want to say thank you to john workman
john just signed up on my website using
the coupon code fix the court
john thank you good sir very very much
appreciate you being here
uh and i also
want to say thank you to
uh
oh nobody nobody
okay
we are moments away yeah they're gonna
resume any second guys everybody relax
david
the clean shaving works for you
the five o'clock shadow works for you
a beard thin or full-grown beard works
for you good but not just the mustache
yeah i haven't had that for
a really really long time
i don't know uh
i don't know
hi david i'm calling from ohio uh
wondering why you have not addressed the
problem in texas
declaring
parents getting care for their
transgender
children
as child abuse i thought we did cover
that is that's not a new story is it i
think we did cover that uh
jim adelberg sending a super chat for
two dollars and the message is here's
two dollars thank you
i appreciate that very much
um let's see what else i have here
for everybody
um
1200 voicemails and nothing super high
quality that i can see offhand
but um you know to give you guys a
compliment those you know
uh jewish people compliment because
i
seem like very hard on them
um is that they did like the english
people did like royalty like when it was
um
embellished
by
the jewish people
i don't know about that
hey if you're watching the um supreme
court confirmation hearings and then
marcia blackburn uh concludes after her
uh demeaning grilling of uh
brown jackson marsha blackburn if you
notice she used uh the word
you know she she was reared correctly
which um
you know rearing has the
meaning to people but also has a lot of
meaning to animals and
farming and
i i think southerners talk about child
rearing i think they just say i don't i
mean listen marcia blackburn is
disgusting and her diatribe was
absolutely vile yesterday i just don't
know that we should read too much into
rearing i think a lot of folks from uh
tennessee or wherever she's from i think
that that that they just that's just how
they talk
uh yeah
but i just noticed that um you know
whenever there's a bunch of people in
our area and they're in europe and
they're
killing people
um
they're usually from
asia
okay
the racist content from whitney
is um is a bit much
hey david um
my name is
brent and i
like your
youtube
videos
just wanted
to let you know that
and
i think you're
really awesome
[Music]
have a great day
that's a beautiful message thank you
brent
the dog whistling yodler is dropping in
a super chat sees please take my last
five dollars sir
i'm going up in the air forever sir your
wife is up in the air
unusual message but fair i'll take it
um let's see if i have anything else
here
i did this hearing for uh katina brown
jackson
oh god katina oh my god
i did this hearing for uh katina brown
jackson for supreme court i think he's
going really well
my favorite moment so far was when she
said i like beer yeah i miss that part
of the speech that she gave actually i
don't really remember that
um
let's see what else i have here
about the hearings
um
not clear
not clear we have too too much else
they're going to be resuming any moment
here
hi avery pacman i i saw your video with
uh thomas
homo dixon okay and that's enough we
will not do the
homophobic stuff uh here is the return
of the nominee to the supreme court
judge katanji brown jackson
i believe mike lee will be next from the
standpoint of questions
wd dilly says here's five dollars for no
more whitney today well that's fine
willie unless someone gives six dollars
and says here's six dollars for more
whitney in which case you would be
overruled but we will keep a close eye
on that
um
i do expect some nasty questions from
mike lee
for sure
i would like to make a statement
in terms of some research that was
undertaken
during the break
judge jackson earlier senator cornyn
said that you had called former
president george w bush and secretary of
defense donald rumsfeld a quote war
criminal unquote
i noticed a little surprise in your
reaction and i was surprised by the
allegation
during your service as a public defender
you filed several habeas petitions
against the united states
naming former president bush and former
secretary rumsfeld in their official
capacities
you were advocating on behalf of
individuals who argued they were
civilians wrongly classified as enemy
combatants of the united states
and your filing was part of your
professional responsibility to
zealously advocate for your clients
in those petitions the individuals
raised more than a dozen claims for
relief
one of which was an allegation that the
government had sanctioned torture
against the individuals which
constituted war crimes under the alien
tort statute
the alien tort statute allows courts to
hear cases for alleged violations of the
law of nations or the treaties of the
united states apparently this is what
senator cornyn was referencing so to be
clear
there was no so quite literally she made
12 claims on behalf of her clients one
of which was that a war crime was
committed against them interesting how
things can be missed and
re-characterized was correct thank you
very much we now recognize senator lee
here we go
thank you uh mr chairman thank you judge
jackson for being here
i want to talk uh
today about some things you you heard
about yesterday there was a lot of talk
uh from members of this committee about
judicial philosophy
i want to talk a little bit about what
that means and and why it's important
we'll start with
what it means at least to me
one of the things that you you heard
from a lot of members of the committee
uh whether they couched it in terms of
judicial philosophy or not
relates to the idea that justice
should be blind that justice properly
administered within our system is blind
and that therefore individual justices
and judges serving in article 3 courts
should should be blind in the sense that
they are able to see
and understand and interpret the law
understand what the law
is
while understanding that
the idea of what the law should be is
left to other branches of government not
to the judiciary
in this respect we recognize that blind
justice and blind justices those who are
blind to the things they're supposed to
be blind to or those
willing to recognize that if there is a
policy flaw in the law
and if there's a policy change that
needs to be made it's not the role of
the court to change it
that belongs to two different branches
of government primarily to congress
this of course requires uh judicial
restraint it requires judicial humility
um and and it gets back to what i was
describing yesterday uh when i referred
to justice barrett
uh drawing on the analogy from the
odyssey of odysseus binding himself to
the mast of the show boy
most of us refer to this judicial
philosophy as textualism
contextualism is neither liberal nor
neither liberal nor conservative it's
neither republican nor democratic
it it uh it's just the approach that
says what the law says matters and the
job of the jurist is to look at the text
and figure out what the text
means to ascertain
the original public meaning of the text
in question
well i doubt there are any members of of
this committee who would disagree with
the idea that justice should be blind in
this respect and that policy changes
need to be made by the political
branches of government primarily by the
legislative branch and not by the courts
you did hear some statements that i
think are uh at least a little bit at
odds with that concept of justice
um
one one of my colleagues mentioned that
you should interpret the constitution
in a way that works for the people of
today
fair enough we certainly don't want to
interpret the constitution in a way that
doesn't work but again that's not the
objective the objective is not to
ascertain good policy
the objective is to ascertain what the
law requires
you were urged to consider the effects
of the court's actions on people's lives
there again and so far as this relates
to policy it's not really the job of the
courts
you were admonished that you must quote
be able to see the real people at the
other end of the court's rulings like
americans who are one supreme court
decision away from losing their health
insurance or one court decision away
from the ability
to make their own health care choices
and the list goes on and on
now that type of judicial philosophy
would would have you step into the role
of policymaker and decide what the law
should be rather than what the law is
you also heard quoted a couple of times
yesterday quoted or paraphrased or
otherwise referenced
federalist 78 in which alexander
hamilton
refers to the difference between law
between will and judgment
will
as expressed by hamilton
refers to are we more or less than two
minutes away from the first question
thanks to what the law is
the judicial branch
has the latter power but not the former
the legislative branch as the former but
not the latter
judge jackson i'd love to get your your
thoughts on on this discussion uh about
what it means what blind justice is why
that's important let's start with with
this formulation of it though
does does the law determine the outcome
of a case
or does the outcome of the case
determine
the
law thank you senator
the law determines the outcome of case
and so
anytime you're looking at a case and
you're looking at the outcomes for
ordinary americans for day-to-day
americans if you're looking beyond
the scope of deciding that case and if
you're looking even within that case
beyond uh what the law says you would be
stepping into a province of a different
branch
is that right i believe so the law and
the facts
uh of the case determine the outcome of
cases
i think that's that's an accurate
statement it's important to emphasize
this this is also something that
hamilton describes in federalist 78
where he goes on to say anytime you
start to see the courts start to
exercise will instead of judgment
the result is is supplanting the will of
the people as expressed through their
elected representatives uh through the
courts and that tends to undermine the
the whole system you see there's a
reason of course why we give life tenure
to
article three judges and justices
and that is because we want to make sure
that they have
the power the authority the discretion
and the confidence to issue a decision
that they might not be comfortable with
in fact a judge who always agrees with
and is always comfortable with his or
her own opinions is as justice scalia
used to say not a very good judge
so we wanted them you
all to have confidence in being able to
make the right decision even knowing
that you
and the public at large might be
uncomfortable with the result it
produces
congress makes laws that you won't
always agree with
congress
is accountable to the people at regular
intervals you can fire every member of
the house of representatives every two
years you can fire one-third of us in
the senate every two years
but we insulate
judges and supreme court justices from
that same accountability
precisely for this reason
it's because political accountability is
so important
this is borne out in the judicial oath
uh uh one of the hosts that you'll take
if confirmed to this position as an
associate justice in which
you'll you'll swear or affirm that
you'll administer justice without
respect to persons and that you'll do it
faithfully and impartially i read this
to mean that you do it without
consideration of external
circumstances external considerations uh
policy considerations
or or otherwise
now
it's interesting we're six and a half
minutes in and he's asked one question
interaction that you and i had when you
came before this committee for your
confirmation to the u.s court of appeals
for the dc circuit where you now sit
in connection with that hearing i
submitted some questions to the record
uh in which i asked you uh whether to
what extent the constitution protects
rights that are not
enumerated in the constitution itself
and and if so to specify uh what those
rights were you responded by citing a
number of cases including griswold
versus connecticut roe vs wade loving
versus virginia and a handful of others
you also suggested that the ninth
amendment uh
was something
was a source for such rights
unenumerated rights the ninth amendment
of course states
uh quote that the enumeration in the
constitution of certain rights shall not
be
construed to deny or disparage others
retained by the people
judge jackson what specific rights
has the supreme court identified as
flowing from the ninth amendment and by
that i mean specifically from the ninth
amendment rather than
uh um in sort of an also ran list
of other features
of the constitution that might back up a
particular ruling
what rights has the constitution
identified as flowing specifically from
the ninth amendment
thank you senator um the supreme court
as i understand it has not um identified
any particular rights flowing directly
from the ninth amendment although as you
said the text of the amendment suggests
that
there are some rights
that are not enumerated right right it's
very it's very existence and its very
language uh suggests that which opens up
other questions as to how those are to
be resolved uh it's led to considerable
debate among uh scholars and jurists
alike as to whether to what extent in
what way uh this is enforceable those
rights are enforceable by the courts
but
how would we go about deciding that how
would uh
how would
jurists go about deciding this question
appropriately
in other words
would it be would it be more appropriate
to say
we will ascertain the existence of
rights protected
by the ninth amendment
based on the contemporaneous
at the time of the ratification of the
ninth amendment
or would it be more open-ended
to protect rights that we think are
important today
thank you
senator the supreme court now
um very clearly has
uh determined
that
in order to interpret provisions of the
constitution we look to the time of the
founding and we ascertain
based on
what
the
original public meaning of the words the
constitution were at the time
sometimes that yields a particular
answer other times you may have to look
to practices historically from that time
but that that is that would be the way
in which you would go about interpreting
the ninth amendment
could it also be that it leaves this
to be decided at the at the discretion
of the supreme court itself
in other words not not based on any
historical precedent but based on what
the supreme court justices themselves
deem appropriate at the moment
i don't think so um why and why is that
because
the
way in which the supreme court
interprets the constitution
is with reference to the meaning of the
text at the time that it is one of the
constraints as i mentioned
in terms of my own way of
handling interpreting the law like one
of the constraints is that you're bound
by the text and what it meant to those
who drafted it
hey at the time i got you yeah
now
on february 1st of this year president
biden said that he was he was looking uh
for a supreme court nominee uh this was
as i recall right after justice breyer
announced that he would be stepping down
and before he had announced to
whom he might nominate
that he was looking for a nominee quote
uh with quote a judicial philosophy
that's more one that suggests that there
are unenumerated rights to the
constitution
and all new members mean something
including the ninth amendment
um
so do you do you share the judicial
philosophy that president biden
described in that statement
senator i i haven't um
reviewed that statement but i have not
discussed anything about enumerated
rights unenumerated rights with
with
the president yes
did uh so did president biden uh ask you
either about your judicial philosophy
more broadly separate and apart from the
ninth amendment or
or
ask you uh
it's not really his business your
approach to the ninth amendment he did
not
in a in a primary election debate uh
that he had as a presidential candidate
in nevada in 2007.
joe biden stated quote
i would not appoint anyone
who did not understand that section 5 of
the 14th amendment and the liberty
clause of the 14th amendment provided a
right to privacy that's the question i'd
ask them
if that is answered correctly
that that is the case
then it answers the question which means
they would support roe versus wade i
assume
uh his reference to the liberty clause i
assume he's referring to the to the due
process clause of the 14th amendment uh
in context that appears to be what he's
he's saying
did president biden ask you
whether you agreed with his analysis of
the 14th amendment
uh as it relates to
uh the right to privacy he did not
tell me this uh
when we look at any provision of the
constitution
um
one of the many reasons it's it's it's
helpful
to look at the original understanding in
addition to the the fundamental reason
that you described
um
it can can help us understand
what motivated it and it can help us
understand
the actions of those who voted within
congress to propose
text
to be amended to the constitution and
those who voted to ratify it
we've got a number of amendments
including the amendment that he referred
to in that last quote i read
that that had a uh an understanding at
least um
an understanding that include included
certain thou shalt nots for government
the equal protection clause i think is
is
a provision
of the 14th amendment that people
understood
uh
among anything else it might do
restricts government's ability to treat
people differently on the basis of race
consistent with the equal protection
clause of the 14th amendment when is it
permissible
for government to treat a person
differently on the basis of race
thank you senator
the supreme court has
interpreted the equal protection clause
as you say to
generally prohibit
classifications on the basis of race and
it said says that
those classifications are to be
rigorously scrutinized
they
are
strict scrutiny which is a standard that
applies that looks at the purposes
of the government and the means by which
the government
seeks to achieve any end related to such
classification
they the government would have to have a
compelling
interest in making that classification
and
the means that it selects would have to
be
narrowly tailored to achieve that
interest
and so those compelling interests um
can't be for light or transient reasons
they it can't just be something like we
we feel like in other words correct
and the reason for this is because
um well number one it's
bad
it's bad for anyone to treat another
person differently on the basis of race
it's especially bad when government does
it because
there's not exactly equal bargaining
power
when you're dealing with the the
relationship an individual has with
government uh by definition
it's a particularly unfair form of
discrimination when it's government
doing it governments have
enforcement officers they have armies
they have
the means of enforcing their will and
their laws and that's one of the reasons
why it's so important
what about under under statute
consistent with title vii of the civil
rights act of 1964 when is it
permissible for an employer to treat an
employee or a prospective employee
differently on the basis of his or her
race
by statute under title vii it is uh
generally impermissible
and and permissible only in very narrow
circumstances
i believe so and the statute itself has
some restrictions in terms of to whom it
applies right the employers some
exclusions in terms of
religious employers for example
uh
not being able to discriminate on the
basis of race but it exempts religious
employers
within certain spheres in order to be
able to protect
that
religious employer's
discretion to operate within its faith
and the rules of its faith
and by doing that it it makes that much
clearer
by making that distinction it makes that
much clearer that um
discrimination on the basis of race and
employment is not something
that the law smiles upon nor should it
um
let's um let's talk about the commerce
clause for a minute if that's all right
now at the time of the founding
founding fathers
didn't foresee and
almost certainly could not have foreseen
the invention of radios televisions
airplanes the internet
and telephone networks
and yet
all of those things are governed
by federal law by federal law we're
really deeply getting an understanding
of uh judge jackson's philosophy here as
you can see
well senator
the
commerce clause um was
initially interpreted by the supreme
court to be very
broad to allow for
uh
federal
regulation of interstate commerce
and
the growth
of the economy in this country
um
but over time the supreme court has made
clear that the commerce clause
limits the federal government that there
is limited authority under the commerce
clause
the state of the law now is such that
the federal government through the
commerce clause is only permitted to
regulate
channels of interstate commerce
instrumentalities of interstate commerce
and
activities that substantially affect
interstate commerce and with respect to
the third category the supreme court has
made clear
in the
uh lopez case and in morrison
that non-economic activities
are not covered by commerce clause
authority and in the uh nfib case the
uh
aca case the supreme court made clear
that inactivity is also not covered
um
and not authorized under the commerce
clause
in most of the most of the items that i
identified in my question in fact uh all
of them i believe would fall under the
category
of
channels and instrumentalities of
interstate commerce we're dealing
with interstate airways airwaves
waterways
networks things like that
things that depend for their existence
for their effectiveness
on their operation
interstate such that they couldn't
no one could effectively regulate them
and preserve their core function
unless that was federal
those fit into the category of the
channels and instrumentalities
with the the
the
third item that you described the the
substantial effects interstate commerce
is there much of a limiting principle
there i mean with
you refer to lopez and morrison uh and
nfib versus sebelius to my knowledge
those are the only three cases
the supreme court uh has decided
since it
it's ruling in 1937 on nlrb versus jones
and the offline steel which essentially
created the modern uh substantial
effects case at the the modern
substantial effects standard
those are the only three instances in
which the supreme court identified
as outside the commerce clause authority
something that congress had enacted
are these meaningful constraints in your
view or are they examples of congress
just getting reckless and sloppy in the
way it drafted things uh
some some have argued for instance that
as long as congress doesn't get reckless
and sloppy it can do whatever it wants
under those do you have any view on that
well um these cases come through the
courts so i'll be general um
the
fact that congress is limited in its
authority
under the commerce clause is established
law it is a
fundamental principle of our
constitutional
order
and
those
limits that the supreme court has
recognized do carve out
categories of
activity
that congress is not permitted the
federal government is not permitted to
regulate um non-economic activity is a
category
inactivity is a category um
now
the supreme court has also through the
commerce clause
establish rules for things that the
states may not do uh this is referred to
as the you know the so-called dormant
commerce clause
uh the dormant commerce clause
acknowledges the power of congress the
exclusive domain of congress as being
regulating interstate commerce but
there's no federal cause of action to
allow for the invalidation of a state
law
under the commerce clause it's been
something that's been adopted by the
courts is that an appropriate exercise
of of the court's
judicial power or does that amount to
de facto legislation on the part of the
courts
well senator i wouldn't characterize it
i know that that's what the supreme
court has permitted the dormant commerce
clause is
um
is
a principle
that supports
the
uh interstate nature and regulation and
authority of
the federal government and so states are
not permitted
under that
doctrine
to discriminate against other states to
preference their own commerce
in a way that interferes with interstate
commerce
i want to turn back for a moment to a
line of
of inquiry you had with
with senator durbin earlier today when
you were talking about
your sentencing in these child
pornography cases i want to make sure
that i understand
your your answer there
um
if i understand it you you were making
the argument
that your concern was that the the laws
in this area didn't adequately take into
account
the transfer of these materials
by electronic means
to be
re transmitted received and stored
through computers is that my
understanding that correctly
well senator my uh the point that i was
making was that the sentencing
commission back when i was part of it
and even since
tasked with the responsibility to
evaluate and make recommendations and
look at the data and information about
cases
has looked at
the operation of the child pornography
guideline
not so much the the statute but the
guidelines
which the congress has
tasked the sentencing commission
with developing and there are aspects of
the child pornography guideline
that congress and legislation has
required
it required certain enhancements to be
included in the guideline
and some of those enhancements
the data is now revealing
um
don't take into account
the the change in the way that that this
horrible offense is
now committed
but the fact that it's easier to commit
the offense shouldn't diminish the
severity of the punishment should it i
mean any more than the more widespread
availability of certain drugs the more
widespread availability of certain
weapons might er
when you surely wouldn't argue for a
lower sentence
when certain things become easier in
other criminal contexts so why is this
one different well
the sentencing enhancements that are in
the guidelines are designed
to help courts differentiate
between
different levels of culpability
congress will say this is an offense
whatever it is and the maximum penalty
is x
and and in most cases the range is
between zero and something like 20 years
that congress gives when it establishes
a penalty
the point of the guidelines is to help
judges figure out where in that range
between 20 00 and 20 years a particular
defendant
should be sentenced
and the guidelines have gradations in
them
that relate to various aspects of the
commission of the crimes
sorry so
so
the commission does data to it does uh
data gathering and research to figure
out how it's important to understand
that this is the case with all sorts of
different crimes
they are choose they've made it they've
made a decision republicans have
to focus on
um
explicit child images
uh in the hearings but the explanation
she's giving could be applied to all
sorts of different crimes also i just
realized mike lee has no sideburns i
understand that and so but in in these
cases as i understand all 10 of the
cases that we've reviewed on on record
where you've sent it someone to a
for a child pornography conviction
in all 10 of those cases you you
departed from the guidelines uh and
deported downward
it's hard for me to understand departing
from those in every case you've got
because it's not supposed isn't a
departure supposed to be grounded in
uh finding that it's outside the
heartland of of of cases
in that range uh cases of that sort
yes senator and as i said before these
are horrible cases that involve
terrible crimes
and the court is looking at all of the
evidence consistent with
congress's factors for sentencing the
guidelines are one factor
but the court is told
that you look at the guidelines but you
also look at the nature and
circumstances of the offense the history
and characteristics of the offender
there are a series of of factors
in the cases you are also getting
recommendations
and in most of the cases i haven't
pinned pendant all down but in most of
the cases if not all of the cases the
government is asking for a sentence
below the guidelines because this
guideline system is not
doing the work in this particular case
understood
section 230 of the telecommunication the
communications decency act uh
provides
um a degree of immunity for tech
companies operating in the space of
being online interactive service
providers
it immunizes
them from certain causes of action that
would otherwise
apply against them
would it be within congress's authority
to condition
we'll continue and i'll be back
an availability of
section 230 immunity
on those online interactive service
providers
operating
as a public forum that is
not discriminating on the basis of
viewpoint or the
the viewpoint of those posting on them
would that be within our authority
senator i can't um comment on a
particular
issue about whether or not it is
um
constitutional or or not
but the
criteria that you identify
it would be relevant i think as to
whether or not the government is
seeking to regulate along
viewpoint lines under the first
amendment that is something that is
generally impermissible
thank you mr chairman
thank you very much senator lee senator
klobuchar thank you very much uh
chairman and senator grassley uh welcome
again judge your wonderful family uh
they all seem to be awake throughout
this entire hearing
um i um just wanted to before i start
wanted to
get at something senator lee was talking
about it's not the dormant commerce
clause um but i really appreciated early
on how you talked about these child
pornography cases a former prosecutor
could totally see where you were coming
from
when you talked about looking at these
cases as a mom
and a judge
and would it surprise you at all that
other judges including a number of them
that were
supported by our
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle have given out similar sentences
in
child pornography cases
no senator it would not surprise me
because these cases
are horrific and
there is a lot of disparity
because of the way the guidelines are
operating in this particular area but in
every case in every case
that i handled involving these
terrible crimes i
looked at
the law and the facts i made sure that
the victims
the children's
perspectives were represented
and i also
imposed
prison terms and significant
significant um supervision and other
restrictions on these defendants well
thank you and i just also want to note
and i know others have brought this up
the
letter of support from the fraternal
order of police in which they said from
our analysis of judge jackson's record
in some of her cases we believe she has
considered the facts and applied the law
consistently and fairly on a range of
issues there is little doubt that she
has a temperament and elect legal
experience and family background to have
earned this appointment we are reassured
that should she be confirmed she would
approach her future cases with an open
mind and treat issues related to law
enforcement fairly and justly and that
matters a lot to many of us now
i want to go back to something i was
talking about yesterday and that is why
today's hearing is so monumental
including that it is occurring at a time
when we as americans have been reminded
again
due to the courage of ukrainians
thousands of miles away that we can
never take our democracy or for that
matter or courts for granted
it is also happening at a time when we
are seeing each other for the first time
after a two-year pandemic connecting to
each other again
um and i hope this moment uh will be a
moment where
we
see a renewed interest in our democracy
we respect each other's rights and views
and that we see that we are not a nation
of 300 plus million silos uh instead or
we are a nation committed to this idea
that what unites us as americans is much
bigger than what divides us
and so in that context you come before
us with this incredible strength legal
acumen uh grace under pressure that you
have demonstrated today
and uh you also come before us as we've
noted as the first black woman to be
nominated following 115 justices uh who
have been confirmed and i will note uh
of the 115 justices 110 have been men
and i um actually once reminded a late
night show trevor noah of similar issues
in the u.s senate uh in fact in the
history of the u.s senate of the nearly
2 000 people who have served only 58
have been women and he responded that if
a nightclub had numbers that bad they'd
shut it down
um but today judge we're not shutting
anything down not the court not the
senate and you are opening things up
and i think one of the things your
nomination presents is an opportunity to
address a decline in the public's
confidence
in our court
and
increasingly many if you see public
opinion polls see the court as over
politicized or out of touch
at the same time we've seen an alarming
rise in threats targeting members of our
judiciary for just
doing their jobs how do you think we can
work to maintain the public's con
confidence in the court
what do you see a role in that
thank you senator
public confidence in the court is
crucial
as has been said here earlier
that the court doesn't have anything
else that that is the
the key to our legitimacy in our
democratic system
and
i am honored to accept the president's
nomination in part
um because i know it means so much to so
many people it means a lot to me
um
i am
here standing on the shoulders of
generations
of americans who never had anything
close to this kind of opportunity
from my grandparents who
had just a grade school education but
instilled in my parents
the importance of learning
and my parents who i've mentioned here
many times already
who were the first in their families to
get to go to college
so this nomination
against that backdrop
is significant
to to a lot of people and i hope that it
will bring
it will
help inspire people
to understand that our courts
are like
them that our judges
are like them doing the work
being part of our government
i think it's very important
very good i think along those lines your
wonderful mentor uh justice breyer uh i
quoted him about how he said
we can help maintain public acceptance
of the court and these are his words we
can do it best by helping ensure that
the constitution remains workable in a
broad sense of the term specifically it
the court can and should interpret the
constitution in a way that works for the
people of the day like as you know uh
it's i think section two article two
section two uh doesn't refer to the air
force uh because we didn't have an air
force back then um so are there things
about the constitution that of course um
as we've gone along have been
interpreted to meet uh the moments of
our time what do you think justice
breyer means when he says the
constitution should be interpreted in a
way that works for the people of today
and you think a justice can be both
pragmatic and objective and respect
history
i do and i think that the justices have
demonstrated that some of their recent
opinions
uh have had to deal with
modern technology technologies that did
not exist
at the time of the founding so
for example the
riley case
carpenter case these were
fourth amendment decisions
in which the court was asked to
determine whether or not
it violated the fourth amendment for the
police to
search someone's cell phone without a
warrant
or for the police to use
gps location data to
determine where someone
had been without a warrant
and obviously those technologies did not
exist
but what the court did
was it looked back at
the time of the founding and determined
what the reasonable expectations of
privacy were
related to
uh the the term unreasonable searches
and seizures which appears in the
constitution
and having assessed what that meant
back then they could use those
principles
to decide
whether or not a cell phone is like
uh someone's home these days with all of
the information and all of the things
that are stored there and the court
determined
that it was a violation of
the fourth amendment
that the police officers needed a
warrant and they did so with reference
to what the constitution meant
in history
very good uh you know you were uh viewed
as a judge and you talked about this a
bit yesterday that uh writes lengthy
opinions um that believes you should
spell things out and uh believes in
being transparent is that a fair
characterization
that is okay good i'm sure your clerks
know that
um and
um i want to talk about something to me
that's a bit the opposite and that's
something that uh some have termed the
shadow docket
and that includes decisions that the
court makes on an expedited basis that
are usually unsigned and issued without
oral argument or full briefing in the
last few years we've seen the court
increasingly deciding cases in this way
often over the descent of maybe three or
four of the justices last term the court
granted 20 requests for emergency relief
a historically high number 10 years ago
in the october term of 2011 the court
granted only six requests in an entire
year
um
when do you think it's appropriate for
the supreme court
to grant emergency relief use this
docket when are the circumstances
that warrant this
and um i think you know these decisions
have a profound effect on people's lives
i'll just use one example last fall in a
one paragraph decision a majority of the
court refused to stop the enforcement of
a texas law that severely restricts a
woman's access
to abortion in that case even chief
justice roberts objected to the court's
decision to let the law take effect
calling the statutory scheme
not only unusual but unprecedented
as someone who believes in transparency
could you talk in general about
when you think this shadow docket should
be used when emergency relief should be
given and how if it's overused it could
undermine public confidence in the court
thank you senator um
well
there there's a balance that the court
has to
consider and that it
insofar as
on the one hand
it has always had an emergency docket
the need for flexibility the ability to
get
answers to
the parties at issue
is something
that's important
in our system
on the other hand the court has also
considered
the interest in
allowing issues to percolate um allowing
other courts to rule on things
before they come to the court
and
i am not privy at the moment
to
the justices views and
why and how they're using
um
the emergency docket in these cases
if i was fortunate enough to be
confirmed i would
look at those issues
um but it's it's an interesting and
important
set of issues
um
you know i think just another example of
this by the way is
um the day before wisconsin's primary
election and april 6 2020 uh right
um as the first um
beginnings of some of the health
orders that came out with the beginning
of the pandemic the court issued a 5-4
decision halting a district court's
order allowing voters extra time to cast
their absentee ballots
so that they could avoid uh waiting in
line to vote and back then people
literally got covered with election
workers and the like because of this
and again i'm not going to
belabor this point but i think some of
this is these decisions that are made um
that don't reflect some of the careful
consideration that you have made in many
of your
decisions as a judge
but speaking of voting i'll ask you one
question on that front since the supreme
court
gutted the section 5 pre-clearance
regime of the voting rights act in its
decision in shelby county the d.c
circuit
has not seen
many voting rights cases
however as you know justice ginsburg
dissented in that case describing the
right to vote as the most fundamental
right in our democratic system do you
agree that the right to vote is
fundamental
senator the supreme court has said that
the right to vote is
um
the basis of our democracy that it is
um the right upon which all other rights
are
essentially founded
because in a democracy there is
um
one person one vote and
and
there are
constitutional amendments that relate
directly to
the right to vote so it is a fundamental
right in our
democracy yes i know that's how justice
barrett answered that question as well
in her
uh recent hearing
um i'm going to turn to an area that uh
senator lee and i
we both chair the subcommittee on
antitrust and so it's near and dear to
my heart so i thought it'd spend a
little time it usually gets relegated to
the second round but i'm i'm putting it
up on the docket here uh u.s antitrust
law has been described as a
comprehensive charter of economic
liberty um
and uh i agree and effective antitrust
enforcement plays a critical role as you
know in protecting consumers and workers
promoting innovation ensuring new
businesses have an opportunity to
compete it actually uh from really early
on uh in our country's history uh has
been a very important part of assuring
uh that capitalism works and
um in january uh for the first time
since the dawn of the internet uh the
senate passed a tech competition bill
out of the judiciary committee it's a
bill that senator grassley and i lead
many of the members of this committee
supported uh the bill uh 16 to six vote
it's called the american innovation and
choice online act it's now headed to the
senate floor i'm not going to ask you
about that bill obviously but i want to
put this in some context
while tech monopolies
have seized from 50 to 90
market share in major parts of their
business lines
uh it is clear to me when you look at
the plain language of the sherman act
clayton act laws that are in place that
these monopolies are not okay
uh however court rulings for decades in
antitrust have created some major
obstacles uh to taking on these cases
and it's not just court rulings uh it is
on us with as i said the dawn of the
internet decades having passed it is on
us the senate and the house to update
our laws this year to give enforcers the
resources to do their jobs something you
uh if confirmed would not have a role in
but uh the role of the courts is also
very critical uh you have been nominated
to replace justice breyer who came to
the court with a strong background in
antitrust law i know you handled a case
you and i discussed it in in my office i
think it got um i think it got uh
decided the merger was abandoned
so you didn't have to rule on the merits
of it it was back in
2017. um
a ftc challenge um but i'll just quote
something that justice breyer once said
he told this committee if you're going
to have a free enterprise economy then
you must have a strong and effective
anti-trust law do you agree with justice
breyer's
statement and how would you characterize
the goals of our anti-trust laws
well thank you senator
the antitrust laws protect competition
and as you said um therefore protect
consumers and
competitors and the economy as a whole
and the
um
sherman act and the clayton act are
broad in their
in the in their statements and their
protections and there's a lot of
precedent in this area
if
i were
confirmed
i would use my methodology to
look at the precedence in these areas to
ensure that any legislation that i was
considering
is interpreted
according to the text consistent with
congress's intent
um
and
in the area of antitrust
that is
ensuring that there is uh consumer
protections
very good um
and just to
play it out a little bit um
since the
1980s
the court in cases like trinco and
credit suisse ohio the american express
has really made it increasingly
difficult to enforce the antitrust laws
and protect competition and during that
same time and i know many of my
colleagues know this we have seen a rise
in
industry consolidation market power and
not only in tech
with companies like google and amazon
and facebook and apple but also across
our economy really in everything from
pharma uh to cat food to caskets um
do you uh what role do you think that
congressional intent should play in the
court's interpretation of the anti-trust
laws and i i say that because i think
that
we're dealing with some cases where
justices have actually substituted their
own
ideologies for the intent of congress
in originally passing the laws
and i think it was justice suiter who
once said before this committee
when we are dealing with antitrust laws
we are dealing with one of the most
spectacular examples of delegation to
the judiciary that our legal system
knows
and he added this certainly a respect
for legislative intent has got to be our
anchor for interpretation um so what
role do you think congressional intent
should play in the court's
interpretation of the antitrust laws
thank you senator um
so i've interpreted a number of statutes
in my
near decade on the bench
and in every case
the text of a statute is what the court
looks at in order to ascertain
what the legislature intended
and
that is
um important because as i've said courts
are not policymakers and judges
um
should not be importing their own policy
preferences it's
judges are
restrained in
our constitutional scheme
in order to affect the will of congress
in terms of their interpretation of the
laws
okay thank you i'm going to turn to
another uh topic and that's freedom of
the press uh new york times v sullivan
1964 case
we have recently witnessed
as you know unprecedented attacks on
journalists and journalism
uh whether it's violence overseas uh
recently learning losing
uh sadly members of the press just in
the last month in ukraine or threats and
intimidation at home
this is very concerning to me given the
important role of the first amendment my
dad
was a newspaper reporter
so the issues hit home for me
can you talk about your view of the role
of journalists in our democracy
thank you senator
journalists and freedom of the press is
protected by the first amendment it is
about the dissemination of information
which is necessary for
a democratic form of government the
supreme court has held as much and that
was
the basis for the court's
determinations in protecting
the press from liability
in new york times versus sullivan
and and its pride progeny
okay
um as you know that uh ruling was a
unanimous ruling in support of the first
amendment and the court held uh that
when newspapers report on public
officials they're only liable for untrue
statements that are published with
knowledge or reckless disregard for
whether the statement was false
the court in sullivan based its decision
on our country's quote profound national
commitment to the principle that debate
on public issues should be uninhibited
robust and wide open
uh that's their quote and it recognized
that quote erroneous statement is
inevitable in free debate end quote and
quote must be protected if the freedoms
of expression are to have the breathing
space that they need to survive
do you agree that those principles are
just as relevant today as they were when
the supreme court first decided
new york times v
sullivan new york times b sullivan is
the
continuing binding precedent of the
supreme court and it
does state the principles that
the court has determined are
undergirding
the first amendment right to
free press okay and last summer actually
in
barisha v lawson the supreme court
declined to review a case in which the
11th circuit applied new york times v
sullivan justice thomas and justice
gorsuch each dissented from the decision
not to grant cert arguing that the court
should reconsider its holding in
sullivan how would you approach a case
that sought to limit or overturn the
central holding in new york times v
sullivan
thank you senator
any time the court is
asked to revisit a precedent
there are
criteria that the court uses to decide
whether or not to
overrule
a precedent
new york times versus sullivan is a
precedent and starry decisis
is very important the principle that um
courts the the supreme court should
maintain
its precedence
um
for predictability and stability in the
law
if the court is asked to revisit a
president
its
criteria what it looks at
are whether the president is wrong and
in fact egregiously wrong the court has
said
whether there's been reliance on that
precedent
whether
the
there are other cases that are
similar to the precedent or that relied
on the precedent that have now shifted
so that the president is no longer
uh on firm footing
uh
whether or not the precedent is workable
sometimes the the supreme court will
uh issue a ruling and determine later
that it's not actually doing what the
court intended
and whether or not there are new facts
or a new understanding of the facts
those
various criteria are what the court
looks at to decide whether or not to
overturn a precedent and they would be
what um i would look at if i were
confirmed to the supreme court
thank you i was recalling as you spoke
about starry decisis at one of your
first nominations hearing for the
district court and you actually um
in answer in response to one of my
questions you said starry decisis is a
bedrock legal principle that ensures
consistency and impartiality
of judgments and
um i think as you know by how you've
talked more broadly about this um
moving off of the first amendment
questions you throughout the court's
history
story decisis
has been so key and the court has relied
on it to maintain stability in the law
reaffirm its impartiability impartiality
as a
former justice
i know senator durbin just read a very
famous book about him minnesotan
justice harry blackman
who actually justice breyer succeeded on
the court
said in his concurrence in planned
parenthood v casey about the court's
decision to uphold roe v wade he said
what has happened today should serve as
a model for future justices and a
warning to all who have tried to turn
this court into yet another political
branch
what role do you think that starry
decisis plays in protecting the
independence of the judiciary and
avoiding the perception
that the court is acting as another
quote political branch
i think it plays a very important role
as a doctrine
that keeps
keeps shifts from happening in the court
that
as
as i've previously mentioned it's very
important to have stability in the law
for the rule of law purposes so that
people can order themselves and predict
um
predict their lives given what the
supreme court has already said
and
if there were
massive shifts
every time a new justice came on or
every time new circumstances arose
there would be a concern
that public confidence
uh would be eroded and so starry decisis
is a very important doctrine
um that the supreme court has
established and um
and it's one that furthers the rule of
law in this country
thank you very much uh well that's a
good way to end uh judge jackson and i
do see uh senator cruz awaiting in the
wing so by coincidence and it looks like
he has things he's putting up of charts
by coincidence i have a was going to put
on the record and since he's here it
makes a lot of sense from the judge that
you clerked for
senator cruz uh
judge ledeck who's now retired and i
know you were very close to him
and uh he actually submitted a letter on
on your behalf
um judge jackson and said in this letter
and he's an appointee of george h.w bush
um similar to judge griffith who
introduced you yesterday and i've been
very impressed by uh the support you've
had from
retired judges obviously not appropriate
for current judges but retired judges
appointed by both democratic and
republican presidents as well as the
bipartisan votes that you have gotten
through
the u.s senate for your other positions
but in this letter
the judge former judge ludwig
says that you are eminently qualified
to serve on the supreme court of the
united states
and then he actually says republicans
and democrats alike should give their
studied advice
and then their consent to the
president's nomination
and he adds republicans in particular
should vote to confirm judge jackson so
i thought that might be a good segue
center cruise
to your uh to your questions so i asked
uh chairman uh that the letter of
support um from uh uh former judge
ludwig um who employed senator cruz as a
trusted law clerk uh be uh admitted to
the record without objection
thank you very much judge jackson thank
you
senator klobuchar finds a minnesota
connection to almost everything
very proud of the fact but justice
blackmon was born in nashville illinois
okay he
was a lawyer at the mayo clinic as we
know and spent a lot of time in a
loser's battle a lawyer in minnesota
when he was chosen to the supreme court
but thank you for pointing that out
and now to the great state of texas
senator cruz
thank you mr chairman
judge jackson welcome uh congratulations
thank you
you and i have known each other a long
time we have uh we went to law school
together we were on the law review
together we were a year apart
uh happily so i hope senator
we were not particularly close but we
were always friendly and cordial we were
uh and you and i had a very positive and
productive meeting uh in my office uh
where we discussed a number of things
including you were there with with
former senator doug jones
uh and we discussed how he and i and a
number of other senators had for for two
different years
participated in reading aloud on the
senate floor
dr martin luther king jr's letter from
birmingham jail which is one of the
truly great
advocacies for civil rights our nation
has seen and and you and i talked
together
uh about our shared admiration for dr
king
uh
when senator grassley questioned you
earlier he asked in particular about dr
king's
speech
on on the steps of the lincoln memorial
where he said most critically i have a
dream that my four little children will
one day live in a nation
where they will not be judged by the
color of their skin
but by the content of their character
do you agree with what dr king said in
in that speech there
i do senator
um
as we were discussing it uh you
referenced in my office a speech that
you gave in january of 2020
at the university of michigan school of
law
uh and after our discussion i pulled a
copy of your speech and read the speech
in its entirety and there were elements
of the speech that i thought were really
powerful
uh and let me say your your
opening remarks yesterday were were
powerful and inspirational as well and i
think
you and your family the journey you have
taken to becoming a federal judge to
becoming a federal court of appeals
judge i think demonstrates the
incredible promise and the incredible
opportunity this nation offers all of us
as i read your speech at the university
of michigan law school however
there was a portion that surprised me
and in particular in that speech you
referenced the work of quote
acclaimed investigative journalist
nicole hannah jones
and her and again this is a quote from
the speech provocative thesis
that america was born
that the
provocative thesis that the america that
was born in 1776 was not the perfect
union that it purported to be and indeed
ms hannah jones in her 16 19 projects
describes
the central thesis of the 1619 project
which the new york times laid out
as a revisionist look of history
revising american history and miss
hannah jones described her central
thesis as quote
one of the primary reasons the colonists
decided to declare independence
was because they wanted to protect
the institution of slavery
now that claim is a highly contested
historical claim
um
do you agree with miss hannah jones that
one of the primary reasons the colonists
decided to declare independence is
because they wanted to protect the
institution of slavery
thank you senator
when i gave that speech at the
university of michigan
i was asked to speak on martin luther
king day
and
every year they have a martin luther
king day speaker
and i gave a speech about
black women in the civil rights movement
most of the speech if not all of the
speech was focused on african-american
women
their contributions to the civil rights
movement
unsung contributions in many cases
and then some of the more recent
african-american women
who have made claims who have
done things in our society
one slide was of
ms uh a journalist as you say who who
made that statement and i called it
provocative
um it is not something that i've studied
it doesn't come up in my work i was
mentioning it because it was at least at
that time something that was
talked about and and well known uh to
the students that i was speaking to at
the law school
so are you aware that that since the
1619 project came out that it has been
roundly uh refuted by very respected
historians including gordon wood of
brown university including james
mcpherson
uh of princeton university mcpherson
called it a quote very unbalanced
one-sided account which lacks content
and perspective
and indeed it was so thoroughly refuted
that the new york times quietly altered
the digital version to remove references
to 1619 as the year
of america's true founding and the
moment america began were you aware of
that i was not
so let me ask you related to the 1619
project which i believe is is deeply
inaccurate and misleading
um
1619 project is quote closely
intertwined with a movement that is
called critical race theory
uh
critical race theory as you know
originated at your and my alma mater at
the harvard law school
uh
in your understanding what what does
critical race theory mean what is it
my understanding is that critical race
theory is
um
[Music]
it is an academic theory
that is about the ways in which
uh race interacts with various
institutions it doesn't come up in my
work as a judge it's never something
that i've
studied or relied on and it wouldn't be
something that i would rely on if i was
on the supreme court
so critical race theory as you know has
its origins in the critical legal
studies movie movement which also came
from harvard law school
from a number of critical legal studies
professors crits as they were known when
we were in law school
who are explicitly marxists and they
find their origins in marxism although
critical legal studies frames
society as a fundamental battle between
socioeconomic classes
critical race theory frames all of
society is a fundamental and intractable
battle
between
between the races it views every
conflict as as a racial conflict
um do you think that's an accurate way
of viewing society in the world we live
in
senator i
don't think so um but i've never studied
critical race theory and i've never used
it it doesn't come up in the work that i
do as a judge
so so with respect i i find that a
curious statement uh because
um
you gave a speech in april of 2015
at the university of chicago
in which you described the job you do as
a judge
and you said sentencing is just plain
interesting because it melds together
myriad types of law criminal law and of
course constitutional law critical race
theory so you described
in a speech to a law school what you
were doing as critical race theory uh
and so i guess i would ask what did you
mean by that when you gave that speech
with respect senator um the quote that
you are
mentioning there
was about sentencing policy it was not
about sentencing
i was talking about
the policy
determinations of bodies like the
sentencing commission when they look at
a laundry list of various
academic subjects as they consider what
the policies should be okay
vice chair of the sentencing commission
so let me ask again what did you mean by
because that was an official
responsibility of
yours what i meant by what you were
doing was critical what i meant was that
there are a number of that that
uh slide does not show the entire
laundry list of different
uh academic disciplines that i said
relate to sentencing policy but none of
that relates to what i do as a judge
so let me ask you a different question
is is critical race theory taught in
schools is it taught kindergarten
through 12th
senator i don't
know i don't think so i believe it's an
academic theory that's at the law school
level
okay um
as you may recall during the
confirmation hearings of justice amy
coney barrett there was a great deal of
attention paid to the fact that justice
barrett served as a board member in the
board of trustees of a religious private
school and and the press focused very
intensely
on the views of that school
in your questionnaire to this committee
you disclosed that you are similarly on
a board specifically the board of
trustees for the georgetown day school
and that you've been a board member
since 2019 and you're currently still a
board member is is that correct that is
correct
uh in regard to the georgetown day
school you've publicly said
quote
since becoming a member of the gds
community seven years ago patrick and i
have witnessed the transformative power
of a rigorous progressive education that
is dedicated to fostering critical
thinking
interdependence
and social justice
when you refer to social justice and the
school's mission on social justice what
what did you mean by that
thank you senator for allowing me to
address
this issue
georgetown day school has a special
history that i think is
important to understand
when you
consider
my service on that board
the school was founded in 1945
in washington dc at a time
in which
by law there was racial segregation in
this community
black students
were not allowed in the public schools
to go to school with white students
georgetown day school is a private
school
that was created
when three
white families jewish families
got together with three
black families
and said that despite the fact that the
law
requires us to separate
despite the fact that the law is set up
to make sure that black children are not
treated the same as everyone else we
are going to form a private school
so that our children can go to school
together
the idea of equality
justice is at the core
of the georgetown day school mission and
it's a private school such that every
parent who joins the community does so
willingly with an understanding that
they are joining a community that is
designed to make sure that every child
is valued
every child is treated
as
having inherent worth and none
are discriminated against because of
race
so judge jackson all of us will agree
that that no one should be discriminated
against because of race
when you just testified a minute ago
that you didn't know if critical race
theory was taught in k-12 i i will
confess i i find that statement a little
hard to reconcile
with the public record because if you
look at the georgetown day schools
curriculum
it is filled and overflowing with
critical race theory that that among the
doc the books that are
either assigned
or recommended
uh they include
critical race theory and introduction
they include
the end of policing and at an advocacy
for abolishing police
they include how to be an anti-racist by
ibrahim kendi
they include literally stacks and stacks
of books and i'll tell you two of the
ones that were most stunning
they include a book called anti-racist
baby
by abram kindy
and
their portions of this book
that i find
really quite remarkable one portion of
the book
says babies
are taught
to be racist or anti-racist there is no
neutrality
portion of the book
they recommend to babies confess
when being racist
now this is a book that is taught at
georgetown day school
to students in pre-k through second
grade so four through seven years old
um
do you agree with this book that is
being taught with kids that the babies
are racist
senator
i do not believe
that any child
should be made to feel
as though they are
racist or though they are
not valued or though they are less than
that they are victims that they are
oppressors i don't
believe in any of that but what i will
say
is that when you
asked me whether or not this was taught
in
schools critical race theory
my understanding is that critical race
theory as an academic theory is taught
in law schools and
to the extent that you were asking the
question i understood you to be
addressing public schools
georgetown day school just like the
religious school that justice barrett
was on the board of is a private school
okay so you agree critical race theory
is taught at georgetown day school i
don't know because the board is not um
the board does not control the
curriculum the board does not
focus on that that's not what we do as
board members so i'm actually not
sure well and i'll note that the board
is is chaired by professor fairfax your
college roommate who introduced you
yesterday so the two of you serve on the
board together
um another book that is on the
summer reading for third through fifth
grade is a book called stamp for kids
again by ibram kendi
i read the entirety of the book and i
will say it is
an astonishing book
on page
33 it asks the question can we send
white people back to europe
that's on 33 that's what's being given
to eight and nine years old
it also
on page 115
says the idea that we should pretend not
to see racism is connected to the idea
that we should pretend not to see color
it's called color blindness
skipping ahead here's what's wrong with
this it's ridiculous skin color is
something we all absolutely see
skipping ahead so to pretend not to see
color is pretty convenient
if you don't actually want to stamp out
racism in the first place
now what this book argues for is the
exact opposite of what dr king
spoke about on the floor of the lincoln
memorial and and
are you comfortable
uh with with these ideas being taught to
children
as young as four and in respect to the
first book as young as eight and nine in
respect to the second book
senator i have not reviewed any of those
books any of those ideas they don't come
up in my work as a judge
which i'm respectfully here
to
address
in my work as a judge
which is evidenced
from
my near decade on the bench okay good i
am then then let's go back to your work
as a judge
um
as was noted
in the first slide
you discuss sentencing as being related
to
critical race theory
and earlier there's been some back and
forth as democratic senators have tried
to address your sentencing patterns as
it concerns child pornography
and i'll confess judge jackson as look
as i listen to your testimony i believe
you are someone who is compassionate i
believe you care for children obviously
your children and other children
but i also see a record
of activism and advocacy as it concerns
sexual predators
that stems back decades and that is
concerning
you wrote your note on the harvard law
review
on
sex crimes
uh the your note is your major academic
work on the law review and yours is
entitled prevention versus punishment
towards a principled distinction
in the restraint of relate release six
sex offenders
and in it
you argue and i quote
a recent spate of legislation purports
to regulate release sex offenders by
requiring them to register with local
law enforcement officials
notify community members of their
presence undergo dna testing and submit
to civil commitment for an indefinite
term
although many courts and commentators
herald these laws as valid regulatory
measures others reject them as punitive
enactments that violate the rights of
individuals who have already been
sanctioned for their crimes
under existing doctrine the
constitutionality of sex offender
statutes depends upon their
characterization
as essentially preventative rather than
punitive and what you go out go on to
explain is if they're viewed as punitive
they are unconstitutional if they're
viewed as preventative
they are not
and throughout the course of your
note you argue they should be viewed as
punitive and therefore
unconstitutional indeed in the second to
last page you go through each of those
four categories
you say requirements that sex offenders
register
may or may not be unconstitutional
depending upon whether quote
sex
in which sex offenders have no privacy
right and registration information or
blood samples so you suggest that may or
may not be constitutional although you
raise doubts about it and then you raise
very significant doubts
about community notification
and you heavily suggest that civil
commitment for sexual predators is
unconstitutional
do you still agree with the sentiments
you expressed in your law school note
respectfully senator those are not the
sentiments that i expressed in my law
school note
my law school note
was about
sex offender registration laws which at
the time were relatively new
as
you know from our time in law school one
of the things that law school students
do is they look for new developments in
the law
and they try to analyze them that's
something that makes for good fodder for
a law school note
my note
which came out in 1996 was shortly after
there were
new
megan's laws
and the point that i was making was not
that the laws were
bad that the laws were wrong i was
trying to assess
something that is
sort of fundamental in terms of the
characterization of the laws
i didn't say that they were
unconstitutional one way or the other
what i was trying to assess
was how they are characterized some
um
some courts would look at those laws and
call them preventative and that has a
certain
set of
consequences
some courts would call them punitive and
that has a certain set of consequences
and what i was trying to do is figure
out
how to make the determination whether
they were punitive or preventative
well your note argued
that they were punitive and i would note
that that view
uh there have been some on the bench
that have advocated that uh the supreme
court in 1997 decided a case called
kansas versus hendrix in which it upheld
kansas's civil commitment statute
that was a 5-4 vote this has been a
question that has been
close at the supreme court
and
i would note beyond that that in terms
of the prevalence of these statutes all
50 states in d.c have registry
requirements
47 states have community notification
all 50 states have dna or blood banks
for sex offenders requirements
and 20 of the states the federal
government and dc have laws that allow
for the indefinite detention of sex
offenders
i would note in the state of texas a
street state court of appeals relying on
very much the the same sort of reasoning
you advocated in your note struck down
texas's sexually violent predator civil
commitment law
at the time i was the solicitor general
of texas i personally argued that appeal
in the texas supreme court
and the texas supreme court unanimously
reversed the court of appeals
and upheld our statute and and if the
views you advocated in law school
prevailed
civil commitment laws
across the country would be struck down
releasing sexual predators
and under the argument community
notification and dna bank laws could
well be struck down as well is that
is that an outcome that that should
concern people
senator my note wasn't advocating for
the striking down of those laws my note
was trying to identify criteria that i
thought could be applied consistently
to determine whether the laws were
punitive or preventative but with either
character and you argued that they were
punitive and you further say in the note
if they're punitive they're
unconstitutional i was looking at four
different kinds of laws and not all of
them did i say we're punitive okay so
let's take civil commitments laws
uh
if you look at civil commitment laws
right now the ucla school of law
williams institute estimates more than 6
sex offenders are currently detained in
civil commitment programs
if the view you advocated prevailed
presumably those 6 300 sex offenders
would be released to the public
is that an outcome that should be
concerning
senator
in law school when i was writing a note
i was looking at a brand new set
of laws that had not previously been
enacted in any jurisdiction they were
new
and i was assessing at the time as law
school students do
what
criteria i thought might be used by
courts to make a determination in the
future as to whether or not they should
be treated as punitive and therefore not
unconstitutional but as therefore
um
ones that carry with them certain rights
versus
excuse me preventative
those those
jackson so you've you've pointed that
these were reviews in law school and
listen i will recognize that all of us
when we are students may have views that
that as
time and maturity
passes on we may change but what
troubles me is this was not just
a law school view it's one that has
continued so when you were vice chairman
of the sentencing commission
you expressed significant concerns
um that the white house has argued that
your quotes were taken out of context so
i want to provide the full context of
your quote because
you said
yes i want to ask you about the means by
which we can distinguish more or less
serious offenders i know that all of you
sort of touched on that mr fettrell you
talked about going from singular to
one-on-one to group experience i'm just
wondering if there's some sort of
inevitable and natural progression from
one stage to the other such that you
could say that the least serious
offenders are in the singular experience
stage i guess my thought is in looking
at some of the testimony that other
people will have later in the day i was
surprised at some of the testimony with
respect to the motivation of offenders
and we're talking about child
pornography offenders and that there are
people who get involved with this kind
of activity who may not be pedophiles
and who may not be necessarily
interested really in the child
pornography but have other motivations
with respect to the use of technology
and being in the group and you know here
are lots of reasons perhaps why people
might engage in this and so i'm
wondering whether you could say that
there is a that there could be a less
serious child pornography offender who
is engaging in the type of conduct in
the group experience level because their
motivation
is the challenge or to use the
technology they're very sophisticated
technologically
but they aren't necessarily that
interested in the child pornography
piece of it
now now i find that a a pretty
remarkable argument that people in
possession of child pornography
are not actually interested in the child
porn they're not pedophiles they're just
interested in technology is is that
and i wanted to provide the whole quote
because the white house said that
portions of this were used out of
context so this is your entire quote
um
do you agree with that sentiment that
there is some
meaningful population of people who have
child pornography but but are not in
fact
pedophiles or getting
getting satisfaction from it
thank you senator for allowing me to
address
what appears to be a question
that i was asking in the context of a
hearing on child pornography you've
provided the entire quote and it looks
as though i was asking that of someone
not taking that position
and the position that i've taken in all
of my sentencings involving
child pornography offenders
is to ensure
that despite
the
attitude and um
view of many of the offenders who came
before me when i was a child judge that
they were just lookers that they weren't
really harming anyone that they were
curating their collections and they
never touched a child
i made sure that they understood
that notwithstanding their
uh collecting behavior that they were
causing significant harm
so judge jackson all right you you raise
your actual sentencing and i think
that's very productive let's let's take
a look
at your actual sentencing
and you've had ten different cases
involving child pornography
um
these are the cases there there are two
us versus butry and us versus
can
for which the government did not make a
recommendation and you said
earlier when when chairman durbin was
trying to preempt this line of attack he
said it's a sickening and egregious
crime which i very much agree with
um and you said the guidelines lead to
extreme departures okay
uh let's look at what the prosecutors
are asking for and i would note that
this was in the district of columbia
where prosecutors are far more liberal
than many of the prosecutors in this
country
and in every case in which so united
states versus hess there was a mandatory
statutory minimum of 60 months and you
imposed 60 months because you had no
discretion
uh in united states versus nickerson
there was a mutual agreement of the
parties to 120 months and that's what
you imposed
in every other case
united states versus chasen the
prosecutor asked for 78 to 97 months
you imposed 28 months 28 months
is a 64
reduction
in united states versus cooper the
prosecutor asked for 72 months
you imposed 60 months that was a
reduction
in united states versus downs the
prosecutor asked for 70 months you
imposed 60.
that was a 14 percent reduction
in united states versus hawkins the
prosecutor asked for 24 months you
imposed three months that was an
reduction in united states versus savage
the prosecutor asked for 49 months you
imposed 37. that was a 24
reduction in united states versus
stewart the prosecutor asked for 97
months you in post 57 that was a 41
reduction
every single case 100 percent of them
when prosecutors came before you with
child pornography cases
you sentenced the defenders to
substantially below not just the
guidelines which are way higher but what
the prosecutor asked for on average of
these cases
47.2 percent less now you said you made
sure
the voice of the children
was heard do you believe in a case
like united states versus hawkins
where the prosecutor asked for 24 months
and you sentenced the offender to only
three months do you believe the voice of
the children is heard when a hundred
percent of the time
you're sentencing child pronoun those in
possession of child pornography to far
below what the prosecutor's asking for
yes senator i do
could you explain how i will
a couple of observations one is that
your chart does not include
all of the factors that congress
has told judges to consider including
the probation office's recommendation
in these cases judge jackson we don't
have those probation the committee has
not been given the probation officer's
recommendation we would welcome them i
would look mr chairman i would love to
see those the second access the second
thing i would say
is that
i take these cases
very seriously as a mother
as someone who as a judge has to review
the actual evidence in these cases and
based on congress's requirement
take into account not only
the sentencing guidelines not only the
recommendations of the parties
but also things like
the stories of the victims
also things like
the nature and circumstances of the
offense the history and characteristics
of the defendant
congress
is the body that tells sentencing judges
what they're supposed to look at
and congress has said
that a judge is not playing a numbers
game
the judge
is looking
at all of these different factors and
making a determination in every case
based on
a number of different considerations and
in every case
i did my duty
to hold the defendants accountable in
light of the evidence and the
information that was presented to me
in a hundred percent of the cases was
the evidence less than the prosecutors
asked for
senator the evidence in this these cases
are egregious
the evidence in these cases are among
the worst that i have seen and yet as
congress
directs
judges don't just calculate the
guidelines and stop
judges have to take into account
the personal circumstances of the
defendant because that's a requirement
of congress
judges have to consider things like
the victims and when i was talking about
making sure that victims
circumstances are heard it was about my
sentencing practices
that that i could show victims being
heard with respect
thank you mr chairman
in 2012 the sentencing commission
on a unanimous bipartisan basis
issued a report recommending changes to
sentencing for non-production child
pornography which is the subject at hand
offenses because of widespread concern
among judges and other stakeholders for
example 70 percent of surveyed judges
said the guideline ranges for possession
receipt offenses were too high
71 percent said the mandatory minimums
were too high
notably the report was supported by
every member of the commission i believe
the question which senator texas was
referring to
was part of the proceedings that led to
that commission report unanimous
bipartisan basis commission report
mr chairman very briefly i would ask
unanimous consent that the books i
referenced be entered into the record
without objection
senator coons
thank you chairman durbin ranking member
grassley judge jackson
good to be with you good to be with you
senator i i'd like to take a few minutes
if i could and just give you a chance to
address some of the issues just raised
my colleague suggested that you've never
sentenced a defendant in a child
pornography case consistent with what
the government requested what the
prosecution requested
but according to my staff's research
that's just not true
so let me briefly ask you about three
specific sentencing cases do you
remember usv nickerson you sentenced
charles nickerson jr to 10 years in
prison
exactly what the government requested i
do senator do you remember usv fife you
sentenced him to 20 years in prison
exactly what the government requested
i do senator and do you recall usv negin
you sentenced him to 37 months in prison
exactly what the prosecution requested i
do senator so
in these three
cases it's also true that the government
the prosecution requested below
guidelines sentences would that seem
surprising to you at all it would not
and is that because overwhelmingly
nationwide in 70
of cases and in your district 80 percent
of cases
downward departures from the guidelines
are the norm
that is correct senator so
to the extent there seems to be some
concerted effort to try and
characterize you as being soft on crime
or
somehow
unconcerned about child safety
i just wanted to take another moment
and give you a chance to respond to that
as a parent
as the member of a family that's had
several members who've served your
brother your uncles in law enforcement
could you share a bit about how having
loved ones who serve as law enforcement
officers
in one case a detective on a sex crimes
unit has had an impact on your sense of
the balance of
justice and mercy in the case of
ensuring that we hold to account those
who commit crimes against children
thank you senator
as a mother
these cases involving sex crime crimes
against children
are harrowing
what i think is important to understand
is that
trial judges who have to deal with these
cases
are presented with the evidence
or
descriptions graphic descriptions these
are the cases
that wake you up at night
because
you're seeing the worst
of humanity
when
when there are victim statements
that are presented
when people talk about how their lives
have been destroyed
as children
how the people who they trusted
to take care of them
were abusing them in this way
and then putting the pictures on the
internet
for everyone to see
i sometimes still have nightmares about
the
main
witness the woman i mentioned earlier
who
cannot leave her house
because of
this kind of fear
the vulnerability the isolation
these crimes are are horrible
and so
i take them very seriously just as i
did all of the crimes but especially
crimes against children
so your honor if i could um the the
characterization that was just presented
uh in a recent column in the national
review a conservative publication
um has
characterized that
view of you as a smear that appears
meritless to the point of demagoguery
and characterizes your approach in
sentencing in these cases
as mainstream and correct
and i'll just remind my colleagues and
those watching that
two of the largest most substantial law
enforcement advocacy organizations in
our country the national fraternal order
of police and the international
association of chiefs of police have
spoken up
in support of your qualifications and
your capabilities
the fop letter
says there's little doubt you have the
temperament intellect legal experience
and family background to have earned
this appointment
that sentiment was echoed by the iacp
in their letter they said
you believe you have a deep
understanding of an appreciation for the
challenges and complexities confronting
the policing profession
and you have during your time as a judge
displayed your dedication to ensuring
our communities are safe and that the
interests of justice are served
i find it hard to believe that these
organizations having looked closely at
your judicial decisional record your
sentencing decisions
your lifetime conduct would have taken
those unusual steps to be that forceful
in supporting you if in fact you had
somehow a disturbing record of
coddling child pornographers or being
soft on crime
in fact judge your record in my view
demonstrates you're an even-handed and
impartial judge
and i can see that when i look at cases
you ruled on
that involve very politically charged or
partisan interests
you've delivered rulings on both sides
for plaintiffs and defendants
and in my review of your record you've
put any personal views or concerns aside
you based your decisions on the argument
of the parties the facts in the record
the applicable law and precedent
and the well-reasoned and thorough
opinions you've written
show to me
a judge striving to make even-handed
decisions based on facts and law
not on some caricature of a
leftist agenda
but don't just take my word for it
we've received an outpouring of support
for your nomination
as we'll hear on thursday a very wide
range of groups and individuals have
sent letters or testimony to this
committee in support of your nomination
it's no surprise to me that your your
legal mind your experience your
temperament
inspires strong support from some of the
best and brightest of our legal
community
and i think it's worth highlighting that
among those many who have written to us
are included well respected conservative
and republican lawyers and republican
appointed judges who agree
with my characterization that you're an
even-handed and impartial
judge we've received a letter from 24
conservative lawyers who held positions
in republican administrations or well
known for their conservative political
or legal views who wrote this committee
to urge your speedy confirmation
they praised your character and
intellect and called you and i quote a
truly excellent person
i'd like to focus though on the way that
these conservative lawyers
characterized your judicial decision
making which is after all the core
issue before us is whether you are the
sort of judge at the district court
circuit court that should be elevated to
the supreme court and they note in this
letter that in nearly 10 years on the
bench as a district judge and then the
court of appeals
judge jackson has been involved in
thousands of cases running the full
range of federal law you're
approximately 500 i think it's more than
570 now opinions written during this
time haven't i'm quoting demonstrated
complete command of the legal subject
matter a judicious and even-handed
approach
a fine ability to express yourself with
force and great clarity
they've also demonstrated and i'm
quoting another attribute essential for
a judge a sense of empathy for the
situations of others
judicious and even-handed
these prominent conservative lawyers
want this committee to know you're
judicious and even-handed and recommend
you for the supreme court without
reservation despite having noted they
differ with you concerning some
political or partisan issues and they're
not alone
judge griffith in a letter to this
committee and then followed up with
personal testimony in your introduction
yesterday
a judge appointed by former president
george w bush enthusiastically supports
your nomination i was struck by his
description of your intellectual
capacity your keen legal mind as well as
your character and judicial approach and
now i'm quoting from his testimony to
this committee yesterday
judge jackson he told us is an
independent jurist who adjudicates based
on the facts and the law
not as a partisan
he went on as justice scalia taught us
an indispensable feature of the republic
the constitution created
is an independent judiciary of judges
who've taken an oath not to a president
or a party but to the american people
and to god that they will be
impartial
and he concluded that you judge jackson
have demonstrated an unwavering
commitment to that oath
that's a conservative judge appointed by
a republican president who told this
committee he's confident you'll decide
cases based on the facts and the law
not as a partisan now i value the
working relationships i have with my
colleagues on both sides of the aisle we
can and do at times have fierce policy
disagreements but we also
work together to try and find ways as
lawmakers and individuals to respect
each other and i take it as a personal
sort of badge or source of pride when
someone with whom i really disagree on
one issue is able to legislate with me
on another
and so i imagine your honor it must be
gratifying
to know that a judge who literally sat
in judgment of reviewed
dozens and dozens of europeans in fact i
think you reversed you once oh more then
more than here is someone who closely
read and reviewed your decisions and as
a circuit judge sat in review of
your
work over years as a district hundreds
of opinions as a district court judge
and has such unequivocal praise for the
even-handed impartial thorough and
nonpartisan way
you've approached judicial decision
making
could you just briefly share with me
what it means to you to hear that
someone like judge griffith has such
confidence you would make an excellent
member of our highest court
thank you senator it means the world to
me to have
the support of judge griffith
his coming here yesterday and testifying
on my behalf
was
so gratifying
um
i have tried in every respect
to follow my methodology that enables me
to rule impartially in every case
and to understand the limits of my own
judicial authority
and therefore thereby reach decisions
without fear or favor
my record demonstrates
that i am not proceeding from any sort
of
preconceived notion about how a case
comes out
i'm not ruling consistent with any sort
of ideology i'm doing what impartial
and fair judges do which is to decide
in every case
based only on the facts and the law
of that
case and i'm very very pleased that
judge griffith
has seen that in the years that he
supervised me effectively as a court of
appeals judge when i was a district
judge
and i think it it's wonderful that he
was able to come here and testify to
that well judge
for those watching and um for those
following this that they might be
puzzled um because my colleague the
junior senator from the state of texas
has tried to ascribe all sorts of views
to you
in his recent questioning
that
try to paint you as some kind of a of an
activist with a radical agenda
and in my review of your experience and
your record these letters from
judges and scholars i i don't see
anything that remotely substantiates
that claim we are here to evaluate your
qualifications your judicial decision
making but so let me get at a few of
these points specifically if i could
i've heard references to the 1619
project and critical race theory
but i didn't hear that cited in any
reference to your opinions as a judge
in your nine years on the bench as a
district court judge
more than 570 decisions have you ever
cited the 1619 project no senator in
your nine years on the bench in more
than 570 opinions have you ever cited
the journalist or principal author of
that 16-19 project ms hannah jones i
have not and in your nine years in the
bench in more than 570 decisions have
you ever
used employed relied upon critical race
theory to determine the outcome of any
case or to impose any sentence or as a
as a framework for your decision making
no senator
um would you just explain to us briefly
what sort of factors you do in fact
consider in your analysis
senator when i analyze a case
i am looking at the arguments that the
parties
raise in the case
i'm looking at
the record
which is the facts of the case developed
if i'm on the court of appeals developed
below
and i'm looking at the law
i'm looking at any statutes i'm
queuing to the text i'm looking at
constitutional provisions to the extent
that they are applicable and any
precedence
related
to the case at issue
those are the inputs that are
appropriate for a judge to consider
and those are the only things that i use
in my decision making
well
i i appreciate your laying that out and
i i'll just
let me dig into two cases if i can that
i think are also probative here because
i i agree with the wide range of
supporters we've heard from that you've
demonstrated
an even an impartial judicial approach
in your record
but this is true not just in the
hundreds of sort of run-of-the-mill
um quotidian cases that are considered
by a district court judge but in several
that have been highly charged and really
quite political in terms of their
consequences
um i'd like to discuss your opinion in
the center for biological diversity
versus mechalenin do you recall that
case i do senator it was a dispute
between groups advocating for
environmental protection and the trump
administration's department of homeland
security
the dispute was about president trump's
efforts to quickly construct a physical
border wall between the united states
and mexico i'm sure i don't need to
remind you or anyone here that at the
time
um
democrats were just about unanimous in
thinking that physically building a wall
from coast to coast was not the
wisest use of resources to secure the
border there were other ways to do it
and with republicans pretty much
unanimously willing to defend it so it
was a policy matter with some sharp
divisions and some political
consequences
you ultimately rolled in favor of the
construction of the wall and against an
attempt by environmental groups to halt
its construction through
um legal case through a legal case can
you discuss what you recall just briefly
of the claims presented and how you came
to a decision in favor of the trump
administration
senator the claims in that case uh which
as you say were brought by an
environmental organization
um
related to the administrative procedures
act which is something that um we often
um see in the district of columbia
and whether or not the agency
uh could wave
certain environmental laws pertaining to
the construction of the wall whether or
not the agency's determination to do so
was lawful
and i looked at the relevant
um
[Music]
circumstances and i ended up i believe
dismissing that case
on threshold grounds before getting to
that point in the analysis but
consistent with what you said i was
guided
by my understanding of the law and what
it required
and not by anything else
i could spend a lot of time on the
details of this case
but let me try and summarize it this way
you analyzed the statute you concluded
congress had clearly blocked the courts
from hearing non-constitutional
challenges
there was no jurisdictional bar to the
constitutional claims to decide them you
considered whether the plaintiff's
claims were viable you looked for
precedent you found one
while not controlling you thought it was
legally sound um and persuasive
um but there was no controlling circuit
court or supreme court precedent
that stopped you
if you were in fact an activist judge a
motivated partisan determined
to let these plaintiff environmental
groups proceed you certainly could have
there was no clear precedent that barred
that from happening
you analyzed the statute
you applied the best precedent you could
find and you reached a result
without regard to the political
consequences
that is correct senator so in my view um
i wanted to talk about this case because
it it there's really nothing unusual or
special about it from your perspective
that is correct for those of us up here
there was a lot special and important
about it it was a highly charged
partisan and political issue but you
looked at the statute you found
persuasive precedent you applied it you
went on to the next case
let me ask about another decision
in a case addressing another very
politically charged issue and
specifically this involves the emails of
former secretary of state hillary
clinton
now the republican national committee or
the rnc is opposing your nomination
publicly accusing you of being a
partisan of a partisan democrat
and they argue you could not possibly be
an impartial justice but ironically back
in 2016 you presided over a case brought
by the rnc
against usaid
related to then presidential candidate
clinton
and you ruled in favor of the rnc
both the substance and the timing of the
case are really quite striking
i did the rnc made freedom of
information act requests for certain
emails involving the former secretary
and despite what the rnc would have us
now believe
um
in this case you reinforced your
deserved reputation for following the
law not a partisan agenda because you
ordered usaid to produce thousands of
pages of documents related to secretary
clinton do you recall when you issued
that decision that order i actually
don't
well i'll tell you it was just before
the presidential conventions so if there
was a moment when the rnc had a
political objective it was right before
the convention
and you actually issued a ruling that
they were entitled to email production
from the usaid on the basis of legal
arguments presented to you the statute
at issue and the evidence is that
correct that is correct
well your honor i'm you know i'm frankly
really struck um at the fact that you
know for all the
back and forth uh in senate hearings and
uh academic circles about the judicial
philosophy of supreme court nominees um
you've shown what the experience of
nearly a decade overwhelmingly spent on
the district court has produced a
methodology
an approach
that looks at the constitution the
statute the facts the arguments of the
parties and reaches a result
without fear or favor without taking
into account the partisan issue at stake
you know i don't believe that a judicial
philosophy
is always all that
meaningful the judge for whom i clerked
on the third circuit had spent years as
a district court judge and when i asked
her you know what's your judicial
philosophy she looked at me and said
i just call balls and strikes i'm a
judge who rolls on the case before me
exactly the same frame that you offered
a judicial philosophy does not in and of
itself constrain
a judge
what constrains a judge is a judge who
is willing to be constrained
who understands that the role of the
federal judiciary is a limited one
and so the real question i think a
president should consider when they make
a nomination the question that we as
senators need the answer to in order to
perform our function of advice and
consent and the question that i think
resonates best with the american people
who are concerned about
this hearing and this nomination and how
it will impact the country and their
lives is sort of
what kind of justice will you be we want
to know if you'll be fair
we want to know if you'll be faithful to
the constitution and to the rule of law
you've been a judge almost 10 years and
you've written more than 570
opinions
i'd say your record as a judge is the
best answer to the question what kind of
justice you will be
how would you say
your honor
that your approach to judging on the
district court relates to the way you
are now judging on the circuit court
and what approach do you think you will
bring with you if confirmed to the
supreme court
thank you senator
my approach all the way through
is one that i believe is required
by my duties by my oath as a judge
we rule without fear or favor
we are independent
as judges in our responsibilities
we
understand
at the district court level at the court
of appeals level and at the supreme
court
that judges
are restrained are constrained
in the exercise of our power under our
constitutional scheme
my methodology is designed to
help me to make decisions within those
confines
at every level
it's no different now that i'm on the
court of appeals than when i was on the
district court with respect to my
understanding
of the constraints on my authority
and my responsibility
to be impartial in my rulings
and i think it would be no different
at the supreme court
well your honor i i know we've walked
through just a few cases um today now
in some ways we've only scratched the
surface of your decade and the more than
570 opinions you've written
but it's clear to me from what i've
reviewed and from just this sample that
as we also heard from
colleagues from conservative lawyers
from judges who wrote to the committee
that you are judicious and even-handed
that you have a demonstrated record
of excellence that you adjudicate based
on the facts and the law and not as a
advocate activist or partisan
um and i encourage my colleagues who
want to know what kind of a justice
you'll be
to take a fair and even-handed
look at your record at your impartiality
and at your methodology
your experience is extensive and broad
your commitment to follow the law
impartially without the influence of
politics is evident in your record
your keen legal mind judicial
temperament and impeccable character are
plain to all
as judge griffith told this committee in
a review of your record makes clear
you've demonstrated that the way you
approach cases is based on the law
and not on some
political
agenda
you understand the reason why the robes
of our federal judges are black not red
or blue
the american justice system as many have
said
is rooted in the impartiality the
independence
and the reliability of our federal
judicial system is one of the most
critical bulwarks
of our system of ordered liberty
no wonder that when you came before this
body to be confirmed for the district
court then the circuit court
you earned and received bipartisan
support
i know president biden counts nominating
a supreme court justice among the most
significant decisions of his presidency
and our role here in the senate in
confirming a justice to our highest
court is among our most solemn
obligations and greatest privileges
so in nominating you i believe our
president has met his mission
and it will be my honor to join i hope
the overwhelming majority of my
colleagues in supporting your
confirmation as an associate justice of
the united states supreme court
thank you your honor thank you senator
coons last week the committee received a
letter judge from the national coalition
against domestic violence representing
survivors of domestic violence urging
the senate to swiftly confirm you to the
supreme court committee also received a
letter about your nomination from nine
separate organizations representing both
survivors of domestic violence and
sexual assault the letter said and i
quote jackson is highly qualified for
the position as her career and record
demonstrate her historic confirmation
the supreme court's first black woman
and the sixth woman overall will
represent monumental progress toward a
nation
it is charged to serve and that values
all of its citizens equally the
organizations also noted quote jackson's
rulings reflect the judicial consensus i
move to enter these letters into the
record without objection they will be
senator sash you're next up but we're on
a cusp of a vote so i want to be fair to
you we're going to take a break at this
point i'm going to
hope
i thought we were taking a break and
going to go vote but if you want me to
go first i'm good no i think we ought to
go over there and okay pray that he
comes along and we can return quickly so
why don't we declare this break time for
20 minutes 405 back in the room
my
okay
[Music]
here
so
right
[Music]
congratulations
and on the second day of the
confirmation hearing for judge kitanji
brown jackson senators getting 30
minutes each to question the supreme
court nominee
they're going in order of seniority of
the senators on the judiciary committee
and alternating party the next person to
ask questions will be ben sasse just
taking a break for votes underway on the
senate floor before the hearing began
judge jackson met with 44 senators
including all members of the committee
this is expected to be the longest day
of the hearing tomorrow a round of
follow-up questions 20 minutes for each
senator and on thursday members of the
american bar association and other
witnesses will testify kitanji brown
jackson nominated to replace justice
stephen breyer who's retiring she also
clerked for justice breyer you can
follow the hearing in its entirety on
c-span and join us as well online at
cspan.org
you can also use our mobile video app
c-span now to follow the hearing in its
entirety
california senator dianne feinstein
asked her questions earlier today we'll
take a look at some of them during the
joined break committee in january of
and a few months later we considered the
nomination of ruth bader ginsburg to the
supreme court
justice ginsburg's confirmation
made her only the second woman to ever
serve on the supreme court after justice
sandra day o'connor
so we have come a very long way since
then though still not far enough
women now make up
about 35 percent of active judges on the
federal district bench and 37 percent of
active judges on the federal appeals
courts
judge jackson if confirmed you would
become the sixth woman to ever serve on
the supreme court
you would join justices soda mayor kagan
and barrett on the bench
this would be the nearest we have ever
come to gender equity on the supreme
court there would be four women on a
court with nine justices
so i have my own thoughts about why
gender balance is important on our
nation's courts but i'd really like you
to tell us all what are your thoughts
on what it means for our country to have
women serve in meaningful members
meaning
meaningful numbers on the federal bench
and in particular what it would mean to
have four women serving on the supreme
court for the first time in history
thank you senator um
i think it's extreme all right we are
currently in a short break on day two a
very very long day of uh judge katanji
brown jackson's confirmation hearings
uh those that series of questions from
rafael edward cruz were
really off the wall
um and
you know i hate to say it but i'm trying
to kind of analyze it the way
a lot of people would see it i think it
was probably
quite effective
in the same way that glenn younkin's
fear-mongering about critical race
theory was effective in his virginia
gubernatorial race i know it's bs
you mostly know it's bs why why is it up
to katanji brown jackson
what is tot i mean you know she's what
how can how does that have anything to
do with the supreme court we know it
doesn't but i think it probably made an
impression on a whole bunch of people
and you know the oversized boards and
the entire thing
um
i think i think he did it for a reason
and it was likely
um
at least somewhat effective at least
but
to the people he's trying to convince
and remember the people he's trying to
convince are people who will see clips
on that on hannity tonight
it's not about convincing the hundred
people that will ultimately vote to
decide whether judge jackson makes it to
the supreme court or not but he's
sort of trying a case in the court of
public opinion
um
and that uh that that is what it is i
want to say thank you to alice maravius
for the twitch prime subscription we are
in the eighth hour can you imagine we're
in the eighth hour of today's stream
my initial thought was that we would cut
this at five
but it's it's gonna go much longer and
there may be continued uh delusional
delusional weaponized questions so i may
keep going i don't know we'll see
um we're gonna we're gonna look at it
strongly let's at least put it that way
and then we will go from there uh
today's coupon code is fix the court
let's fix it guys it's a right-wing mess
right now
it's a right-wing mess
uh qt jelly says i'm approaching my
longest stream of all time in a few
minutes
how can i see that where can is there
where can i see on twitch those
statistics does anybody know i would
love to look that up that's interesting
if anybody can tell me where to do that
i would check it out
twitch tracker let's check that out
twitch tractor
david parkman
here it is
an exact match was found i'll pull this
up for all of us
okay
summary
streams let's see here
streams by calendar day
stream duration
ah let's take yeah check this out
okay so here are some very interesting
statistical elements
so um
longest stream oh it's today we just did
it look at that we just did it i think
right hold on oh no no no no no we
didn't okay so we are
a third of an hour oh my god we're a
third of an hour from this being
the
longest stream ever on twitch and and
youtube i mean it's all it's all the
same in term from the standpoint of all
of that uh wow that's that's a big deal
so let's see if we can keep it going
um a lot of january 2020 streams which
were trump's impeachment
um
around election day
where is january 6th in all of this
january 7th
january 22nd
it's not a that seems like a mistake
well needless to say it's all very very
interesting and uh i i welcome everybody
to what will soon be the longest um
january 6th i was banned i don't
remember i don't remember that is that
true i don't remember that it's
interesting
anyway uh we're here that's the point
this we're streaming right now i think
and that's uh
what what else can we say i don't know
where i'm going with this okay
um
let me see
we have some
we don't even have any new voicemails to
play here
all right well no voicemails that's okay
no big deal
um
there are okay so let's think about how
long we have left so there's 22 senators
on the judiciary committee
how many have gone so far i think it's
is it nine are we not even ha we can't
possibly be only halfway through maybe
it's
elev actually don't know
12.
unless they speed up we might be here
till midnight
to be perfectly frank
yeah i don't know that uh yeah i'm
probably not
unless something were to explode here
i don't know that i'm streaming till
midnight but we'll see i mean that's i
i could be convinced i guess
uh okay let's take a look at some new
clips related to what's been going on
today
here is uh ted cruz asking judge jackson
about books she's not read
first book as young as eight and nine in
respect to the second book senator i
have not reviewed any of those books any
of those ideas they don't come up in my
work as a judge
which i'm respectfully here
to
address
can she comment on the skin tone of the
characters in good night moon please uh
because that is extraordinarily likely
to come up uh on this chord
in my work as a judge
which is evidenced
from my near decade on the bench okay
good i am then then let's go back to
your work as a judge
conceding that none of that had anything
to do with her work as a judge i guess
uh seemingly
seemingly
um
let's see what else we've got yeah here
is a picture of a oh i think this is
this is this the porn
that ted cruz
is intern liked that one time i think
that that's what that is
that's a nice photoshop i like that
um
let's see what else we have here
so judge jackson all of us will agree
that that no one should be discriminated
against because of race
when you just testified a minute ago
that you didn't know if critical race
theory was taught in k-12 i i will
confess i i find that statement a little
hard to reconcile
with the public record because if you
look at the georgetown day schools
curriculum
it is filled and overflowing with
critical race theory
that that among the doc the books that
are
either assigned
or recommended
they include
critical race theory and introduction
the end of policing and an advocacy for
obama is his argument that private
schools shouldn't be allowed to teach
what they want because it seems his
position is the opposite when it comes
to
like christian private schools
publishing police they include how to be
an anti-racist by ibrahim kendi
they include literally stacks and stacks
of books and i'll tell you two of the
ones that were most stunning
they include a book called anti-racist
baby uh by abram kennedy
and
they're ibrahim's a good guy he actually
he's he's a fan of the show and we've
we've corresponded
portions of this book
that i find
i've never even heard of this book by
the way really quite remarkable one
portion of the book
says babies
are taught
to be racist or anti-racist there is no
neutrality
another portion of the book
they recommend the babies confess
when being racist
now this is a book that i actually would
go further i i believe dogs should
confess to racism as well
uh very very important
important uh okay here's a picture of
phil spector in my feed and i don't i
don't really know why
we are standing by for the resumption of
questions for
judge katanji brown jackson it is day
two day two
um
cats don't need to confess because cats
are not racist obviously
hey david when you started the show
today um
or the stream you said
there's ted cruz he's going to be
disgusting today and i'm pleased to
report that uh he was in fact disgusting
yeah
that at least that's
that did happen yeah it did
the uh
the prediction was um
the prediction was was very much uh very
much correct yeah there's a great
curvier enthusiasm episode actually
where um
there is a racist dog actually if i
recall correctly
isn't the
larry larry's dog i think is initially
racist but then it's homophobic
against rosie o'donnell or it's the
opposite i think maybe the dog is
originally homophobic but then stops
barking at rosie o'donnell but starts
barking at wanda sykes
is that do i have that right
it's one it's one or it's i may have the
order transposed
but um
it is indeed one or the other
um okay let's see how we're doing from
the standpoint of the longest stream
ever
we are very very close very very close
to our longest stream ever which is a
big deal
okay bw rock says first supreme court
nominee to have a confirmation hearing
it was because it was a jewish man and
they didn't do another hearing again for
years interesting i i don't know that i
understand the reference
and i apologize for that
i'm just unsure
about that
um
yeah
i'll have to look into that
spencer says david sir i'm a music
educator and i would love to hear how
you got interested in playing drums
where you learn to play and what keeps
you playing i got interested in it
because i was curious what would it be
like to play the drums i learned to play
originally with a teacher in the town i
grew up in northampton massachusetts and
i keep playing because i like playing
sir yeah
uh coupon code not working coupon code's
working fine the you do have to the only
thing is you have to spell it correctly
but i assure you it's working fine the
coupon code today is fix the court i
would love it for you to sign up on my
website joinpakman.com
uh free item let's do it yeah next next
person to sign up on my website gets a
free item you could get a t-shirt a hat
a coffee mug tea mug juice mug water mug
coconut milk mug coconut water mug
coconut oil mug coconut oil mug yeah
okay
um
coconut butter
you can put anything you want in the mug
uh next person to sign up on my website
okay and uh fix the court is the coupon
code thanks to blueberry babe for
gifting a subscription on twitch
um i see a lot of people saying am i
committed to streaming this to the very
end i'm really not to be totally honest
but i'd be willing i mean like listen i
don't know if we got to 50
i will commit to streaming this to the
end how about that because it's a pretty
weak day so if i guess if someone dumps
in 29 twitch subs i'll commit to going
to the end and that may be famous last
words because at the rate that this is
going we may only be we may only be
halfway through which is very scary very
very scary that we may only be halfway
through it looks like people are
re-entering the hearing room and we will
soon be resuming
um can you put ice cream in the mug yeah
sure sometimes i will have ice cream of
my out of a mug i i will cop to that i
will cop to that
uh voicemail that just came in
sure i called canada to see if they
could return to cruise but they said
he's been discontinued
okay i heard the word ted cruz in this
but the audio quality
is such a disaster
that i don't
know that i can really even understand
what's being said
i called canada to see if they could
return ted cruz but they said he's been
discontinued
let me recover my ears for one second
yeah i don't i don't know that i uh i
don't know that i understood anything
about that i want to say thanks to jen
here for gifting a subscription and d4
ray for gifting five that's six putting
us at 27. also thanks to first aid geek
girl and milo wilde with a subscription
each putting us at 30.
a massive thank you to jeff curtis who
just signed up on my website jeff you
get a free item from my online store
please email info davidpakman.com
jeremybootin
also
uh dumping in a membership there dumps
yep
um putting us at 32 which i appreciate
also thanks to papa sweet and what a
shot
for the twitch prime subscriptions
putting us at 34 you have missed nothing
we are in hour eight if you can believe
it we are in hour eight
of today's stream and i believe we may
only be about halfway through as this as
a disturbing a reality as that is
there's 22 people who get to ask
questions
i think we've heard from either 11 or
13. i i mean i think we're barely
halfway if we're halfway
can any it is disturbing i know it's
it's wild thanks to catty catty ah
for the twitch prime subscription you're
number 35 today
now there's a lot of people saying david
this is the seventh hour you're only
seven hours and 40 minutes in guys
when you turn one
you're starting your second year of life
do people get this concept therefore
when you are at seven hours and 40
minutes you've completed seven hours
and 40 minutes of the eighth hour okay
that's why the second century is years
101 to 200 or 100 to 199
do people understand this please
please
i don't want to keep doing this it's
it's not i feel like it's not my fate to
just keep explaining that
thanks to lukan as well as an anonymous
gifter putting us at 37.
much appreciated
yeah man people are getting people are
just furious with me okay it looks like
we're back
and we're tired of it i know we're we're
going to be back soon dick durbin uh
having a snack
and a drink
very good
okay
no no you're not one year old when
you're born
your first year
is from zero to one
your second year
is from one to two
oh man
getting absolutely crushed in the chat
absolutely crushed
um
okay let's see if we can
break the tension with a voicemail here
i'm trying to see if i have anything
related to the hearing
which would be my preference
um
it's not really looking like it
this is lloyd from west virginia
uh being a white redneck myself
uh and completely supporting your show
as a white redneck thank you um
i think the use of the word
pernicious
is a little much for people like uh
i forget his name that wanted to debate
you
so i would actually argue that the word
pernicious is not enough the definition
of pernicious is having a harmful effect
in a gradual or subtle way
i would argue that some of these lunatic
magats
are more than just subtly or gradually
harmful i would argue that they are
aggressively harmful so i disagree with
the caller if anything it is not a harsh
enough word
not a harsh enough word
thank you to sumi long and jen here for
the twitch prime subscriptions
appreciate you guys very very much
is it fair to say lindsay acted today as
if he was between the ages of two and
three yeah sort of
more or less
i would i would go for that
um
see what else we've got here
hey david i'm not sure if this has been
asked already but as we all know with
the
recent umbrella uh uh
all right thank you very much for the
call we are in the middle of a level
five hype train on twitch and we are
moments away
from the longest stream ever let's see
if we've gotten there
uh no we are very very close very close
dangerously close to making this the
longest stream ever
um
couple other voicemails as we stand by
so
i wanted to encourage um it was against
germany just because
i really feel like this is all their
fault obviously
and although they sort of kind of
look like them but not really
very important i want to say thank you
to why my pie guy
as well as adam david lee for gifting
five subscriptions that's a total of six
putting us at 45 45
and uh
extremely important day
uh let's see what else we've got here
we've got a uh
voicemail from
[Music]
this guy
hey david how you doing sir i'm a uh
an avid watcher of your videos so this
is actually billy harrison the very
antagonistic caller pretending to just
be
some random caller appreciate your
content i appreciate the information you
try to get out to the
average layman like myself um
i am a
centrist uh middle the road type of uh
democrat i think um
trump is a
god-awful human being
and uh oh wait maybe this isn't billy
harrison it just sounds like him this
guy does not sound unhinged right now
i don't know why this country thinks
that a
game show host or a reality tv star
could do any good he damn near ruin this
country and everyone's so blinded by
stupidity that they think he's an
amazing person and i appreciate the
content you put out there i have learned
a lot off your channel yeah this is not
billy harrison this is someone who
sounds similar and calls from the same
area code learned a lot of things
uh keep up the fight man keep up the
good work brother um
please proceed
the hell is all those other schmucks out
there who's saying that you're
doing wrong and beautifully said no that
is not billy harrison i apologize for
that um
no word yet on whether machinery will
soon be completely shut down yes uh
people asking the mike pillow lawsuit
against machines continues we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines that's right
um
here's a commentary on my recent spanish
tortilla video
hi david i'm calling to say good job on
your short where you give a cooking
lesson i'm cooking a tortilla
you've obviously been listening to all
my voicemails and have taken my advice
on making better shorts you're
wearing a nice clothing the video
quality is good there's an overdubs
you're not dealing with bad audio
quality uh everything's planned out
the only thing i would uh
contest with though is you're not
wearing an apron that's right i did not
wear an apron nor did i wear safety
goggles while cooking anytime you cook
with oil you do have to be worried there
could be some splatter uh yeah no but a
lot of people like that by the way the
the spanish tortilla video i did the
other day
it really proves that there's nothing
you can do without being criticized on
the internet
looks like we're back on the record here
senator judiciary committee will come to
order the senator from nebraska senator
sass
thank you chairman
judge welcome back um by my quick
eyeballing count of this you are 51 done
as of this moment which feels more like
curse than blessing but i meant it is a
good thing thank you i think so this
could this could go until midnight
that's not a joke that's because if
we're halfway done we're seven hours in
all for spending time with me in my
office and thank you for answering the
questions of the committee today and
tomorrow um what you've said in public
matches what you've said in private and
that's obviously a testimony a testament
to your character
that also
can be helpful to rebuilding public
trust so thank you for the way you've
the ways you've engaged thus far
um judge you are
likely to go on to serve a lifetime
appointment on the supreme court which
means that this is very likely the last
job interview you ever have
um and the most public senator yeah
these processes are a lot like a
proctology exam
that means that it's an opportunity uh
for you to explain to the american
people how you view a supreme court
justice's job and the limits and bounds
on that job so i want to go back to a
topic that you and i have discussed a
few times which is how you approach
cases um you've told this committee and
you've told me in private um that you
don't have a judicial philosophy yet but
that you think of yourself as having
more of a judicial methodology um i'd
like to understand that a little bit
more
and i think it would be helpful for the
american people to understand that
argument and that distinction a bit more
as well
earlier today you said that you quote do
not believe there is a living
constitution and you also said that
you're constrained to interpret the text
and that's i think you said sometimes
that's enough to resolve the issue so i
think i've heard you pay partial tribute
uh to the judicial philosophy of
originalism but you've not adopted it or
embraced it as a philosophy or label
that applies to you
so maybe one of the places we could
tease that out a little bit more
is trying to um dig into whose
jurisprudence you most admire um we've
heard many nominees before like like
senator grassley former chairman of this
committee i'm not an attorney uh so the
farming and ranching people where i'm
where i come from uh know that john
kennedy is super smart rhodes lawyer who
kind of pretends to be uh you know aw
shucks kind of guy as he picks your
pocket um grassley and i get equal time
mr chairman
he all he always gets unequal time uh he
always gets bonus time uh but i think it
might be helpful for us to understand
who you most identify with and past
nominees before this committee have
talked about the mold of particular
justices they thought they followed in
and so if you had to tell the american
people who you're closest to
who is that justice or who are those
justices
well thank you for the question senator
and i
um
i must admit that i don't really have a
justice that i've
molded myself after or that i would what
i have is a record
i have
570 plus cases in which i have employed
the methodology that i described
and that
shows people this is smart if you name
anybody then they'll find the worst or
most controversial decisions of whoever
she names and ask her to say whether she
agrees with those decisions it's it's a
minefield this is a smart approach
thoroughly
all of the arguments that are made
in the case to me as a judge because i
want
in my lengthy opinions for people to
understand the inputs this i say is what
i'm considering because i lay out in
very
you know detailed way
everything that people have argued in
all of the cases and then when i'm doing
my interpretation
i am focused
on the text
of any statute or constitutional
provision
i am
looking as appropriate to
the intentions of the people who wrote
the words because i view statutory
interpretation constitutional
interpretation those exercises
consistent with my limited authority
i am conscious of
not
interpreting those texts
consistent with what i believe the
policy should be or what i think
uh the outcome should be
i am trying in every case that involves
that kind of interpretation
to assess
what it is that the parties
the parties who wrote the text intended
and
as a result because my methodology
involves um these various pieces and
um
because of the way in which i do things
i'm reluctant to
establish
or to adopt a particular label
because the idea of how you interpret is
just one part
of
the entirety of a judge's responsibility
as i mentioned you know i'm looking at
the
facts in a case and my experience as a
trial judge helps me to assess the facts
from all of the different perspectives
of the parties because i'm
able to
do that i think having heard from
parties in all sorts of cases directly
as they present their arguments that's a
part of the judging
responsibility that isn't really
captured by something like originalism
or living constitution and i believe
that the constitution is fixed in its
meaning
i believe that it's appropriate
to look at the original intent original
public meaning of the words when
one is trying to assess because again
that's a limitation on my authority to
import my own policy views
but there are times when
the meaning
unreasonable searches and seizures
due process
looking at those words
are not enough to tell you what they
actually mean you look at them in the
context of history
you look at the structure of the
constitution
you
look at the circumstances that you're
dealing with in comparison to
what
those words meant at the time that they
were adopted
and
you look at precedence that are related
to this topic
all of those tools judges use and i have
used is if
if you look at my cases
but when you say that you look at the
intent of the authors of a statute
sometimes courts have to say the people
who wrote this statute whether they
meant to or not have done something that
we the judiciary decides speaking in the
voice of you
is unconstitutional and deciding that
something is unconstitutional requires
an interpretive framework for how you
get there right and so you and i talked
to my office
about the differences between justices
kagan
breyer and sotomayor's judicial
philosophies and you told me that you
needed time to study that issue further
so assuming that you've had a chance to
think about that a bit more i guess i'd
ask you again
what are the differences among the three
of their judicial philosophies
with respect senator i have not actually
had time
with all of my meetings and with
senators and um the work that i've done
to to appear before you today i would
say
that there are differences as you see
from the various opinions that they have
issued uh i'm not sure yeah i also don't
know that it makes you more qualified to
be on the court to be able to present a
book report about the different
philosophies of three justices on the
court are looking at different
provisions they are using the various
tools that judges use and that i have
used
in my cases
the the idea of
striking down a statute as
unconstitutional is daunting and should
be daunting
i think for any judge or justice and and
had to be would have to be looked at
very carefully because
of the limited nature of the judicial
role and the fact that
the policies have been adopted by the
branch of government that has that
authority under the constitution
so i i guess i'm surprised after nine
years on the bench that
i mean you're super smart nobody
disputes that um and having worked for
justice briar and knowing of some of the
fights some of the philosophical
arguments he and justice kagan had um it
just seemed surprising that
you wouldn't be able to at least
speculate not speculate but reflect a
little bit on the nature of those
disagreements because to say it depends
on the particular case that's fine but
they have different philosophical and
hermeneutic approaches to the tax so
maybe another way to get at it um
i think
justice breyer again for whom you
clerked and justice scalia used to
travel together and uh have lively um
debate circuit conversations can you
tell the american people a little bit
about what breyer scalia
roadshow looked like what were they
arguing about
well my understanding is they were
arguing or at least presenting two
different
viewpoints as to how the constitution
should be interpreted and i would say um
just as an aside before talking about
their positions
um that
while i have been on the bench for nine
plus years the issue of constitutional
interpretation in that sense doesn't
come up very often
it comes up to the supreme court for
sure
but it doesn't come up very often in the
lower courts
what justice scalia and justice
breyer
i believe were
debating
was
the justice scalia's notion of
originalism meaning
that the words of the constitution
should be interpreted
as
they were written by the founders in the
founding era and that they should not be
considered to
essentially to establish principles
that modern justices could now apply
based on their own
view of the needs of society
and that justice breyer's position was
more toward that latter view that
the idea of um
the constitution needing to
be interpreted
in a way that is consistent with modern
sensibilities about
the principles
that the document reflects
and i would just say that
it appears now that the supreme court
has taken uh justice scalia's view that
the prevailing
interpretive
frame
for interpreting the constitution is now
very clearly
looking back through history so we see
that even in
um the heller case where the justices
even even the justices in descent
were all
analyzing the issues in the second
amendment
through a historical lens what what was
meant at the time of the founding so
that is now
the way in which constitutional
interpretation is done
but do you identify with that position
i identify with the position insofar as
that's how
uh the text is interpreted of the
constitution that i am a strong believer
as i said in
uh precedent in starry decisis in
predictability in the rule of law and
the way that the law now
interprets the constitution is through
this historical frame
um i'm grateful for your last couple of
minutes because i think that it's in the
american civic interest for us to
understand these different schools again
non-lawyer here but my uh simple way of
summarizing some of what i think i heard
you just say is that scalia argues hard
that the constitution has a fixed
meaning and justices aren't really free
to depart from it without a
constitutional amendment passed by the
political branches so that the voters
get to hire and fire the people or
have a role at the state level in the
ratification of a constitutional
amendment and breyer's position seems to
me
and i won't get it precise enough uh in
technical legal terms joe's prudential
terms probably to satisfy him but that
the constitution is speaking to more
abstract principles and therefore
there's a lot more play in the joints of
what a justice's job is and
i think the way you summarized their
debate was pretty fair and i also think
it's fair for us to want to understand
what your position is about it because
you're obviously
as i've said
incredibly uh smart and incredibly
likable and winsome and on the on the
stage for a lot of americans to look up
to i'm at the ra ra here here side of
that debate um at the level of what is
the supreme court justice's job i think
that's why a lot of us are still trying
to tease out the philosophical
distinction which i think is more than
just a methodology but i want to want to
thank you for that answer um you've also
brought up the the fourth amendment a
number of times in our conversation and
i would like to talk a little bit more
about the constitution and whether it's
meaning changes and so i'd like to go
back to the fourth amendment topic you
brought up in my office
you said i think that origin and correct
me if i'm miss summarizing your position
you said that originalism wouldn't have
much to say about the fourth amendment
because the founding fathers never
conceived of a tool a piece of
telecommunications equipment like this
and so i think during our conversation
you said that the original meaning of
the fourth amendment won't tell you much
about what to do with a new technology
my guess is that originalists and scalia
in particular would disagree
so what what do you do if the text of
the form this is by far the most
sensible discussion that has been had
with a republican on the panel so far
just to clarify what i intended to say
and i may well have misspoken um
there is an originalist take i think on
the question of what happens with a cell
phone
as the supreme court
held in the riley case there was a way
in which you
assess
principles of the constitution the text
of the constitution and apply it
to modern technology and you have to
because there's no question that cell
phones didn't exist at the time of the
founding so if the originalist principle
is now that's a fact that's not an
opinion okay there were no cell phones
when they did the constitution listed at
the time of the founding there would be
no answer
to what to do about a cell phone and so
what the supreme court has said and done
is
to determine
that the principle of the fourth
amendment with respect to
searches
is to determine whether there is a
reasonable expectation of privacy
they also have
looked at
property interests with respect to
whether or not there's an invasion of
privacy
and then determined from history
what that reasonable expectation of
privacy related to back at the time of
the founding
and analogized
to current circumstances related to
things like cell phones
it's it's a method of interpretation
that allows you to
instead of
the the alternative which would be
don't worry about the history just look
at the words in the constitution and say
what do i think is reasonable or
unreasonable with respect to police
officers searching cell phones that's
not the way the supreme court handles it
they try to determine
what was unreasonable
historically
and then given those principles
historically it would be unreasonable
for police officers to enter someone's
home to rifle through their papers and
documents they then analogize to
current circumstances and the fact that
a cell phone is like your personal file
cabinet and they say
okay given what we understood the
framers to have intended about the need
for a warrant or the need for uh
protection against unreasonable searches
we're going to apply that
to modern circumstances it's still an
originalist way
quite sensibly
the current dispute
so are there non-originalist ways to
wrestle through that same question and
what would they be
one could imagine
that rather than
referencing history at all
that the court would look at the
constitution it says no unreasonable
searches and seizures
and would just ask in the in
you know in light of modern
sensibilities in light of what we would
think would be reasonable today or what
the court itself would think would be
reasonable today
we'd apply that that modern
understanding
to
the cell phone situation
and the danger i think justice scalia
would say is that that's a kind of
framing
that permits
judges
to
make a determination based on their own
views rather
than hewing themselves as as senator lee
said before that justice barrett pointed
out hewing themselves to the text of the
constitution
and does breyer have a different view
you know i haven't um
i'm just trying to think i i my
understanding of the living
constitutional principle is that it's
closer to
looking at the needs of modern society
but i'm i'm
not well versed in it in part because
the supreme court has now so clearly
taken
the historical perspective
uh the originalist perspective in its
interpretations
you brought up the cell phone example
with me but i know you have others what
are some other areas of life where the
original meaning seems to be
two and a half centuries removed what
are what are places that the
constitution seems to not speak to
well senator i you know i'm
reluctant to s
spell out uh different circumstances
what i will say is that
when you look at the language
in the constitution
there are some provisions that are
completely
clear on their face without any question
of what was intended the age of
the required age of senators the
required age of the minimum age of the
president these kinds of provisions all
you need is the text
and there you are
but there are provisions of the
constitution
that are broader than that and therefore
some interpretive
frame
is necessary
and to the extent i mean every question
the supreme court gets
that involves new technology for example
that relates to constitutional
provisions
will require some kind of analogy i
think um
but you know i can't speak to
to anything more than that
you have described justice breyer's uh
constitutional approach as pragmatic
what does that mean
i understand it to be um
and his approach
to be
about
ensuring that the rules
that follow
from the supreme court's determinations
are ones that
make sense and are workable
um
he he said recently
explaining his approach to interpreting
a statute you're not going to go outside
the words but it often doesn't give you
the answer and you look at the history
and you look at its purposes and you
look at the consequences too and you'll
try to evaluate them from that the point
of view of what a reasonable legislature
writing this statute have thought that
these words were there to achieve
do you do you align yourself with that
position
in the broad sense
that what it is that the court
is tasked with
um when statutory interpretation is
being undertaken
is to achieve
the purposes of the legislature
the text
is the
primary and in most cases sole
indication of what the legislature
intended
as opposed to the court saying
i see this statute but i'm you know
uncomfortable with
how it's going to turn out or what it's
going to mean and so i'm going to import
my own policy perspective
instead the court is constrained to say
regardless of what
i think the right policy objective
should be in this with respect to this
law
my purpose my
requirement
is to determine what congress intended
but with respect to legislative intent
when a congress of
535 often distracted people 100 in this
body and 435 and the other pass
something you know by a two to one-ish
vote
um
and it's a part of a large piece of
legislation how do you how do you
determine what the intent is when it's
535 people doing something that has many
many different purposes for why somebody
might vote yes
well you you look at the text i mean the
the
the way in which
statutes are interpreted
is based on what the legislature says
there are times in which there are
statutes
in which congress includes a purpose
statement for example
in the actual text of the statute
you look at the text of the provision
if that isn't clear you look at the
structure of the statute
there are cannons of interpretation that
courts use to
evaluate and interpret statutes things
like
the
a word that appears in the section that
you are interpreting
should be defined the same way it is in
another section
you know the same word being used
congress probably intended to
um
for it to have the same meaning
so
there are tools in the law that exist to
help courts to interpret the text but
again the
goal
is to interpret the text
um
as a means of
understanding and reflecting what
congress intended and of course in
statutory interpretation
if congress decides that the court has
gotten it wrong
then as this happened many times
congress comes back and clarifies and
tells the court no this is this is what
the statute means
i want to go back to an exchange you had
with senator cornyn
substantive due process
is a doctrine that often allows courts
to create new fundamental rights
what's the test for determining a new
fundamental right
the supreme court has said in the
glecksburg case
that
the fundamental rights that are
recognized or that are are included in
substantive due process
um are those that are deeply rooted in
the nation's history and tradition
in a case prior to that the court had
defined it as the rights that are
implicit in
the ordered concept of liberty or the
concept of ordered liberty
um
so there are standards for the courts to
use to identify these these types of
rights
so did the supreme court use this test
in row or casey
in row in casey
i don't know that the court used that
formulation
um
i know that after casey the court
has determined
um
not so much that
the right
to terminate a woman's pregnancy is
fundamental
the the right exists and
it's subject to the framework in casey
uh that allows for
uh regulation
um
so long as there's not an undue burden
on the exercise of the right
pre-viability i i think some of what
we're wrestling with here is the
question of and i think what senator
cornyn was driving at is how particular
the concept of deeply rooted goes and
how that really is abound uh on what the
judiciary can do but i want to thank you
we're nearly at time i want to thank you
for engaging in the back and forth i
want to think more about what you've
said and look forward to further
discussion tomorrow it it still appears
to me that there's a very basic
difference between a judicial philosophy
and a judicial methodology
into and how you go about applying that
when you're interpreting a law and
making a determination about
constitutionality or non and i
know that you haven't claimed
a judicial philosophy at all but a
judicial philosophy of originalism here
but i do think the fact that you've at
least nodded to it uh in the committee
hearing today is in and of itself a
pretty great testimony to how much of
scalia and bork's work has has moved to
the legal field so i'm grateful for for
the time you're taking with us i'll look
at listening tonight and talking with
you again tomorrow thank you thank you
senator sass senator blumenthal
thanks mr chairman uh
thank you judge for your
patience and your perseverance uh
i want to begin just
by thanking also for an extraordinary
moment in our history
i think we all as americans
feel excitement and pride
in
really making history here and we'll
continue and i'll be back picture's
worth a thousand words as i look at your
parents
and your husband
and your daughters
uh
what i see is america
and the best of america
so i think we should all feel that
excitement and pride in this moment and
the extraordinary journey that has
brought you here you will
make the court look more like america
but also
think more
like america
in the obstacles and challenges that
you've overcome to be here we don't know
all of them
but
you will provide a
very important perspective indeed a
unique perspective that the court
needs more than ever at this moment in
its history there are a lot of people
who are book smart
there are not as many people who are
person smart and you are both
that kind of emotional intelligence
is what our courts need
not just our supreme court
so i want to really begin by asking you
as a role model for others
to talk a little bit to
the
young women and girls of america
particularly black
young women and girls
about those challenges
and obstacles that you've had to
overcome
to be here and what's helped you do it
thank you senator
i am humbled and honored
to have the opportunity to
serve in this capacity and to be the
first
and only black woman to serve on the
united states supreme court
i
stand on the shoulders of
generations past
who
never had anything close to this
opportunity
who were the first and the only
uh in a lot of different fields my
parents as i said were the first in
their families to have the chance to go
to college
i've been the first and the only in
certain
aspects of my life so i would say
that i agree with you that this is a
moment that
all americans should
should be proud
now you've never been a prosecutor
a lot of us on this panel have been
prosecutors i was the u.s attorney the
chief federal prosecutor in connecticut
for four and a half years and then i was
attorney general of my state
for
20 years
but
i would say one of the most meaningful
[Music]
cases in my career was
as a defense counsel
i was asked by the naacp legal defense
fund to represent
a black man on death row in your home
state of florida he had been convicted
of
murder
and rape
had been on death row
for a number of years
and i took the case because i was asked
to do it
and eventually
somewhat to my surprise found in fact he
had never done
the crime
of which he had been convicted
and eventually we won his freedom
because the prosecutor in the case
concealed
evidence which was a violation of his
constitutional rights
and
he was a free man
as a result
your husband
as a surgeon saves lives lawyers don't
do it often
but
i know from personal experience the
importance of having
a good
representative an advocate a council
because in that case he had been denied
it when he originally went to trial and
only after years in both state and
federal courts
was the truth
vindicated
so
i want you to talk a little bit about
why it is important
for
defendants to be represented by zealous
really aggressive and energetic
advocates who
tell the truth to the court put on the
evidence
and present the best possible case for a
defendant accused of a crime
thank you senator
the idea
is one that is rooted in our
constitution
the framers were
concerned about government overreach
in a lot of different areas
the provisions of our constitution are
protecting
individual liberty
from
government overreach this is why we have
provisions about limited government
and there are many provisions in the
constitution that are
limiting government action when it comes
to the deprivation of liberty
because the framers understood how
important liberty is
to
our society and so there's the fourth
amendment there's the fifth amendment
there's the sixth amendment there's the
eighth amendment
these provisions are crucial and
it is
zealous defense counsel
that ensures that the government
is protecting these rights that ensures
that these rights are protected and that
people are getting due process in the
criminal justice system and that's to
all of our benefit
that helps everyone in america
when we ensure
that liberty cannot be denied without
due process
it's defense counsel as i said who are
making arguments and they're not
condoning
the criminal behavior
they're making arguments on behalf of
clients
in defense of the constitution and these
constitutional values and as a judge i
now see
how important it is
for me to be able to
make my decisions
after hearing from both sides
that's crucial we have an adversarial
system which means
that judges are presented with arguments
from both the prosecution and the
defense
and only when i'm able to hear from both
sides can i make
a just
fair determination
and fairness is the hallmark of our
constitutional scheme and it's what
makes us
the best criminal justice system in the
world
and it's not only the reality of
fairness but also the perception of
fairness the public's understanding of
how courts work that is essential to the
credibility that courts have correct
that is correct
and so i feel very strongly
i know that a number of us on the
committee agree that
more transparency more visibility is
important for the public to understand
what goes on in the courtroom
i know you
feel transparency is a good thing
you've been asked about cameras in the
courtroom i'm a supporter of
senator grassley's sunshine in the
courtroom
act as well as uh senator durbin's
cameras in the courtroom act
uh i am hopeful that the court the
united states supreme court actually
will back these proposals because their
support would be very important
tell me how you feel
about the basic principle of
transparency and more visibility
well senator
one of the reasons as i said that i
write such long opinions um is because
i want everybody to know exactly
the arguments i've considered
the facts that i've reviewed
and
in pretty fine detail
the course of my reasoning and i've done
this in
570 opinions
i think it's important
for public confidence as you say
for
people
who are bound by the law
and who are affected by the courts
to know
what the court's views are
with respect to the issue of cameras in
the courtroom i understand that that is
something that is proceeding through
congress and
if i was confirmed i would look forward
to talking with my
colleagues to understand the positions
uh that people have regarding that issue
i appreciate that response uh one of the
other
areas that i think is important to
transparency and to public trust and
confidence in the court
is visibility as to
its own decisions
which
i think is directly contradicted by the
shadow docket you've been asked about it
before but i just want
folks understand
that some of the
most important decisions the supreme
court have been decided
or at least
issues resolved
without oral argument without briefs
without
any public explanation
a controversial
travel ban
has gone into effect
the first federal execution in 17 years
was permitted
uh statewide covet restrictions were
enabled the collection of data in the
2020 united states sense census and
enforcement of voting restrictions in
the 2020 presidential elections as well
as decisions relating to immigration and
blocking the
byte administration from enforcing
a federal moratorium on evictions
imposed because of the covet 19
epidemic americans have a right to an
open full fair
proceeding with a record
of the court's reasons for making
decisions so
i hope that you will
urge your colleagues when you talk to
them about cameras in the courtroom also
to do less on the shadow docket
and i hope that perhaps
if they don't congress will take some
action
i uh finally want to ask uh so far as
this issue of transparency is concerned
about
um
codes of ethics
you have followed a code of ethics as a
district court judge and court of
appeals judge correct
i have
does that code of ethics apply to the
united states supreme court
my understanding is that it does not
correct
um
and uh my hope is that you will perhaps
urge your colleagues as well to support
a code of ethics they haven't done so as
yet but i think we have an obligation
in the congress to set forth a code of
ethics and i hope they'll support it uh
senator durbin and
others of us have supported that that
kind of measure as well
um
and i i would just ask you
whether you'll raise it with your
colleagues if you're confirmed
senator um
certainly if congress is taking anything
up and that requires our review i would
absolutely
um i would absolutely consider it to and
even if not i would would consider it
talking to them about it thank you
uh you know the reason i raised these
points is that um
i
respect the united states supreme court
i've argued four cases before it
i was a law clerk to justice blackmon uh
who by the way was from minnesota mr
chairman
uh
in fact he was known
as one of the minnesota twins when he
was appointed because he was thought to
be
exactly like
then chief justice warren berger who
also was from minnesota in his very
very conservative views
and as it
happened
justice blackman became one of
the most progressive members of
the court
over the years that he served he had a
capacity
for growth and for learning and
listening which i believe you have and i
think it is one of the most important
characteristics of anybody who
serves
on the court
but
i do think the court's crisis of
legitimacy is the result of divisions
within the court
the polarization and politicization that
has drawn lines
the process that has happened in recent
years
in confirmation proceedings
and so i really think that consensus
building
building bridges with your colleagues
will be immensely important i think
that's one of the reasons that
the president chose you
having talked to him about it
that you have that kind of persuasive
and forceful intellect but also the
personal
and
warmth and depth that will enable you to
do it
maybe you can tell this committee about
how you worked on the sentencing
commission for example
or in your previous experiences on that
kind of consensus building
thank you senator um consensus building
was one of the things that
justice breyer was particularly good at
in terms of his
personality in the time that i clerked
for him i witnessed
the way in which he continually reaches
out
to
colleagues continually seeks
common ground
and it's something that i would
hope to be able to emulate if i
were to be confirmed
when i worked on the sentencing
commission the commission is a seven
member body
um
working on sentencing policy
which is at times a pretty
contentious effort because we're talking
about
criminal justice
as commissioners we are working on
policy issues related to
uh appropriate sentencings and
um
by statute
the commission is is a bipartisan group
and during my four years as a
commissioner
i was
able to work
well with other members of the
commission
to find common ground to work on issues
to come together and
the vast majority i heard a statistic
that something like 95 or 97 percent of
the votes that the commission took
were unanimous
and that that happened because of a lot
of effort and in intention on the
parties on the part of all involved
to see if we could work together
and that would be the kind of thing that
um
that i would hope to do
if i was confirmed to the supreme court
you've mentioned in your previous
testimony the challenges of
applying the law to evolving in new
technology
obviously
the internet raises exactly those
questions congress passed the electronic
communications privacy act in 1986
when the internet was barely
recognizable it was nascent
just
starting
and
now
our nation faces a mental height health
crisis
it is partly
aggravated by the pandemic the isolation
and anxiety that's resulted from but
also by the internet
and by the tech platforms that drive
toxic
content at children
as a result of these black box
algorithms that nobody really
understands literally no one understands
because
the
tech platforms want to keep them
secret
and
we are trying to
upgrade the law and update it
to give parents tools
to have greater visibility as to what
their
children are doing and to give parents
and children
tools
to protect them against some of the
bullying and
eating disorder content and even
suicidal and substance abuse
stuff that
they are
driven to see
and senator blackburn and i have
introduced a bipartisan measure of the
kids online safety act
that will
provide a more modern solution to a
modern problem
to update
the law to account for
the role of social media in
our ongoing and aggravating
mental health crisis in this country
uh do you agree that it helps the
supreme court
and judges in general to do
their job when congress updates our
statutes
to account for technological change
thank you senator
the role of
the court
is to
interpret statutes when
there are disputes related to the
statutes and
in circumstances in which statutes have
not been updated
i don't think it's surprising
to note that
there are disputes
about the meaning of the statute about
how it applies
and so
to the extent that congress undertakes
to
make amendments and
make the changes
i think it helps
courts maybe there'll be fewer disputes
or
easier disputes to resolve easier
disputes to resolve in the sense that
and i've seen it happen a judge will say
i don't know what congress meant to do
in this kind of situation because
this law was written at a time when
none of this stuff now existed i'm sure
you faced that
situation i think it's true
of
social media and the dangers to
children as a result of the toxic
content that they often find and often
seemingly are
addicted to use again and again and
again because it's part of the business
model
of those social media and big tech
platforms
yes i have i have faced this situation
one of my cases the
alliance of
artists and recording companies versus
general motors is a case
that i ended up writing a couple of
opinions about
and involved
a statute of congress
related to
digital recording audio devices
and whether or not royalties were
required for
the purchase of those kinds of devices
and it was enacted at a time in which
recording technology was at a different
stage
than it is now
and disputes
arose that came before me regarding
whether or not to
apply the royalty
requirement in that statute to
modern recording devices and in
particular the recording devices that
are now in automobiles
when you take your cv and you put it in
your own car and record
record onto the hard drive of your car
is that the same thing as
putting your cd in one of those machines
that records from cd to cd
and you give your the the second
recording to all of your friends that
was
that was what the statute was originally
meant to
cover and the question was whether uh
recording to your own car's hard drive
counted
and it was a very interesting
interpretive exercise but again it was
the kind of thing in which
i was focused on
trying to ascertain what
based on the text of the statute and the
definitions in the statute
what congress
intended this statute to cover
and
cars
other devices appliances at home
collect huge amounts of data don't they
and
as consumers we feel we own that data
it's ours
but it can be bought and sold exchanged
and mined
in a way that right now consumers have
no consent over
uh
and it enhances
the dominance of just a few of those
tech companies just a few of the
corporations corporate power
is
emboldened and
enabled in many respects by the amount
of data they collect it's also
enabled by forced arbitration we've had
a reference to it already today
with respect to
complaints about sexual harassment which
fortunately
uh we have addressed i've been uh proud
to work on the
ending forced arbitration of sexual
assault and
sexual harassment act which president
biden signed after we passed it uh just
a
few weeks ago
i've heard harrowing stories
from survivors of sexual assault
and victims of workplace
harassment who were silenced and denied
justice by forced arbitration but forced
arbitration applies as well
to
everybody who has a cell phone
you have a forced arbitration agreement
many workers have forced arbitration
agreements
nursing homes have forced arbitration
the point is that you have dedicated
your life
to access to the courts
the right of a trial the right to a jury
the right to a judge none of it is
possible where there is a forced
arbitration
agreement that's why
i've worked on a measure called the fair
act
that would
make any
forced pre-dispute arbitration agreement
invalid and unenforceable if both sides
want arbitration that's fine but access
to the courts
should be available to everyone
i know that you're limited as to what
you can say about measures and
that are before us and policy issues
but i hope that you
will consider
the trend that the court has adopted
in support of
forced arbitration and denial of rights
like class action
and review whether they are appropriate
uh let me just uh
finish with a couple of quick points
first of all on the harvard law school
harvard law review article
on
registration of sex offenders convicted
sex offenders
i must say uh i read this article
several times
in my view
it is
analysis not advocacy
would you agree
absolutely senator as a law school
student
i was trying to do what law school
students do which is
analyze
a new
set of legal provisions these laws were
new
and i was trying to
um assess
what
criteria courts could use to look at
them i was not making an argument about
them at all
exactly and by the way one of those
statues was in connecticut
it was challenged
on constitutional grounds double
jeopardy
it went to the united states supreme
court
i defended it there
it was upheld
i don't know whether your article was
cited
but uh i would put this
law review article very much in the
category of analysis the distinction
between prevention and
punishment uh i would
call it
protection
not
punishment or prevention
that's the argument that i made to the
supreme court
uh i ask that this article will be put
in the record mr chairman
without objection
uh by the way it took me two or three
times to get through it so
uh no disrespect to you or the harvard
law of you
um
the um
the issue of
child pornography
um
you reckon you you mentioned i think
that in your decisions on these
sentencing cases
involving child sexual abuse material
which by the way i agree is absolutely
horrific
abhorrent
it's the reason that
senator graham and i have actually
sponsored a measure called the earn it
act that addresses it
but you said that you imposed a sentence
that matched the recommendation
by either the prosecution or the
probation office
in
most
of the cases where you did that
sentencing is that is that right you
have that
yes senators uh in looking back at um
the records concerning
my cases
um
it looks as though i had
cases that involved either
child pornography
internet
interstate travel to meet up with a
child for sex the sex crimes related to
children
and in 10 of those 14 cases i imposed a
sentence that was
consistent with or greater than
what either the government or the
prosecution
uh requested
their probation excuse me sorry
the government or the probation office
and let me just ask you the probation
office
is an independent arm
of the court
that investigates the defendant
looks at the crime
the defendant's background
his family situation
all of the relevant factors
involved in sensing including the
sentencing guidelines and then
independently and
impartially
makes a recommendation
presumably to serve the interests of
justice in that particular case based on
the individual facts there is that
roughly a correct description that is
correct senator the probation office uh
works within the court system
they are independent of the parties and
they
investigate and make recommendations
in cases
concerning what the probation office
thinks is an appropriate sentence
thank you
let me just finish by saying uh
much of america is watching these
proceedings on a split screen
on
one hand they are literally seeing
the death and destruction in ukraine
russia's brutal barbaric
assault on
individual rights
basic freedoms
that we often take for granted here
and we are exercising exercising those
rights right here
you are
a teaching
lesson this proceeding is a
teaching lesson about the importance of
democracy
the people of ukraine are fighting for
it they are dying in their neighborhoods
and streets
and their homes they are huddled in
basements
they're
men and women
are
resisting valiantly and braving bravely
against
a huge military
force that russia has unleashed and a
reign of terror from the skies simply
because they believe in the ideals
of freedom and law
that we are seeking to preserve here
and so on this side of that split screen
i think it's important that we do our
best to honor
the norms and the rules that you've
sought to uphold throughout your life
and i'm
proud and excited
to be here
with
you and your family
as we go through this process and i look
forward
as i hope
many of us do to
a bipartisan majority in support of your
candidacy thank you thanks mr chairman
thank you thank you senator blumenthal
i'd like to bring everyone up to date we
have several considerations the
remaining senators for questions
the endurance of our witness
judge jackson
votes on the floor
uh request for compassionate release by
a number of people in the audience
here is where we stand
we're going to have senator hawley
followed by senator hirono then we're
going to take a 20-minute break
because that's when we think there'll be
some votes on the floor we can take care
of those and get back in 20 minutes then
we will return from that break to
senators cotton and booker
then we'll take a 30-minute break or so
for dinner
then it'll be senator kennedy padilla
and tillis
and we're going to start off tomorrow
with our two
senators ossoff and blackburn
so we should finish in the 9 to ten
o'clock hour this evening
god willing so at this point uh i
recognize senator hawley thank you mr
chairman judge nice to see you again
thank you again for being here
congratulations again on your nomination
i i want to start uh where senator
blumenthal left off i want to talk with
you about some of these cases i
mentioned them yesterday so i know you
know which ones i want to talk about the
seven cases
child pornography cases in which you had
discretion they came before you you had
discretion to sentence one way or
another in these seven cases not every
case of course do you have discretion
sometimes the law requires you to impose
a sentence certain sense but in these
seven you had discretion and each of
these seven you chose to depart both
from the federal guidelines
and also from the government's the
prosecutor's recommendation senator
lee's asked you a little bit about this
senator cruz has asked you about it he
had a chart with the seven cases on it
before we jump into those i just want to
correct the record on one or two things
senator coons suggested that in three
cases nickerson win and fife
you actually impose sentences either
within the guidelines or at the same
level the prosecution but in nickerson
you didn't have any discretion that was
an 11 c1c case the law bound you and
wynn wasn't a child porn case and
neither was fife
just one other quick thing to clarify as
to these comments about the probation
office the probation office doesn't
issue national guidelines right i mean
the probation office doesn't issue
sentencing guidelines they're not public
they're not recommended to all judges
the probation office provides advice
to judges case by case usually in
private usually
not available to the public is that
right judge
not exactly senator
the probation office
in uh criminal cases
is assigned by the court
to work
with respect to
the evaluation of cases in every case
consistent with
congress's requirements
the probation office prepares
a
pre-sentence report
in which they review
all of the statutory factors
concerning sentencing congress has a
statute
for sentencing
it requires uh judges to consider the
nature and circumstances of the offense
the history and characteristics of the
defendant the need for the sentence
imposed to promote
various purposes of punishment
there are many purposes listed in the
statute
and the probation office
is the arm of the court
that does factual investigations in
every criminal case unless
there are certain cases in which you can
wave it but the background
is the probation office's assessment
of
the facts related to
a particular
sentence and a particular crime and the
the probation officers report when a
court sentences
actually
uh in most cases becomes the findings of
fact of the court and so the probation
office appears
just like
the prosecution and the defense the
probation office has written a report
and they
make a recommendation
to the court
based on their independent analysis
related to the facts of a particular
crime and defendant and sentence
understood so they they give the court
counsel understood
uh however they don't issue guidelines
they're not uniform it is by its very
nature a case-by-case inquiry as you
said the report goes to the judge
as i understand it the the
pre-sentencing report i'm sorry the
probation reports are are not public in
all of the cases that we're talking
about here i'd love to see them
if they are
but uh it's not as if there's one set of
guidelines that are federal sentencing
guidelines and then there's the
probation guidelines the probation
office is giving advice to the judge it
varies case by case senator it's not
it's not it's not the same
sorry i thought you were done that's all
right let me ask you about a specific
case i mean let's talk about i i listed
these seven cases in which you had
discretion and you did not follow the
prosecutor's recommendation or the
sentencing guidelines but let's just
talk about one of them because we've
talked about some of them as a group
let's talk about united states versus
hawkins i think that's when you probably
remember from 2013 the defendant there
was wesley hawkins he was 18 years old
at the time he uploaded five video files
of child pornography from his computer
to youtube this is how the police got
onto him he then uploaded another 36
depictions of child porn and other lewd
photos of children to his icloud account
when the police executed a search on his
apartment on the premises they found 17
videos on his laptop and 16 images of
child pornography
all of them
very graphic
some of them involving
very young children 17 videos in
particular this is from the government
sentencing memorandum in this case just
so we understand the facts here are some
of the videos that the government
charged that they recovered
there was a 24-6
24-minute six-second video depicting a
12-year-old male
committing a sexual act i'm not gonna
i'm not going to read exactly what it
was
there was a one minute and 57 second
minute video depicting an eight-year-old
committing a sexual act there was an 11
minute and 47 second video depicting an
11 year old
committing
a sexual act and being raped by an adult
male
there was a 15 minute and 19 second
video depicting two 11 year olds
committing sexual acts there was a seven
minute and 51 second video depicting a
12 year old
committing a sexual act so
as the government said in this case and
i'm quoting now from the transcript of
the sentencing hearing 17 videos is a
lot
and some of the videos including the
ones that are described in the statement
of the offense and i've just related
some of them are very lengthy
and include numerous images numerous
views sometimes collages sometimes
multiple victims you see the act in
progress
the government goes on to describe some
of these as
sadomasochistic
images so this is this is a tough case
this is one of those tough cases you
were referencing earlier you talked
about this morning said these cases are
terrible this is one of them this is
terrible stuff this is not a good guy
who's doing this stuff guidelines
recommendation in the case was 97 to 121
months so if i'm doing my math right
that's up to 10 years
and
in this case the guidelines
recommendation was essentially written
by congress because in the protect act
of 2003
congress specified what they wanted the
range to be in these kind of cases and
congress also specified what they wanted
the mandatory minimums to be i know you
remember the protect act because you've
you've talked about it you've you've
given
lectures on it
and it was enacted as i said in 2003 was
84-0 was the was the vote here in the
senate
the concern the reason the protect act
was put into place is the senate was
concerned over lenient sentences by
judges in child porn cases
which is what you described you said
about it there was an increasing
perception on capitol hill and within
doj
that liberal judges were to blame for
the downward pressure on federal
sentences and that legislation was
necessary to rein the men
that's you in 2011 describing this
law so congress has set the guidelines
here 84 not in the senate i noticed the
chairman voted for it as did a number of
other members of this committee so that
congress sets the range essentially it's
97 months up to 10 years now the
prosecutor in this case this is in dc of
course you're on the federal district
court
prosecutor in this case
it's a a uh a liberal administration i
think it's fair to say it says in the
state of texas see my colleague from
texas next to me here the prosecutor in
this case nevertheless still asks for
two full years
in prison
you gave the defendant three months
guidelines called for ten years
prosecutor wanted at least two
you gave him three months
and when you did you made you made a
number of arguments and statements in
the record and i'd like to go through
some of them because i've read them all
and the first argument you made was that
the federal guidelines that punished
child porn offenders the ones that
congress wrote
were and i'm quoting you now are in many
ways outdated
that's your quote and you went on to say
about why you thought they were outdated
i'm going to quote you again you say and
i quote i don't feel that it's
appropriate to increase the penalty on
the basis of the number of images or
prepubescent victims meaning little kids
as the guidelines require
because these circumstances exist in
many cases if not most
and don't signal
an especially heinous
or egregious
child pornography offense end quote i
just want to ask you about that because
i just have to tell you i'm having a
hard time wrapping my head around it
we're talking about eight-year-olds and
nine-year-olds and eleven-year-olds and
twelve-year-olds
he's got images of these the government
said added up to over 600 images
gobs of video footage
of these children
but you say this does not signal a
heinous or egregious child pornography
offense
help me understand that what word would
you use if it's not heinous or egregious
how would you describe it
thank you senator for letting me
address
the concern
that you've put forward
based on the record
that you've reviewed
as a judge
who
is a mom and
has been tasked with the responsibility
of actually reviewing the evidence
the evidence that you
would not describe
in polite
the evidence that you
are pointing to discussing
addressing in this context is evidence
that i
have seen
in my role as a judge and it is
heinous it is
egregious
what a judge has to do
is determine
how to sentence defendants
proportionately
consistent
with the elements that the statutes
include
with the requirements that congress
has set forward
unwarranted sentencing disparities is
something that the
sentencing commission
has been focused on for a long time
in regard to child pornography offenses
all of the offenses
are horrible
all of the offenses are egregious
but the guidelines as you pointed out
are being departed from even with
respect to the government's
recommendation
the government
in this case and in others
has asked for a sentence that is
substantially less than the guideline
penalty and so what i was discussing was
that phenomenon that the guidelines
in this area are not doing the work
of differentiating defendants as the
government itself indicated in this very
case and so
that's what i was talking about but i
want to assure you senator
that i take these cases
very seriously
but these cases
include
the notion by many defendants
that the folks at issue that the
defendants themselves are collecting
these images on the internet
they're terrible things that have
happened but they're
not involved say the defendants they're
not focused on you know what is actually
happening to the children
and so part of my sentencings was about
redirecting the defendant's attention
it's not just about
how much time a person spends in prison
it's about understanding the harm of
this
this behavior it's about
all of the other
kinds of restraints
that sex offenders are ordered
rightly
live under at the end of the day the
sentences in these cases include not
only prison time
but
restraints on computer use sometimes for
decades
restraints on ability to go near
children sometimes for decades all of
these things
judges consider
in order to affect what congress has
required which is a sentence that is
sufficient but not greater than
necessary let me just promote the
purposes of punishment yeah well let me
just ask you about that last point
because you said this a couple of times
now the the sentences that congress
require congress wanted the guidelines
to be mandatory
congress wrote the guidelines in this
case
they wanted them to be mandatory they
gave the courts factors to consider to
choose between the sentencing range
congress wanted you to choose between 97
and 121 months that's what congress
wanted the supreme court in booker
said that the sentence the sentencing
guidelines would be discretionary so the
supreme court gave you the discretion
but if we're talking about what congress
has wanted congress wanted them to be
mandatory my only point in raising that
is just to say that you had discretion
in these cases
and you used your discretion to to
choose the sentences that you did let me
ask you about some of the things though
that you said because you said this this
morning and i appreciated how you want
to direct the defendants you want to get
them to own up to what they've done in
these cases i thought that was powerful
and i thought it was right
but let me just ask you about what you
said to this defendant
you said to this defendant through whom
you sentenced to only three months in
prison that your collection i'm quoting
you your collection at the time that you
were caught was not actually as large as
it seems
the government felt the need to respond
to you on the record they said the
government doesn't believe that it's
appropriate to just disregard the number
of images that the number of images can
be appropriate and indeed in this case
the defendant has amassed an extremely
large collection of child pornography
but you disregarded that you also told
the defendant you said this this seems
to be a case where you were fascinated
by sexual images involving what were
essentially your peers
and then you went on to say the
defendant was merely trying to satisfy
his curiosity curiosity is your word
one more thing on this same idea you
said you were viewing this is you to the
defendant you were you were viewing sex
acts between children who were not much
younger than you and this whole
discussion is about why you're only
giving him three
months judge he was 18.
these kids are eight
i don't see in what sense their peers
i've got a nine-year-old a
seven-year-old and a 16 month old at
home and i live in fear
that they will be
exposed to let alone exploited
in this kind of material i don't
understand you saying to him that
they're peers
and that therefore you were viewing sex
acts between children who are not much
younger than you and that that's
that's somehow a reason to only give him
three months help me understand this
senator i don't have the record of that
entire case in front of me what i recall
with respect to that case
is that unlike the many other
child pornography offenders
that i had seen as a judge and that i
was aware of in my work on the
sentencing commission this particular
defendant
had just graduated from high school
and some of
perhaps not all when you were looking at
the records but some of
the materials that he was looking at
were older
teenagers were older
victims
and
the point
senator
is that you you said before the
probation office is making
recommendations and they do so on a
case-by-case basis that is what congress
requires
that if this is not done at the level of
but you had one russian judge you admit
that right i just want to be senator
sentencing is a discretionary act of a
judge
but
it's not a numbers game it's not i
understand that congress
wanted the guidelines to be mandatory
the supreme court
in 2005 determined that they couldn't be
in an opinion by justice scalia
determined that they couldn't be and
congress since then
has not come back
to amend them or to change them or to
make them mandatory again and so there
is discretion at sentencing and when you
look at the sentencing statutes
congress has
given the judges
not only the discretion to make the
decision
but require judges to do so on an
individualized basis
taking into account not only the
guidelines but also
various factors including
the age of the defendant
the circumstances of the defendant
the terrible nature of the crime the
harm to the victims
all of these factors are taken into
account and the probation office assists
the court
in
determining
what sentence is sufficient but not
greater than necessary and i appreciate
senator that you
have looked at these from the standpoint
of statistics that you're questioning
whether or not i take them seriously or
i have some uh reason to
uh
handle them in either a different way
than my peers or a different way than
other cases and i assure you that i do
not
that if you were to look at the greater
body of
not only my more than 100 sentences
but also the sentences of other judges
in my district and nationwide you would
see
a very similar
exercise of attempting to do
what it is that judges do
attempting
to take into account all of the relevant
factors and do justice individually in
each case well let's keep talking about
about this case you also said to to this
individual
who is an adult tried as an adult 18
years old you also said to him besides
saying that you thought his victims were
his peers you also said there's no
reason to think that you are a pedophile
and then you went on to say again that's
another reason why you weren't going to
give him you're only going to give him
three months because you had to judge
that he wasn't a pedophile and then you
said and this is something i'd i really
need your help understanding then you
apologize to him
and i just have to tell you i can't
quite figure this out
he said to him this is a truly difficult
situation
i appreciate that your family's in the
audience i feel so sorry for them
and for you
and for the anguish this has caused all
of you
i feel terrible about the collateral
consequences of this
conviction and then you're going to say
sex offenders are truly shunned in our
society
i'm just trying to figure out judge
is he the victim here or the victims the
victims
you're
saying that you are you're apologizing
to him you're saying you're sorry for
the anguish this has caused him there
was a victim impact statement in this
case
it didn't get read into the record but
it was there
i've described the videos that we have
you say earlier in the case you talk
about how heinous these crimes are and
you describe them to your credit you
describe how heinous it is to your
credit and yet here you are giving him
three months
and apologizing to him and saying you
feel sorry for the anguish that's caused
him and also saying you think that sex
offenders are truly shunned in our
society
so just just talk about that help me
understand i mean is he a victim is that
your view here is that why you said this
is that what you meant by senator i
i again don't have the entire record i
remember in that particular case i
considered it to be unusual
in part for the reasons that i described
i remember in that case that defense
counsel
was arguing for probation
in part
because
he argued
that here we had a very young man
just graduated from high school he
presented
all of his diplomas and certificates and
the things that he had done
and argued
consistent with what i was seeing in the
record
that this particular defendant
had
gotten into this in a way that was i
thought inconsistent with some of the
other cases that i had seen part of what
a judge is doing
as
required by congress
is
thinking about
this case
thinking about unwarranted sentencing
disparities that's in the statute
other cases other determinations that a
judge may have made about this
i don't remember in detail this
particular case but i do recall it being
unusual
and so my my only point to you
is that
judges
are doing the work
of assessing in each case
a number of factors that are set forward
by congress
all against the backdrop
of heinous criminal behavior
but the guidelines are no longer
mandatory congress has not
corrected as you would say the supreme
court's determination about that justice
scalia's decision that the guidelines
are not mandatory congress has not said
that and congress has given judges
factors to consider
this in my view was an unusual case that
had a number of factors that the
defendant was pointing out that the
government was pointing out that the
probation office was pointing out
and i
sent this
18 year old
to three months in federal prison
under circumstances
that were presented in this case because
i wanted him to understand that what he
had done was harmful
that what he had done was unlawful
that what he had done
violated the law and and needed to be
punished
not only by prison but also by all of
the other things that
the law requires of a judge who is
sentencing in this area but but judge
with all due respect and i'm i i'm
telling you what i'll be directed to you
i am questioning your discretion your
judgment that's exactly what i'm doing
i'm not questioning you as a person i'm
not questioning your excellence as a
judge frankly but you said it you had
discretion and i that's exactly what i'm
doing i'm questioning how you used your
discretion
in these cases and to me
to take a guy who's 18 years old who has
what the government says is an extremely
large collection of prepubescent
pornography
10 year olds 11 year olds we're talking
about i mean
gobs of hours of time here that he has
and
you say to him what that you say that
well you know it was it was just a
collection i mean he was just viewing it
and it was you know essentially they
were his peers you say to him that he's
not a pedophile
i don't know how you know that i don't
know why that's relevant to the
guidelines but maybe it is you say he's
not a pedophile
um you say that you're very sorry for
him and what he suffered and then you
give him three months when frankly a
liberal prosecutor is asking for two
full years i mean it does seem like an
extraordinary case to me it would bother
me no matter what it really bothers me
when in every case child porn case
you've had we've had discretion you've
sentenced below the guidelines and below
the government's recommendation and
saying that sex offenders are truly
shunned in our society as you said to
him it it reminds me of echoes which you
said as early as law school on that
harvard law review article senator
blumenthal was just talking about there
you say
and i'm quoting you now in the current
climate of fear hatred and revenge
associated with the release of convicted
sex criminals
courts must be especially attentive to
legislative enactments
regarding these sex criminals i guess
like like this the enactment here the
the the protect act that congress
enacted so i i want to i want to try to
understand here is it your view that
society is too hard on sex offenders you
say they truly are shunned in society
you wrote that
many of these laws are products of a
climate of fear hatred and revenge
so just is that is that still your view
i mean do you think that these that
these laws
are
too tough that we're too tough on sex
offenders explain what you meant in this
case in 2013 and it seems to be the same
thing you said many years ago
senator it's not the same thing i said
many years ago many years ago as a law
school student i was evaluating a new
set of
legislation state laws about
registration and i was analyzing them as
law students do
wasn't about the sex crime it was about
the characterization of the law
is it a punitive law is it a
prescriptive law and
how would a court go about determining
that that was the frame that i used then
it could have been about anything it was
about
the characterization
of
legislation
i don't i'm sorry i don't mean to
interrupt you i've only got two and a
half minutes left but i just want to
make sure i understand this
this is i'm quoting from your conclusion
now this is on page 17 32
of the harvard law review this is your
conclusion
in the current climate of fear
hatred and revenge associated with the
release of convicted sex criminals
courts need to be especially attentive
to legislative enactments so you that's
a conclusory statement you're saying
that there is a climate of fear hatred
and revenge that are informing these
laws and you described some of the laws
earlier i think megan's law and others
senator cruz asked you about some of
those i i i just i'm trying to
understand what you meant by that
because you're saying something similar
in the hawkins case you're saying that
society truly shuns our sex offenders
um
with all due respect
my uh article is now in the record
people can read it and they can see
that i was evaluating these laws not to
determine their constitutionality not to
say that they shouldn't be enacted but
to talk about
the ways in which courts
make determinations about the character
of the law and all of the consequences
that follow from them
in law school i had not had
any uh experience in in terms of the
criminal justice system and i was doing
what law students do which is
uh
seeking to analyze in a creative way
new legislation
with respect to mr hawkins i was doing
what judges do
which is
look at the statute 18
usc 3553a
exercise discretion as congress has
required us to do
take into account
all of the various aspects of a
particular case
and make a determination
consistent with
my authority
my judgment
and understanding fully
the egregious nature of the crime
as you said
even the prosecutors in these cases are
not
recommending guideline sentences
the probation office which is an
independent authority
looking at these cases and the facts
related to them are not recommending
guideline sentences
this is a particular area
where the commission has seen an
enormous amount
of disparity
and has in fact asked congress to come
back and address
to to help judges
who are looking at these cases to be
able to rely on the guidelines which
congress has declined to do
senator in that case
we have the statute that congress has
enacted concerning penalties and we have
judges who are doing their level best
to make sure
that
people are held accountable as they need
to be in our society in a fair and just
way
mr chairman i my time's expired i have
thank you judge uh i have no further
questions at this time
just checking with my staff so the
original statute was passed in 2003
the scalia decision 2005
the booker decision so the original
statute that i'm talking about um i'm
just thinking was i felt like it was in
the 80s
we think it made it in 2003 i'm
all right
by
justice scalia the booker decision
made the guidelines
advisory so that even though judges have
to calculate them they are no longer
binding and what it meant in the statute
is that the guidelines became one
factor among many
that judges consider at sentencing
i'm not going to opine on justice scalia
and his
conduct and decision as it relates to
the overall topic i hope we all agree
that we want to do everything in our
power
reasonably within our power to lessen
the incidence of pornography and
exploitation of children you have made
that clear that is your position too
but i just want to tell you
congress has doesn't have clean hands in
this conversation we haven't touched
this now for 15 16 or 17 years
and
this you aren't the only one who faced
this kind of a challenge with the cases
before you
i said this morning and it bears
repeating in united states versus klotz
trump appointed judge sarah pitlik
holy's choice senator hawley's choice
for the eastern district of missouri
sentenced an individual convicted of
possession of child pornography to only
60 months
well below the
135-168 month sentence recommended by
the guidelines m mr chairman you've
mentioned let me finish uh i'll finish
and then of course i'll recognize you
senator holly you've said some very
powerful things in support of this judge
but clearly she faced a situation where
she decided she would not follow the
guidelines and took a sentence of less
than half of what they recommended we
have created a situation because of our
inattention and unwillingness to tackle
an extremely controversial area in
congress and left it to the judges
and i think we have to accept some
responsibility for that senator
i just wanted to say uh chairman durbin
since you mentioned judge pitlik in the
klotz case
she followed the prosecutor's
recommendation in that case my as i've
said over and over part of my concern
with judge jackson is that she has not
followed the prosecutor's sentences she
didn't in the hawkins case we're just
talking about or the guidelines
and i'm happy we'll we can have a policy
debate about whether or not the
guidelines are too lenient i would argue
in this era of exploding child
pornography they're not too lenient at
all i think you were right the first
time when you voted in 2003 to make them
tougher i will just say that uh i don't
know if you sponsored a bill to change
this i'll be looking for it but i will
tell you that there isn't a long line of
people waiting to co-sponsor this
controversial issue we if we're going to
tackle it we should but we should
concede in the meantime that we've left
judges in the lurch in many of these
situations there is no clarity in this
situation and i think to hold this judge
responsible for the overall situation is
to ignore
our
non-feasants malfeasance whatever it
might be and lack of responsibility in
dealing with this senator hirono
thank you mr chairman
judge jackson as you may know i ask the
following two preliminary questions of
every nominee who appears before any of
the committees on which i sit so i will
ask you these two questions first since
you became a legal adult have you ever
made unwanted requests for sexual favors
or committed any verbal or physical
harassment or assault over sexual nature
i have not have you ever faced
discipline or entered into a settlement
related to this kind of conduct
i have not
just jackson my colleague from missouri
seems to think that
it's appropriate for federal judges to
sentence individuals below inappropriate
to sentence individuals below the
sentencing guidelines in these kinds of
cases horrific cases and so i think it's
important to offer a couple of
clarifications for the record
judge jackson when the u.s sentencing
commission first addressed the issue of
sentencing in the
in this area in 2012
do you remember that only 40
of convicted offenders in this category
were receiving sentences within the
guidelines
senator i don't remember exactly the
number but i do know that there was a
great deal of variance from the
guidelines 40
would you be surprised to learn that the
department of justice which prosecutes
these cases sent a letter to the u.s
sentencing commission in 2013 stating
that the existing sentencing guidelines
for child pornography offenses
do not accurately reflect
the current landscape of child
pornography offense
conduct
um i
don't remember that particular letter
but there was a lot of concern about
this guideline from from all sides
and now the sentencing commission issued
another report just last year on this
topic and do you know that as of that
report an even lower percentage of
convicted offenders were receiving
sentences within within the guidelines
did you know i'm not surprised or
something i did more now it's even less
i didn't know but i'm not surprised
did you know that as of last year it was
just 30
of non-production offenders who were
sentenced within the guidelines i did
not know but i'm not surprised
my republican colleagues made a big show
yesterday of
promising a fair process and to me that
means ensuring that you are treated
no differently than any other federal
judges
that have nominees that have come before
us
see there was an article recently that
highlighted the fact that many of
president trump's circuit court nominees
who were previously district court
judges had also issued below guidelines
sentencing to child pornography cases
judge
ralph erickson who was confirmed to the
8th circuit in 2017 with support from
every republican member of this
committee who was serving in the senate
at the time and there are at least 11
cases where he sentenced people to below
guidelines sentences
does that surprise you
it does not senator
i'm not sure if you know judge erickson
but do you have any reason to believe
he's a soft on child pornography based
on these sentences
i don't have any reason to believe
do you think my republican colleagues
are soft on child pornography just
because they voted for judge erickson to
become a federal appellate judge even
after he issued these 11 sentences
senator i'm
not in a position to
evaluate whether your colleagues are
soft on crime because of their votes
i have no reason to believe that
they voted for this person
but um i i think it would probably be
quite unfair to characterize him as
being soft on child pornography i would
also like to talk to you about
judge joseph blanco bianco
who was confirmed to the second circuit
in 2019 with support from every
republican member of this committee who
was serving in the senate at the time
including senator holly
in the case united states b bowen
judge bianco sentenced a defendant to 60
months in prison when his guidelines
range was
to 151-100
months
and here's what judge bianco said in the
sentencing transcript for that case
quote
and the guidelines here are just way
disproportionate under the facts of this
case and i don't view them as
particularly helpful in this case i
believe the probation department got it
right in terms of the statutory
mandatory minimum being sufficient but
not greater than necessary to achieve
the factors of
sentencing quote
i'm not sure if you know judge bianco
but do you have any reason to believe
that he's soft on chop
often child pornography based on that
sentence or those comments i do not
senator
do you think my republican colleagues
including senator holly are soft on
child pornography because they voted to
confirm judge bianco to the second
circuit
even after he he issued below guideline
sentences and made these comments
i have no reason to believe that that
here are some of the other circuit
judges that all of my republican
colleagues voted to confirm despite the
fact that they
they sentenced child pornography
defendants to below guidelines sentences
judge amal thotpar on the sixth circuit
judge richard sullivan on the second
circuit
judge andrew brasher on the 11th circuit
again i'm not sure if you've ever met
these judges before but do you have any
reason to believe they don't take child
pornography seriously
i do not
i would like to note that senator cruz
referred to a chart
that listed
eight cases
and the government recommendations and
the sentencing guidelines and that
you did not adhere to those sentencing
guidelines
what was not included in the chart was
what the probation recommendations were
and if you add those probation
recommendations
in five of the cases you follow the
probation recommendations in one
instance you are lower and one instance
you are higher than the probation
recommendations mr chairman i would like
to introduce the complete chart
for the record without objection
you've been asked to answer a lot of
questions about your judicial philosophy
some of my colleagues particularly on
the other side seem dead set
on
finding out if you are an originalist
a textualist if you believe in a living
constitution or various other labels
i don't find these labels particularly
useful
take originalism
proponents claim you just have to dig
deeply enough into the historical record
and you'll somehow find the one true
meaning of a constitutional provision
the fallacy of this
approach is illustrated in district of
columbia versus heller
there justice scalia's majority opinion
and justice stevenson's dissenting
opinion each applied originalism
justice stevens more effectively in my
opinion
and reach completely different
conclusions about the scope of the
second amendment
take textualism
and bostock
judge gorsuch applied textualism to find
that title vii
of the civil rights act protected
employees from discrimination based on
sexual orientation and gender identity
in dissent justice alito mocked justice
gorsuch's
application of textualism and he wrote
the following justice alito
quote the court attempts to pass off its
decision as the inevitable product of
the textureless school of statutory
interpretation
championed by our late colleague justice
scalia but no one should be fooled
the court's opinion is like a pirate
ship
it sails under a textureless flag but
what it actually represents is a theory
of statutory interpretation that justice
scalia excoriated the theory that courts
should update old statutes so that they
better reflect the current values of
society end quote and these are two
justices who are usually in agreement so
so much for labels
so instead of trying to fix some label
on you
i'd rather focus on the fact that you
are fair and objective in your approach
that you are even-handed in your
application of law to the facts and that
you are independent
during your last confirmation hearing
you spoke about judicial independence
about what you learned during the three
clerkships
and you're then eight years on the bench
you said and i quote i know very well
what my obligations are what my duties
are
not to rule with partisan advantage in
mind
not to tailor or craft my decisions in
order to gain influence or anything of
the sort
end quote
well said
so my question is the following
what do you do to ensure that you
maintain independence free of partisan
partisanship when you handle a case
thank you senator
what i do and what i've done in
all of my
570 some odd
opinions
is
to apply a methodology that is designed
to
ensure my impartiality
and
to respect the limits of my judicial
role
what it means is that i am receiving
the cases
and at the outset
i am
setting aside any personal views that i
might have about the parties about the
issues as i also said in my dc circuit
confirmation it doesn't matter to me
whether the argument is being made by
the president of the united states or a
death row inmate what i'm doing is
looking at the argument
i'm looking at the facts
i'm applying
the law in as neutral and consistent a
manner as i can
because that is the duty and requirement
of the judicial oath
i'm also very conscious of the limits of
judicial authority of the the
restrictions that exist in the law to
prevent me as a judge from becoming a
policy maker
this means that i
carefully scrutinize
my jurisdiction
it means that i
look
at the text and focus on the text and
the intentions of
the legislatures
that
drafted
that provision
or the intentions of the framers
that
put forward that constitutional
principle
it means i'm looking at precedent
if i was fortunate enough to be
confirmed to the supreme court
i would be upholding the principles of
starry decisis as i consider the
precedence and making sure that the
court is
putting forward consistent and
um
predictable
rulings as is important to maintain the
rule of law
all of these i see as constraints on
judicial authority that i care deeply
about
in order to maintain my independence as
is necessary
to
ensure public confidence
in my rulings as a judge
judge jackson i have sat on this
committee now for a number of years
and as some of my colleagues continue to
try to pin labels on the nominees who
come before us frankly i find your
methodology
to be as succinct a
definition of what would lead a judge to
come up with fair and objective results
i thank you for that
as a lower court judge you were
generally bound by the supreme courts
and the d.c circus presidents
that certainly won't be the case if you
are confirmed to the supreme court
the supreme court can overturn its own
precedence that's why i found your
analysis and committee on the judiciary
versus mcgann instructive in that case
you had a president committee on the
judiciary v myers that had already
confronted the issues you faced however
it was another district court decision
and you were not bound by it you
nonetheless followed that precedent why
did you find that opinion so persuasive
well senator
in
um the law
there are
different kinds of precedent and by that
i mean
um there's vertical precedent which is
what people are most
familiar with there are
cases that are handed down by higher
courts the appellate court the supreme
court
and those bind the lower courts so that
even if you disagree with them you have
to follow them because they're binding
precedent
but there's also horizontal precedent it
it too is about maintaining consistency
and predictability in the rule of law
and what that means is when you are in a
district
there are many judges
and if someone else in your district has
handled a case
that
comes out or that involves the same
issues and comes out in a certain way
you as the second judge have to contend
with that ruling you can't ignore the
fact
that there is precedent in your district
that handles a case in a particular way
and with respect to the mcgann case
the precedent wasn't just close it was
nearly identical
the the myers case involved
the former white house counsel
and the argument by the executive that
had absolute immunity
in
with respect to a request by the
legislature that she provide testimony
my case involved a former white house
counsel
who
was claiming absolute immunity at the
request of the executive in response to
a legislative subpoena in both cases not
only was the absolute immunity issue on
the table but in both cases the same
threshold issues about whether or not
there was jurisdiction
in the court because the legislature had
standing or didn't have standing which
is which was the argument that was being
made
the same question about whether the
court could hear
a dispute between the legislature and
the executive branch
all of those issues had previously been
considered
by my colleague in the district court
and he wrote an extensive i'm talking
about judge bates he wrote an extensive
opinion
analyzing each of the issues and so at a
minimum
as the second judge dealing with these
exact same issues i had to look at what
he did
and decide
was it persuasive did i agree
and i did
judge jackson of course if there had
been a vertical precedent i.e from the
supreme court or the circuit court that
was on point to your mcgann situation
yes you would have had to follow that
precedent but there wasn't and so you
followed a a reasoning by another
district judge that made a lot of sense
to me and that certainly makes sense to
me
you discussed scary decisis and the
importance of precedent in your opinion
and this is what you wrote quote
it is interesting to note that the
doctrine of starry decisis performs a
limiting function that reflects the
foundational principles
that undergird the federal government's
tripartite constitutional system
this is because deciding a legal issue
anew each time that same question is
presented without any reference to what
has been done before nudges a court
outside of its established domain of
saying what the law is and into the
realm of legislating what the law should
be
i know that you've been asked say the
questions about the importance of
precedent before but maybe you can just
tell us
one more time why precedent is important
in our judicial system
thank you senator
our judicial system
is one that is designed to uphold the
rule of law
unlike other
systems in other societies some other
societies we believe
that we have a government of laws and
not men
and yet
there are men and women who are acting
as judges in the context of our system
what precedent does
is ensure
that there's consistency across the
different
individuals who are tasked with the
solemn responsibility of interpreting
the law
it ensures that
there's public confidence that the law
is what is guiding
judges in their decision making and not
just their own individual views
and so it's it's crucial
for
maintaining public confidence
maintaining stability in the law
establishing a system that has
predictability in it
all of which
supports confidence in the judiciary
which which is the currency of of the
judicial branch
because of the importance of precedence
in promoting confidence etc you know
people need to know what the law is
and so precedent is important on this on
that score and if you are confirmed to
the supreme court what factors would you
consider before
overturning precedent
well there are many factors that the
supreme court considers and not just
whether they think a prior precedent is
wrong that is one of the factors the
court has said that
a precedent that is egregiously wrong is
one that is subject to reconsideration
but in order to actually make the
determination about overturning it
in addition to it being wrong the court
considers
whether or not
there's been reliance on that precedent
and if so how much
the court considers whether or not
the precedent is workable
sometimes the court will
issue a ruling in a case and it turns
out that it's not actually functioning
in the way that the court intended and
so that might be a reason
to revisit it
the court considers whether or not
other precedents in the area
have shifted
such that the
foundation for the particular precedent
is no longer
uh
sustainable
and the court considers whether there
are changes in the facts
uh that relate to that precedent or a
new understanding of the facts that
relate to a precedent
all of those factors are things that a
court takes into that the supreme court
takes into account
when it decides whether or not to
revisit
a precedent
therefore the court should consider all
of those factors
i would say reliance factors loom large
as far as i'm concerned uh before
overturning a precedent but basically if
you have five members of the court
deciding to overturn
a president they can do so
right
under our scheme yes under the
constitution
and so we're seeing uh more and more uh
presidents being
asked to be overturned an analysis by
national affairs found that since 2017
when justice gorsuch was appointed to
the court the court has shown and i
quote an increasing readiness to
overturn precedent end quote this is
true for both long-standing presidents
and those that are just a few years old
for example in 2018 janna's decision the
court overturned a 41 year old president
called abood that decision weakened
public sector unions
justice alito first signaled that he
wanted conservative anti-union groups to
challenge abood in his 2012 decision
in knox versus s-e-i-u
this is called signaling and justice
alito definitely single signal his
desire
to re-visit the buu decision so yes
these groups they got the message
they brought case after case to meet the
criteria that justice alito laid out and
although they came close in 2016 justice
scalia's death left the court stuck in a
four to four decision
in a case called fredericks the
california teachers association
basically the minute justice gorsuch was
confirmed the court finally had a
conservative five to four majority to
overturn abood and the result was janus
i followed these lines of cases very
closely so that is what happened they
waited for justice gorsuch and boom
five to four against unions
another in another example the courts
acknowledged four most conservative
justices thomas alito gorsuch and
kavanaugh dissented in june medical
voting to overturn a president banning
burdensome and unnecessary restrictions
placed on abortion providers this
particular president was only four years
old
now the court is poised to overturn roe
v wade even though women
have relied on their constitutional
right to have an abortion for nearly
years
of course i'm not suggesting that
supreme supreme court decision or pr
presidents are sacrosanct because i'm
thankful uh the court can and uh did
revisit presidents like plessy v
ferguson that were wrong the day they
were decided
but justices should not be seen to be
advancing their
individual political or ideological
agendas at the expense of individual
rights and precedence that people have
relied on
one result of the court's new approach
is that people's view of the court is
changing for the worst a recent pew poll
found that 44 of americans now
disapprove of the supreme court
this is up 15 points from august
2020 shortly before the late justice
ruth bader ginsburg died and amy comey
barrett was appointed to fill
her seat
i think court watches acknowledge there
is an ideologically ideological split
in this current supreme court
when
we are seeing more cases
decided on ideological bases not on the
facts and the law i think it leads to
the american people questioning
whether the court is a fair and
objective arbiter of cases
and controversy
you were asked earlier today about your
representation of guantanamo detainees
just to make it clear
as a federal public defender you were
assigned to represent guantanamo
detainees is that right that is correct
senator and then while at morrison and
forster you also did pro bono work for
guantanamo guantanamo detainees were you
assigned to do that work as well
so there was one detainee who i had
represented as a federal public defender
who
was
brought into my firm's practice
unbeknownst to me
uh and when i arrived at the firm
the
attorneys who were working on that case
recognized that i had previously been a
lawyer who had represented this
particular detainee
and asked if i would help with his
habeas petition at that stage i think
you clarified that earlier
today and you served as council of
record on amicus briefs
related to
detention
i think that was brought out today yes
were you working on behalf of detainees
at that point or were you working on
behalf of other groups or individuals
i was working on behalf of other groups
or individuals in in with respect to
retired judges
um i
yes there were there were three briefs
in total two different cases
and um one of the briefs that i filed
was on behalf of
20 retired federal judges including one
who was a partner at my firm at the time
and who wanted to make a particular
argument to the court
concerning the detention process and
these were judges that were nominated by
various presidents it must have been a
diverse group and they asked you to
do they brief
and they did
yes
so as part of your work at the law firm
a responsibility of your employment you
were
assigned to work with this diverse group
of retired judges and to represent
conservative or libertarian
organizations such as the cato institute
and the rutherford
institute to advocate their views
yes the other
two briefs that i filed were at the cert
stage and then at the merit stage of a
case that was eventually
mooted
but my clients in those cases were a
diverse group of organizations including
the cato institute the rutherford
institute and the constitution project
members of this committee know full well
that
lawyers are
we we are
and we have to follow the cause of
professional conduct which says that we
have to zealously represent our clients
and that's what you are doing with
regard to the detainees and i just want
to note that some of the very senators
who are openly questioning you for
representing
defendants or detainees have in the past
made the argument that judicial nominees
should not be opposed for the arguments
they make in the course of representing
clients
i'm going to quote one of my colleagues
i've been a military lawyer for almost
30 years i represented people as a
defense attorney in the military that
were charged with some pretty horrific
acts and i gave them my all the system
of justice that we're so proud of in
america requires the unpopular to have
an adequate and an advocate and every
time a defense lawyer fights to make the
government do their job that defense
lawyer has made us all safer
do you agree with that
i do senator
in 2012 prominent conservative lawyers
signed a letter defending attorneys who
have represented guantanamo detainees in
part the letter said quote
the american tradition of zealous
representation of unpopular clients is
at least as old as john adams's
representation of the british soldiers
charged in the boston massacre
good defense councils is key
to ensuring that military commissions
federal juries and federal judges have
access to the best arguments and most
rigorous factual presentation before
making crucial decisions that affect
both national security and paramount
liberty interests
end quote
so the the quote that i read isn't the
first time that to my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle have
try to
say that your representation on your
work is a public defender somehow i
don't know disqualifies you or makes you
uh leaning one way or the other so
you've made it very clear
that that is not what you are about i
just have one more question in the
remaining time oh i'm sorry i will
senator i'm sorry we're on a roll call
i'm on such a role
you're on a roll and we're on a roll yes
thank you mr chairman
mr chairman but before we break if i
could ask one question of the chairman
sure
senator hirono just made reference to
the recommendations of the probation
office and in five of these cases
to the best of my knowledge those
probation recommendations are not in the
record i haven't seen them my staff
hasn't seen them
and and that raises two questions number
one whether the white house is providing
differential material on this nominee's
background to democratic members than
republican members because i don't know
where senator hirono would get access to
them other than from the white house but
secondly regardless of whether it's
differential
would the chairman agree that there is
considerable focus on these cases and
the committee both sides
should have access to the pre-sentence
reports and to see the underlying facts
judge jackson has said she was following
the facts and the factors in those cases
senator you know we've completed
discovery before we started this hearing
mr chairman how did senator romero
i'm not gonna entertain this we've been
through discovery do you have access to
them i don't know that i do i really
don't can we ask senator hirono how she
got access to them sorry to interrupt
you senator but i want to make an
announcement we're gonna have a
10-minute break members are going to
head to so you're going to keep
differential access to this information
i'm not sure what differential access is
i'll take i'll look it up we have a vote
on the floor that take about 10 minutes
so 10 to 15 minutes relax
and then we're going to come back and we
have two senators cotton and booker who
will be recognized and then take a break
for dinner
uh and then we're going to try to still
finish tonight uh with two remaining
senators senator assaf and tell us who
are going to be first thing in the
morning so we stand in recess
okay
i
[Music]
all right everybody i am here we are
continuing to monitor there's a short
break here very very interesting
questions from maisie hirono
and others and you really get a sense
that the republican party is made up of
just people who really love to read from
it's very very clear from them naming
books and mentioning that books exist
and are used to teach things in school
we know that it is an extraordinarily
well-read
group of 11 senators here
on the republican side today as
certainly certainly all of you can tell
um
this is likely to go on uh quite a bit
i actually don't know
exactly the number of people we've now
heard from is it
is it 15 out of the 22
or something like that if it is that
seven half hour each would be three and
a half hours to go
uh i guess you have a lot of time to
read on flights to cancun yeah exactly
very very well said
um
four more oh they're only doing two more
today is that right that they did they
say that i miss that
two in the morning and then they're
gonna okay
i did not hear that
i'm trying to keep uh keep up with it
all myself i want to say thank you to
ronald rose who just got a david pakman
show membership at joinpackman.com
for more two after break two after
dinner tonight okay that's that's that
makes more sense so they're coming back
in five minutes they're gonna do two
more then they will do dinner
they're gonna go until about nine that's
what i expected okay that makes a lot
more sense to me
um
and then right i think the issue is
that's not going to get them to all 22
they'll probably need to do two more in
the morning before they start 20-minute
rounds that that makes sense
um
i will be taking the dinner break myself
as well
um i am making a
yeah no we we don't anything could be on
the menu quite frankly by the way how
are the calzones but we have subway
tomorrow pizza is here
the food is here warm food around noon
yeah exactly
i will be having this is a great recipe
uh coconut cod
chowder
it's a
recipe that's baz great person to follow
delicious soup
very very strong soup and i know that i
know in my audience we still have a lot
of people who have this
almost a childlike aversion to
fish and seafood
but not me it is a coconut cod chowder
and only coconut milk
so it's vegan other than the fish yeah
a very very exciting soup
so that's a little bit um a little bit
later today thank you to marcus the
atheist as well as that crazy guy
and sahira
ex
all of whom have grabbed twitch prime
subscriptions today
um what else do we have going on any
super chats
no
um
yeah
yeah there's this weird thing in the
united states where a lot of parents
just assume kids don't like fish it's
like you realize that in like
spain
france
italy
thailand japan
china
kids grow up eating fish it's uh
yeah
anyway
just one of those weird things let's see
what sorts of voicemails
we have today
hey david i really would love to be on
your show i'd love you to interview me i
am an anti-racist educator i'm actually
the most popular anti-racist educator on
the
on the right wing uh social media
platform getter
this is the most popular anti-racist
educator on getter that's interesting
so if you want to have me on thank you
that'd be nice i am pretty popular
and they call me the anointed skeptic
that is at
and then there's the anointed skeptic
let's see
anointed
skeptic
getter
let's see
uh
not finding anyone with that name on
getter
yeah not finding any anointed skeptic on
any platform interestingly enough that's
weird
all right
i'll look into that
here's the eggman weighing in
hey dave
judge jackson who joseph r biden jr
nominated for this supreme court is not
going to be confirmed during his
presidency nor will any judge be
confirmed to the supreme court during uh
biden's presidency i would bet good
money on that shallow brother what does
anyone is the eggman kidding around
he doesn't think that judge jackson's
going to be confirmed i think it's very
clear judge jackson's i i would take
that bet let's see if predicted
has any anything on that
um
let's see where where the money is on
that issue
would uh i guess that's biden
administration
votes for supreme court nominee by july
1.
uh
weird
new supreme court justice by the end of
the year almost everybody says yes well
by the unl so
unless biden dies before the
confirmation
i think she's in
even 75 believe that she'll be confirmed
by april 8th
so
yeah that's a bet i would probably take
i would probably take
thank you to peter bongo for the twitch
prime subscription appreciate that peter
very very much
um syed ahmad says via super chat sir
what are the best elements of soup
um
i mean i would i would argue really
really good broths
broths
right i mean at the end of the day
with no broth it's not a soup
and with bad broth it's a crappy soup so
i think i would say that broth
are the most important elements of soup
some people call them stocks
some people and and really what's the
main ingredient in broths it's water i
would say water
is the most if we want to be
reductionist
i would say that um
water is really the most important
water and education
i guess
thanks to blue box for the twitch prime
subscription very much appreciate it
um couple other
voicemails here
hi david uh this is bethany from
oklahoma welcome um i have been watching
the
hearings today
uh throughout the day while i can i've
been at work also please
but to be honest it is just really hard
to take any of these
um republicans seriously well yeah i
obviously cannot
stop thinking about merrick garland
and 2016.
um
where
where we were
nine months at that point away from an
election um but
you know the gop blocked him from
from even having any hearings at all and
um
but then with amy
tony barrett
we were a mere month from the election
so it is just so i mean it's so
frustrating because not only yeah did
that happen and it's just unforgivably
hypocritical
but then also
amy
in her hearings
refused to answer
so many questions yep
and um and so like i said i've watched
a lot of the hearing but but not all of
it there's a lot of missed also
and so i guess one of my questions is
has um
you know has that happened
i i don't want to
mess up how i say her name for sure but
yeah so the the question is whether
katanji jackson uh brown jackson has
declined to answer any questions there
are there's a handful of times where she
just said i'm just not familiar with
what you're asking me about and uh she
at one point she was asked what supreme
court justice does she model her
philosophy after or is it closest to and
she declined to answer that quite
frankly and that was the right move
because if she says oh my favorite
justice was uh
you know whoever
elena kagan then they'll find some
bizarre off-the-wall elena kagan
decision from who knows when and then
ask whether she agrees with that so it
was it was smart but i actually think if
there's any criticism of uh judge
katanji brown jackson there would be two
critiques that i would make and you guys
let me know what your opinion is one is
she was not well enough prepared
for the sandbag questions like for
example when she's asked are you
familiar with this and she goes no and
they go well here's what it says do you
approve of that
there are definitely ways that you can
be coached to answer that stuff where
she she was a little bit a little bit
unstable there that would be one
criticism the second criticism i would
make
is um
she she arguably answered too many
questions she where a lot of the the
right wing justices
will brazenly
just not answer any questions like amy
kovet barrett is a good example of that
um and she i would say she's answered
too many questions compared to
so many other
uh nominees
those would be my uh my
criticisms for today
i want to say a huge thank you and send
peace and love to david n wright david
enright just signed up on my website
joinedpakman.com
david used my coupon code fix the court
we must repair the court which is above
my head and david is new member number
60 60 as you can see here today
which is uh just a fantastic thing that
everybody has going for them let's
listen to
a couple other voicemails that have come
in in the last few minutes
hey david ricardo regards that recording
regarding this trial uh this is andrew
and what's
my friend adam who's uh
a black man anyway he says that
in order for
black um people in in the u.s they have
to
work a thousand does anybody know what
trial he's talking about
times harder
to achieve the same goals as
white people in america
and he is uh yeah i mean he's a high
level
is this a does he think the hearings are
a trial is that what's going on does he
think that that that this is a trial of
katanji brown jackson that's interesting
i would love to see the charges right
against her
um sophomore engineer for google
and it took him i think it was like 10
or
like interviews to get the job but he
said yeah we got to work a lot harder
to to get there which is i'm seeing a
lot on twitter and everything anyway
thanks for your show both interesting
yeah i mean assuming that by the trial
he means these supreme court
confirmation hearings uh i've gotten a
number of emails from people saying that
to some degree
um
uh judge jackson is being held to a
different standard in some way um i i
actually just i don't think it's it's
race related at this point i can't say
that it's race related i think it's just
the typical hypocrisy of republicans
um if my view on that changes then i
will let you know
one of the things that judge jackson has
not weighed in on and i i believe that
it's absolutely
critical that she does
uh is she willing to carry forward a
lawsuit against all machines including
personal devices we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines
exactly she has not addressed that issue
and i think that it is uh
really the issue of our time
and i have prepared everyone in my life
for
now with the summer coming
we may have to give up our weed whacker
the wheat the weed whacker
may be absolutely rocked legally
by this forthcoming
lawsuit from uh
from mike pillow although that is a case
that might be come before the court and
if that if she should not prejudice
her own opinion before she's been
presented with the facts about the
machines we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines
why is that so funny every time
it's just it's it's wild it's wild how
funny that is
um
okay
standing by to resume
and then i am going to be i'll take a
dinner break for my coconut coconut cod
chowder
uh
okay looks like we're
in pretty good shape here
um
oh the guy who called in about the the
trial called back in
okay uh david it's andrew again and yeah
i didn't mean trials i meant the
confirmation hearing
i'm glad you had fun with it beautiful
no well i mean the analysis assuming
that we were talking about the
confirmation hearings it was a beautiful
analysis or at least a comment uh when
the i liked i kind of like calling it a
trial but
uh it's not but i still like it i still
like it and definitely saving that was a
good save
okay
i do want to announce that this right
now that you are currently watching
is the longest stream
in david pakman show history now i'm
trying to refresh this
twitch tracker
uh and for some reason it's not working
it's not refreshing guys
let's see
we can pull it up is the website down
hmm twitch tracker is not coming up
that's weird
man that's
disappointing all right well we'll see
if it comes back up anyway
this is now the longest single stream
in uh david pakman show history and i
appreciate everybody who's been with us
today
um close to 100 000 different people and
i really appreciate that and uh show
your appreciation with a you know use
your twitch prime or get a membership on
the website whatever you please
uh here's a super chat coming in i went
to get some sumo oranges but they were
sold out can you stop creating
artificial demand by mentioning them
it's not artificial demand if people are
actually buying the oranges that's real
demand
that's i mean you know
i don't know how else to say it take a
look at the oranges of the investigation
exactly
um i've got half a dozen sumos in my
fridge right now
i may even bring one down
later
for the post-dinner part
of the evening
david sealy says what is the perfect and
positive spicy chicken recipe
um okay spicy chicken chili so what i
would do is i would buy
hot
italian
chicken
sausages
okay
um i would then put some olive oil in a
uh in a in a pot in a soup pot or you
know like a lake crusade stockpot or
whatever
get yourself the
get yourself some onion going
salt and pepper and then
squeeze empty
the chicken sausages into the pan
um
and then i'd probably put in
you know a jalapeno
and uh
maybe a bell pepper
and some tomato paste you really want
the tomato paste to almost get like a
crust on the bottom of the pan like on
the edge of burning on the edge
and then after you've got all that going
at this point the sausage is cooked um i
would put in
i'm just making this up as we go but
this is pretty close to my my recipe
uh then i would pick my beans for
something like this i would probably do
pinto and dark red kidney
two cans of each maybe
and
then now here's this is controversial
but i prefer
instead of getting
um instead of getting like crushed
tomatoes
i would put in whole peeled tomatoes two
28-ounce cans along with their juices
and then just allow those whole tomatoes
to break down
um
and then just let it simmer some people
do uh some people add broth some people
don't you could add water
and then oh oh my god i skipped the
spices no before you add in any of this
stuff you've got to add in a bunch of
chili powder bunch a bunch of chili
powder
and
oregano
maybe some cumin or cumin as some say
uh
yeah and then at the very end i'll
usually add uh
with as far as the cilantro goes i'll
usually put in half of it chopped
cilantro into the pot and then later as
a garnish i will also add some
roughly that's more or less my uh oh god
people are unsubscribing like crazy is
that recipe is that a bad recipe i mean
listen use like vegan fake chicken if
you want i avoid sort of those highly
processed foods but if that's the issue
by all means you can do that
okay
that's going to do it i think in terms
of recipes at least for now they're
coming back to order momentarily no no
noodles you don't want any noodles no
noodles whatsoever should be involved in
chili that's i would that i have to i
have to draw the line somewhere and i
think noodles in chile is probably where
i do it yeah garlic certainly not
everybody uses garlic i mentioned onion
already onion was the first recipe
dranoa
i would even i would even consider
putting in
potentially some pixels uncharged
piccolos yeah
just to make it extra
uh looks like the feed briefly went down
there on twitch
something something a little maybe the
stream is too long
but something a little bit weird is
happening here and i don't i can't tell
i can't say that i like it
couple other voicemails coming
in
so i also wanted to tell you though that
the italians like get the finish like
chlamydia and stuff just because it's
like you say stuff like
oh well it's like you're snapping and
you're the problem whatever
if you have to like defend yourself
against like an italian who's yelling at
you and it's contagious yelling is
contagious
and if it's like well if you
you don't mind contagious stuff
apparently so
you know
that's why the spanish end up with like
chlamydia and because it's like a
giants don't give me chlamydia because
they know like
if i catch something
it's their fault so
man i don't know what she's talking
about i really don't
uh
see what else we've got here
hey david what's up man um i'm a fan of
your show i just want to get that out of
the way right now uh yeah i i think
you're really great
um
you're pretty objective for the most
part i gotta say um i you're better than
tyt like a million times whoa so anyways
uh now that i got my whole fanboy
out of the way
uh what i want to say to you is this
uh to your point that you say
the media isn't covered oh hold on are
we live right now
oh no no okay okay so this guy's message
went the full three minutes then he
called back and did another three minute
voicemail sorry man i got cut off by
some really rude woman that was like
good boy but whatever yeah the
voicemails are limited to three minutes
that's
why no anyways as a voter that's my
single number one concern now my point
is this one and the reason i'm calling
back is because i didn't get to my point
sorry about that i ramble on sometimes
um but i think about this stuff a lot
and
and and i
look into it very extensively so hear me
out
i just think it's ironic okay
and and i could be absolutely 100 wrong
about this this is a theory i so that
went three minutes and then it called
back again
yeah so sorry about that last message
i'm just signing off um i don't know if
you were following any of that but
basically
so unfortunately
we have 1200 voicemails that i have not
yet listened to we can't have
nine minutes worth of voicemails to make
one point
it is outside the scope of the show i
love everybody i'm flattered that people
call in i love it it's great i
appreciate everybody okay we can't have
when there's 1200 voicemails waiting to
be listened to
you can't take up nine minutes in order
to make a point and not to mention we've
never played even a single three-minute
voicemail on the show
the podcast i'm talking about so if
you're leaving three of them it's just
there's just not a chance it's
unfortunately outside of our scope
it's outside of our scope okay
yo david pakman i just appreciate your
viewpoint on
just about
everything thank you and your cadence of
your voice and
um
your willingness to
view
all sides
keep it up
later gator well thank you very much uh
we are now in the 11th hour not
metaphorically but literally of this
stream we are in the 11th hour
and if we go here to stream duration
you will see that today today is the
longest stream in david pakman show
history history
we've never seen anything like it never
ever ever
and uh
oh hold on i already have to ban someone
so user schertzen came in here followed
immediately said i'm a neo-liberal shill
they've been banned and their entire
presence on my channel was about four
seconds they've already been banned wow
that
that is crazy that is crazy
it's just like it's it's more sad than
anything else that this is what your
life has come down to
hey david uh this is mike from new
hampshire
and uh i just had a thought i was
just watching the show i watch it quite
a bit and all right we are back on the
record committee will resume i want to
make one thing clear for the record
senator blackburn you're going to be
recognized this evening because senator
tillis has asked he hasn't volunteered
to be uh paired in the morning with
senator also for the morning show yes mr
chairman i just felt like we should
it's on
my voice is just soft
i felt like we should
finish
tonight
we're trying to i know senator there are
a lot of people involved in this i
totally appreciate that and you asked to
be on the program tonight and we're
going to put you in and i appreciate
that thank you okay good
senator cotton mr mr chairman before we
start this questioning right before the
break i asked the chairman about
senator hirono had referenced five
probation reports that were not in the
record i asked the chairman whether the
democrats had access to information
about judge jackson's judicial record
that republicans did not
you did not answer me at the time but as
we return answer i'll give you an answer
okay well hold on let me finish my
question when we returned and when we
walked in each of the republicans was
handed this piece of paper
which is the first time any of us have
ever seen which is a chart of probation
recommendations we were just told that
the white house gave it to democrats
earlier today
i don't know if that's true or not
and what i would ask you is that is
there anything else that democrats have
asked access to in this case that
they're not sharing
with republicans on this committee and
mr chairman how would you react it if
say during the kavanaugh confirmation
the white house shared judicial
materials with republicans and did not
share it with democrats i'm pretty
confident you would have expressed
extraordinary displeasure at that if i
recall
there was some discovery issues in the
kavanaugh case
involving several years of his
performance in the white house which
your own council decided we couldn't
disclosure to the whole committee oh boy
and in this case is there anything else
that democrats have access to of judge
jackson's record that you have not
shared with republicans on this
committee and in particular
the pre-sentence reports no i suspect if
they were helpful you would have made
them public so the fact that you have it
raises an inference that they're not
helpful to the case you're making
senator you will always draw your own
inferences and i know where most of them
had i will just tell you that the
information that we received from the
white house i'm told everyone had access
to if they wanted
and now you have it just a matter of
hours after we've received it exactly so
is there anything else democrats have
that republicans do not from from judge
jackson
mr chairman can i ask you a question
about this i want to be sure understand
the handout that i just saw
the white house gave to some of us
earlier today but not all of us
we it was available i'm told the
information was available to anyone who
requested it the white house you had to
be clairvoyant and know they had it no
not clairvoyance i think it's pretty
obvious senator it if how would you know
to request it you would know it after
senator hawley launched his attack on
the judge
at that point all of this information
became relevant to uh countering
so i would be expected to say geez after
senator holly asked questions i better
call the white house and see if they can
help me research this that's not real
that's the point the point i'm getting
to is and you know as a good lawyer uh
what you do during discovery
i wasn't aware of the fact that this was
available the white house requested it
received it we asked for a copy and
within an hour or two you received the
same copy
when did y'all get let me let me finish
when did y'all get your copy
sometime today
sometime today that covers a lot of
ground richard
i don't have any personal knowledge of
this i'll be honest with you you don't
have any personal what knowledge does
your staff does your staff know i i have
they're standing behind you i talked to
them earlier mr chairman
i'm so sorry i just want to make this a
partisan issue if it doesn't have to be
my staff just says we just got it ten
minutes to go as well so i'm very upset
i joined ted cruz good wow mr chairman
that's an alliance that's well-known yes
yes mr chamber i i do think it's it's
significant we we've had now reference
some pre-sentence reports
and we've we've got this material that
references recommendations made by the
the office of adult probation and parole
well okay but we've got critical
information that is contained within
them the the recommendation made by the
office of adult probation and parole in
these cases is something that's drawn
from the pre-sentence report
it seems to me that if we're going to
have a job for jot
selective incorporation
of information in there we ought to have
access to the whole report
so i i i i respectfully request yeah
take a break so booker can read it
access to these reports they've been
made now by a member of the committee
in reliance
on information that we haven't had
access to and and and i think we need to
be given those you you can't you you
can't uh i i'd like to draw this to a
conclusion i can tell you what i know
well so would i
and here's the point most of this
information was published in the
washington post five days ago all right
this is not confidential information
when the holy attack on the judge
started this fake drama information the
white house did
and then shared it with us within the
day and you now have the same copy that
we have
story is it fair for you to characterize
uh senator hawley's questions or the
questions raised by any of us as an
attack
yes completely fair we've raised a
legitimate question regarding our
sentencing regarding the most heinous
crimes imaginable oh come on no these
are legitimate questions mr chairman
don't call them attacks well i can just
tell you their attacks i have
characterized
them as attacks and other things as well
i think it's pretty clear what's going
on here and now you have all the
information we have so mr chairman for
example in the questioning about the
hawkins case
judge jackson said she relied on the
factors relied on probation's
recommendation we just found out and
what you just handed us that in the
hawkins case you guys know why they're
doing this right because this is when
everybody's watching the news at home
it's 6 p.m almost 7 p.m on the east
coast a lot of networks are carrying
this live right now this is why they're
doing it king ticket
and senator this committee given that
she raised it as the based on her
sentence
it is highly relevant to the committee's
analysis to see what the pre-sentence
report says why did the probation office
recommend 18 months and she only
sentenced to three months
march 19th washington post
in the case of u.s versus hawkins a sex
offender had multiple images of child
porn over 18. sentencing guidelines
called for sentence up to 10 years john
jackson sends the perpetrator to only
three months in prison
those facts we knew it's the probation
recommendation we don't dispute that
the guidelines said in 10 years i'm
curious whether they can go till
midnight i think it would be interesting
both recommended sentences well below
the guidelines the government
recommended 24 months probation
recommended 18 months and defense
recommended one day
i'm telling you it was published in a
newspaper well i can't help what is
leaked to the newspaper or not this
committee you keep referencing discovery
this is not litigation this is a
committee of the united states senate
where both sides of the aisle have a
right to access to the record and we're
carrying out our constitutional duty of
advice and i will tell you this uh for
some reason your side didn't request the
information but how would we know to
request so i'm hereby requesting all
other information you magically have
that you haven't told us you have and
you're not sharing with the other side
so noted for the please proceed we'll
continue with the questioning and we're
requesting the pre-sentence reports in
particular which are highly relevant to
the issues senator cotton please proceed
we don't have any pre-sentences please
proceed
governor judge i'd like to talk about
crime
in 2019 there were about 16 000 murders
in america in 2020 there were more than
20 000 it's a 25 increase in one year
2021 data isn't complete but we know
many cities have reached record levels
of murder including philadelphia atlanta
and milwaukee
at the same time
the prison population has decreased by
about 14 percent
in part from pandemic policies but also
from fewer prosecutions
and weaker sentencings now it's already
fallacious though that reflects
previously committed crimes because it
takes time for people to go through the
justice system some members of your
family have law enforcement backgrounds
and i honor them and thank them for
their service
does the united states need more police
or fewer police
thank you
senator as you just noted
i have law enforcement in my background
and i am
very familiar with
the problems that crime cause in the
communities where we live okay judge i'm
sorry um we have a few minutes here
you have a lifetime appointment if
you're confirmed i asked a simple either
or question does united states not
really the job of a supreme court
justice senator the determination
about whether
there should be more or fewer police is
a policy decision
by
another branch of government and
municipalities judges have control over
and i
will stay in my lane in terms of the
kinds of things that
are properly in the judicial branch okay
if you don't want to address whether the
united states needs more if you're a
police we'll move on to sentencing which
is certainly in your lane there's been a
lot of talk about i mean what is their
opinion on fly-by-wire airplane systems
yeah it's like it's just not up to her
likely or less likely to commit a crime
if they know that they will be caught
convicted and sentenced
senator
what is in my lane is the
consideration of particular cases of
prosecution you've spoken a lot today
about criminal senate saying about the
theory of sentencing you've written
about a lot about on your record it is a
very simple question
is someone more likely or less likely to
commit crime if they're certain more
certain that they're going to be caught
convicted and sentenced
senator i am aware
from my work on the sentencing
commission and not as a judge
that there is research into
recidivism rates into
rehabilitation into the factors that go
into a determination about whether
someone is more
or less likely to commit crime part of
what
um congress has taken into account when
it determined that
one of the purposes of punishment is
deterrence
is the idea that if someone is
convicted and punished
they will be deterred from
committing other crimes and you've
mentioned that and you've written about
that in your writings there's four
purposes of punishment one of those is
deterrence
isn't it inherent in the concept of
deterrent that people are less likely to
commit crime if they're more likely to
get caught convicted in sentence why
can't you just say that's the case
senator it's not that i'm avoiding
saying that's the case no that's not
judge that's exactly what you're doing
i'm asking a very simple question
in general is someone more likely or
less likely to commit a crime if they
know they're going to be caught
convicted and sentenced it's very part
of deterrence it's it's very difficult
to answer questions in general when
you're asking about
things like phenomena related to crime
it's the theory behind deterrence
that by punishing someone they will be
less likely to commit the crime in the
future that is a theory that
do you think that theory is correct
senator there is research that supports
that
deterrence is something that can occur
does it occur in every case i can't say
that yeah the research i've seen is that
generally speaking a belief that one
will be caught does serve as a deterrent
but stricter penalties
do not and this is where the death
penalty thing comes from
is 17 years too long or not long enough
for a criminal to spend in prison for
murder
senator these are policy questions
whether they're in the province of the
sentencing commission in terms of
recommendations whether they're in
congress
they're not the kinds of things that i
can opine about so you don't want to
opine on whether 17 years is too long or
too short a sentence for murder kind of
depends on the circumstances but senator
cotton
the the
congress has prescribed a number of
factors that judges look at
when they sentence it may
in many cases not be i don't i can't
answer in the abstract in the way that
you these are very concrete let's turn
to rape do you know how long the average
inmate convicted of rape serves in
prison in america and what state
well senator rape is not a crime in the
federal system that
that i'm
familiar with working there you go so i
don't know it's 7.2 months
do you think 7.2 months is
too long or too short for someone
convicted of rape
to be sentenced to prisons these really
aren't issues at the supreme court
policy question about
the the egregious crime of rape and
congress has said that the court is
supposed to take into a number take into
account a number of factors when it
sentences
okay i can't answer in the abstract well
these are judge these are not abstract
these are very concrete um and remember
these are just the length of sentence
but the whole point of our justice
system is we don't we don't sentence
people abstractly we sentence people in
specific cases for the things they did
based on the facts of the case murders
increased by the fastest rate ever in
the united states
do you know what percentage of murders
are solved in america
of cases i do not senator the answer is
about half 54 percent sounds high
sounds high do you think we should catch
this is imprison more murderers or fewer
murderers
well senator it's very important that
people be held accountable for their
crimes
uh so
that is by the way who's talking do you
guys hear that there's another guy
talking in the background somewhere oh
so is that a yes we should catch more
murderers specifically the 46 percent of
murderers who get away with it
senator i'm not
to the saint you're asking about
enforcement or law enforcement those
judges it's a very simple and common
sense question 46 of all murders go
unsolved
should we it would be great to solve
every murder should we catch fewer would
be great to solve every murder we should
hold people accountable for their crimes
and so if people are not being held
accountable then that is a problem let's
turn to assaults and remember on the
supreme court she has no involvement in
solving murders
20 no senator 44 so 56 percent of all
assault victims did not receive justice
do you think we should catch him in
prison
more
criminals who commit assault against
innocent people or fewer i'll be back
senator
it's very important that people be held
accountable for their crimes so if
they're
not
um
then it would be a problem for the rule
of law
let's look at sexual assault and rape
do you know how many what percentage of
sexual assaults and rapes
go unsolved in this country
i do not senator
more than three quarters of all sexual
assaults and rapes go unsolved do you
think we should catch and imprison
more rapists and sex criminals or fewer
senator
one of my two uncles was a detective
in a sexual crimes and battery unit
so i'm very familiar
with
that type of crime
it's a horrible type of crime as are all
of these that you are articulating and
it is important for people to be held
accountable for criminal behavior it's
fundamental to the rule of law
okay
so in 2020 alone well over one million
one million violent crimes
went unsolved in america do you think we
imprison too many violent criminals or
not enough
senator it's important
for
our rule of law
to ensure that people are held
accountable who are breaking the law
in the ways that you mention and
otherwise
what do you think
the families of all those victims think
do you think they think that we should
arrest and convict and sentence all
these criminals who get away with it
senator
i know with the families of law
enforcement officers think
because i'm one of them
i know what crime does to our society
i care deeply about
public safety
and as a judge it's been my duty when i
was at the trial level i'm no longer
there but when i was at the trial level
to ensure
that people are held accountable for
their crimes okay
let's turn to the crime of child
pornography i know there's been a lot of
talk about it today i don't want to
spend much time on it a lot of people
have tried to explain the various
differences in these cases and the
pre-sentencing reports and the sentences
that they got so let me just ask you a
simple question about it
should the united states strengthen or
weaken
sentences for child pornographers
senator that's not a simple question and
the reason
is because
what this country does in terms of
penalties is in congress's province
you all decide you all decide what the
penalties are you decide what the
factors are that judges use to sentence
if
you determine
that any set of penalties is
insufficient
then it is in your purview
to make that determination there are
many crimes that congress has determined
warrant mandatory minimum penalties
warrant other kinds of penalties and
that is in your purview to determine
i say judge i think whether or not we
should strengthen or weaken
sentences for child pornographers is a
pretty simple question but i'll move on
um i think the difference we've heard
today gets to this simple fact that a
bunch of elite lawyers whether they're
judges or federal prosecutors or public
defenders or law professors think that
sentences for child pornography are too
harsh i don't and i bet a lot of normal
americans don't either you've said
repeatedly that sentencing is a
discretionary act and i understand that
and i agree with it
but you always seem to use your
discretion in these child pornography
cases
to reduce the sentences
i'd say if i had that discretion i'd
probably throw the book at child
pornographers maybe that's just me
but let's turn to drug crime
last year more than a hundred thousand
americans died from drug overdose drug
overdose deaths and gang crime have both
skyrocketed in recent years
at the same time that a lot of soft on
crime laws and lower sentences have been
advocated including it on occasions
judge by yourself
in general do you think the united
states should weaken or strengthen
sentences for fentanyl traffickers
traffickers not users
senator
whether or not congress chooses to
strengthen or weaken
penalties for any crime
is a determination of this body
which is ordinarily made after study and
review determination
um that is
in the province
of congress
well judge you've said before that
sentencing is a discretionary act so
that that is literally the job of the
judge in many of these cases to
determine whether to have a shorter or a
longer sentence respectfully senator the
judge makes that determination not based
on
one data point
in general which is what you asked me in
general should we
lower or heighten sentences a judge is
making a determination in a particular
case looking at all of the factors it's
discretionary for sure but we do so
within the bounds
of a sentencing range that congress
prescribes and at times in which
congress decides that a penalty needs to
be heightened they impose a mandatory
minimum then our range is shorter
and
when we're looking at the crime we're
not looking as a policy matter across
all fentanyl crimes and determining
whether the penalty should be increased
as a judge
we are asked in the context of a single
prosecution regarding a particular
person who
has committed a horrible crime but also
says congress
is a person who has a life
who has a job who has all of the other
factors that congress has told judges
they have to look at when they decide
what penalty to impose in that
particular case between the range that
congress sets so it's not a situation in
which i can in my role as a judge tell
you as a general matter
whether penalties should be increased or
decreased
i have to say i i think that not many
americans
especially not the hundred thousand
americans uh who's lost someone to drug
overdose think these are tough questions
but let's move on
let's talk about retroactivity when you
were on the sentencing commission you
repeatedly advocated for retroactively
reducing drug trafficking sentences
so this is a case where a drug kingpin
who's dealing fentanyl gets sentence and
then a few years later he gets lucky he
gets in front of some new judge who's
maybe more sympathetic and thinks he got
a wrong raw deal or maybe he just gets
in front of the same judge a few years
removed from seeing the faces of the
victims of his crime
do you believe that resentencing years
after a convict conviction tends to
reduce
senate's lengths
senator
respectfully i just wanted to um remark
on your previous question in in your
statement that these are not
difficult questions they're it's not
that they're difficult questions it's
that they're not questions for me
i am not
the congress i am not making policy
around sentencing my job is to look in a
particular case and decide
what the penalty should be within the
range that congress prescribes i
understand you you were making policy
though at the sentencing commission and
you're implementing changes to
sentencing guidelines so my question
again is do you believe that
resentencing years after a conviction
tends to reduce sentence lengths
i'm i'm not sure i understand your
question obviously if you
re-sentence you're giving
the
judge another opportunity to look at the
circumstances in light of the changed
penalties sometimes the judge in that
new situation
will
keep the same penalty
a re-sentencing is just an opportunity
for the judge to reevaluate in light of
the change circumstances okay almost
without exception retroactively
weakening sentencing laws and guidelines
let's harden criminals out early
i i always hear the argument i hear from
some of the senators on this panel i
heard a version of it from you earlier
that each case is going to go before a
judge and it won't be an automatic
release
because
each judge is going to assess the facts
and hear the arguments
in 2014 you said that judges would not
would not
likely reduce the sentences in the vast
majority
vast majority of cases if sentencing
guidelines for drug trafficking
were reduced
i think you missed that one judge
since 2014 retroactive reduction took
when retroactive reduction took effect
approximately two-thirds
of all convicted drug traffickers who
asked for early release got it that's
thirty one thousand six hundred fourteen
hardened drug traffickers back on the
streets
more than
seven thousand five hundred of those
hardened drug traffickers
use weapons in their crimes so that
means that only one-third of these drug
traffickers who sought to have
retroactive reduction of their sentence
were denied judges one-third a vast
majority
senator it's hard for me to answer
questions about these numbers because
i'm trying to understand whether this is
a retroactive
release that was a result of the
sentencing commission's actions or
congresses congress made a decision
about
um
retroactive
reductions and drug penalties so i i'm
just
not sure what but judge in both cases we
always hear the argument whether it's
from members of congress to include
senators on this committee or the
sentencing commission that we shouldn't
worry there's going to be individualized
case-by-case determination
and that is my that is my experience
that's when when there's a when there is
a retroactive
uh change
so what happens is that
um whether it's the guidelines that are
changed or
the laws that are changed which happens
in congress
and there is a subsequent determination
as to whether or not to
apply that retroactively apply that
change so that
both the people who get
um convicted of that penalty moving
forward and the people who have already
been convicted both of them get the
benefit of the change if the
determination is made to make it
retroactive
under that circumstance where you're
talking about a penalty change applied
to prior people
each one of those prior people goes back
before a judge
and a judge usually the senator who if
this is generally there are some
exceptions but generally speaking um the
judge will reevaluate whether or not to
give that person the benefit
of the change
this is an individual assessment that's
what congress
requires in every sentence and and
ultimately
um
one that benefits
all of us under the law because judges
are being asked to look at these cases
and not make
just
generalized uh determinations
so so the 2014 comment was specifically
about the sentencing commission but
generally whether it's in front of the
commission or the congress we always
hear this argument that judges are going
to make these individualized cases and
not that many people will be released
i'll point out that of the one-third
that were
uh not reduced the vast majority of
those were not eligible the percentage
of cases in which a sentence is not
reduced for public safety reasons
because someone is viewed as too
dangerous to release early as one
percent it's one percent judge do you
remember a man named keith young
yes good
for the benefit of my colleagues uh let
me quickly cover the basics of his case
you sent it to him in 2018
keith young was a career criminal who
had previously been convicted of
trafficking cocaine in 2017 he was
running a drug business in his house
where his children lived
and was found with
two one kilogram bricks of heroin worth
hundreds of thousands of dollars along
with a gun
ammunition thousands of dollars in cash
and equipment to cut and package heroin
for a retail sale
the drug lab also confirmed that there
was fentanyl in both bricks of heroin
and in one of the two bricks there was
actually more fentanyl than there was
heroin
while at the dc jail awaiting trial
young bragged about his arrest and about
how he was a
kingpin
those are his words not mine
he was even recorded calling his wife
and brother to give them instructions on
collecting drug money from people for
him
the prosecutors filed a notice of
young's criminal history which meant he
faced a mandatory minimum of 20 years
you did not seem to like that judge
in fact at his sentencing you said this
a quote that you shared his frustration
that you couldn't give him a lighter
sentence
i was shocked to see this in the
transcript
i was also shocked that you apologize to
this drug kingpin for having to follow
the law
you literally said that you didn't think
20 years is fair this is the quote and
for this i am sorry
mostly because i believe in second
chances you apologize to this career
criminal a drug kingpin in his own words
he was not some low-level first-time
drug offender who made a bad bad choice
that was in 2018
but in 2020 you got a second
chance after young sentence
congress passed something called the
first step act
which reduced sentences for serious drug
traffickers with lengthy criminal
records
during the pandemic lots of criminals
like keith young tried to twist the
first step act's compassionate release
provision
which was intended for terminally ill
elderly inmates to get early release and
blame it on covet
you had none of that and that's good
you rightly said at his resentencing
hearing quote covet 19 is not only
present in prisons
and you said that young's passed as a
smoker and his claim of various other
health issues did not entitle him to
early release if you had stopped there i
would have cited that as a great example
of how you follow the law and made a
well-reasoned decision unfortunately you
didn't stop there
you said in the resentencing that quote
congress did not make their changes
under the first step act retroactive
but that if they had then you could have
given him a reduced sentence
but then you said no matter what the law
says
and this is a quote judge
the court feels as though in this moment
per mr young's compassionate release
motion
the court is being called upon to
evaluate the length of his sentence
under the revised section of the law on
the first step act and so it is almost
as if i am sentencing him today
and
if i were to do so he would face a
sentence that would be well below the
240 months that mr young received and so
for that reason i will grant mr young's
motion
judge jackson before you granted this
fentanyl kingpin's motion to reduce his
sentence did you contact any of the
victims from his case
senator thank you for allowing me to
address mr young's situation i asked a
simple question did you contact the
victims in his case or not
senator mr young was not released his
sentence was reduced and i did not
contact the victims in this case because
there were no victims he committed
a crime a drug crime there were no
identifiable victims in his case
drug crime is not a victimless crime a
hundred thousand americans were killed
by overdoses understood senator but
there was no one to contact people just
knowing that i acknowledge that you did
not release him you're right you didn't
release him he filed a motion for
compassionate release
you denied that rightly
but you reduced his sentence he didn't
file a motion to reduce his sentence he
wasn't eligible for a reduced sentence
under the first step act because it
wasn't retroactive towards him
you took a motion for compassionate
release to get out of prison
and turn it into a motion to reduce a
sentence so he's going to be released
seven and a half years earlier years
from now
last week judge when we talked in our
office you talked about a lot about
judicial restraint is transforming his
motion for compassionate release
into a motion to reduce a sentence for
this
drug trafficking kingpin an example of
judicial restraint judge
yes senator it is and i will explain how
mr young
as you say
was facing originally a sentence of 20
years in prison which i imposed
i
tried mr young
who went to trial
you're talking about
but the way that our laws work
the
20-year sentence that he received for
the amount of
of
heroin that he had
was increased based on a
sentence that he received i think it was
10 or 15 years before
he had no
criminal history between the old old
sentence and i forgive me i can't
remember exactly what it is and i'm sure
people will look it up but
10 15 years before he had some minor
sentence
then he had this really obviously
serious terrible sentence
and the government filed what is called
an 851 which is an enhancement
based on his
really really old
prior criminal history
i followed the law which said that he
had to go to jail for 20 years it would
have been more like 10 years if the
government hadn't taken into account
his very old criminal history but i said
fine
this is the law i'm following it you're
going to jail for 20 years
in the interim
covid
happens
we get lots of compassionate release
motions and there's a statute that
congress has enacted which allows
defendants to
seek
compassionate release
to seek reduction
of their sentence not just release
reduction release some adjustment to
their penalty under the law if there are
extraordinary and compelling reasons to
do so that's the quote from the statute
extraordinary and compelling reasons
doesn't say
anything more narrow than that although
you do have to look at the guidelines
related to compassionate release
all of which i did related to his motion
and he argued several things he argued
his smoking his asthma these were
reasons he said for compassionate
release and i disagreed
what i did find extraordinary and
compelling
is the fact that between the 20-year
sentence that i gave him originally
and the compassionate release motion
that he filed
congress
changed the law
congress decided that the old penalty
the old crime was no longer eligible for
the increased so that a person who was
convicted
at the time of his compassionate release
motion for doing exactly what mr young
had done
would not get a 20-year sentence that
would not be
lawful
for a person
at that moment and one of the things
that congress says to the judges
is care about unwarranted sentencing
disparity care about the fact
that the person you're sentencing is
being treated differently than someone
else who committed exactly the same
crime and i understand it wasn't
retroactive in the sense that everybody
absent a compelling uh
absent a compassionate release motion
wouldn't have been eligible for
re-sentencing but here i have a
defendant before me
and all of the factors that congress has
asked me to take into account
and
a compelling argument
that there were extraordinary and
compelling circumstances that is a
change in the law
that would create unwarranted sentencing
disparity if i didn't take account of it
and so what i determined under those
circumstances
is that i would sentence re-sentence mr
young
to the penalty that congress had decided
was the appropriate penalty for the
conduct that he committed as of the time
of his motion judge
congress did change the law after his
sentencing then the first step back that
was a terrible mistake congress
specifically
did not
make that change retroactively and you
saw that and you thought it was
extraordinary and compelling even though
congress specifically did not make it
retroactive
you chose to rewrite the law
because you were sympathetic to a
fentanyl drug kingpin whom you had
expressed frustration at having
sentenced him to his cri to his 20-year
sentence in the first place
you twisted the law and you rewrote it
so you could cut the sentence of a drug
kingpin that's what you did judge
respectfully senator i disagree
congress
provided judges through the
compassionate release motion
mechanism
with
the opportunity
to review sentences
congress prior to the compassionate
release mechanism being enacted
a judge who
imposed a sentence would have no
opportunity to revisit
in mr young's case the question was
with this compassionate release motion
under a circumstance in which congress
had changed the law was that an
extraordinary and compelling
circumstance
to
revisit his sentence and i made a
determination that it was so i suppose
then if you're confirmed we can just
count on you to always rule in favor of
retroactivity no matter what the facts
of the case are because it was a blatant
blatant rewrite of the law here so you
could reduce the sentence of a drug
kingpin if you didn't like sentencing to
20 years in the first place
no senator it was not
senator booker
approaching 11 hours now of a long day
and forgive me i want to go back to one
of my early senators uh lindsey graham i
think he asked you something and i'd
like to just put it this way
on a scale uh from 1 to 10 how deep is
your faith
that i want to ask that question
you're asking me
you won't ask i'm just joking okay
i won't ask you that but i do want to go
through some of the things that uh some
of my colleagues did on on top line and
forgive me i don't want to dwell too
much but some of it i found today
um
[Music]
just to me really didn't hold water and
i want to start with uh my friend and
colleague ted cruz who is my friend i
like he's a text in my one of my
favorite texans is bernay browns who
says it's hard to hate up close so pull
people in and a lot of times in this uh
culture of tribal politics uh the
reality is we know each other we get to
know each other over years and i've had
the privilege of working with ted on a
lot of really good policy
so i went back to my office and
re-listened to his questioning of you
about critical race theory and he
referenced your speech which i hadn't
read uh uh
you harvard folks are so uh well focused
on these things but i just i read your
speech
and i was very surprised uh ted had a
very big chart i think he needs to give
senator whitehouse some advice on charts
in our white house this was very small
it was almost if they were proportionate
to their state sizes
um
but uh
easy there new jersey
um mr chairman i i would request that my
colleagues in the democratic party would
stop interrupting me um
but he he talked about your speech and
when i read your speech uh there's a
couple things that jumped out first of
all was this he he acknowledged was a
very powerful speech very moving speech
about extraordinary black women i have a
criticism your mother was not in it but
i will leave that alone um
but uh there's some things he honed in
on almost as if there seemed to be
accusations which don't hold merit to me
we have a saying in new jersey i felt it
was all hat and no cattle um and so here
here we he he she he said that you
called uh the woman who wrote the 1619
project that you called her provocative
that that's not a compliment necessarily
if you call someone provocative is it
no no i mean i think ted cruz is very
provocative and that doesn't mean i that
doesn't mean i agree with what he's
saying his philosophy he doesn't mean i
agree with his statements but uh
he pointed out you also called
the author
acclaimed
she won a pulitzer prize correct
in journalism so she is acclaimed she is
uh but in nowhere are you heralding her
as this is a reflective of your
philosophy that's true right correct
yeah so i don't understand that at all
uh part of his chart also was a lot of
ellipses skipping out things but you
mentioned critical race theory when
you're talking about policies in general
i actually went back to that talk too
and i saw you through everything in
there you were talking about psychology
economics all different types of
disciplines is touching upon the law i
think there was everything in there i
seem to be except for astrology but um
you you you understand that that was you
just listing a list of things that
people could say touch the law they
weren't your philosophies at all
correct senator and that speech was not
related to
what i do as a judge that was talking
about sentencing policy and all of the
different academic disciplines
that might relate to it yeah and then
finally we're entering an age that is
surprising to me in american society
where lots of books are being banned and
uh
lots of talks about books being read uh
you're on the board of a private school
and you have no uh supervision or
authority over what books the children
read in a private school correct correct
i really i really do appreciate that uh
jumping really quickly to a lot of talk
today
um about
uh these uh child exploitation cases um
and and senator durbin i think that
uh
actually josh hawley used the word
attack when describing his own his own
so i don't understand why what that
point of sensitivity was but i i i
individual cases we've now heard about
two
you've you've presided over as a judge
more than 10 15 cases
i've presided over
14 cases that involve child sex crimes
but i prov over my career as a trial
judge i've presided over more than a
hundred right and cases are
heavily fact specific right that is true
did you remember all the facts of the
case that uh senator holly was i did not
you did not right and and the facts
matter right they do and and as a judge
you're looking at all of the facts of
the case not just what might be talked
about later or what people are honing in
you have to take everything into account
and make a decision correct yes that's
what congress has required judges to do
right and just to clarify that congress
thing because again uh you went to this
elite law school i went to a gritty
inner city law school in yale um and uh
so you know this better than me but it
was actually 1984
that the sentencing laws uh the
sentencing standards were passed down
correct i believe so yes yeah it was
1984 and then later in 2002 or three
things were updated but that 1984 was
before the internet uh completely and i
just want to clarify also the booker
decision yes could you just clarify for
the record because my mom might be
watching no relation to me whatsoever
correct
so um
the booker decision which uh earlier i
mentioned that i thought justice scalia
wrote it in fact it was justice stevens
yes but justice scalia concurred um so
he had a separate opinion and he had
written
a previous decision that was very
similar yes the booker decision um made
the guidelines
the sentencing guidelines advisory why
why would the supreme court joined by
some of the most conservative members
why would they do that
well they determined that um
in essence the booker
that if the guidelines were mandatory
that it would
um
violate the right to a jury trial to
have jurors decide every aspect of your
sentencing yeah it's just sort of the
separation of power sixth amendment yes
uh this is this is really important yes
um and
so that gave judges latitude yes now i
if you were falling out of the norm and
this is where you know i've now read
conservative periodicals looking at this
line of attack that's not a negative
pejorative again my colleague himself
used it but this line of attack on you
i've seen conservative papers liberal
papers mainstream papers all
say this doesn't hold water and the
reason is and again i unlike white house
and tech and crews i don't have a chart
i'm uncharted um but i would like to
hold this up for you um
you are well within the norm
nationally for going below the
sentencing guidelines because
of of this problem where you have this
incongruency that that judges on both
sides of the uh of that have been
pointed by people both sides of the
aisle have seen i just want to make that
very clear you are you are well within
the norm in the united states of america
i i love i'm a former mayor and one of
my favorite mayor friends used to always
say and god we trust but everybody else
bring me data and and and so the data
kind of shows that you're not some
outlier
and and forgive me because this is
you're not allowed to do this but i kind
of sat here i was a little insulted
about the accusation
that somehow
this mother of two
confirmed three times by the united
states senate
who has victim advocacy groups writing
letters for you
who has child victims advocacy groups
supporting you
who has presided over fact specific
cases of the most heinous crimes
that somehow the implication
that you are somehow out of the norm of
other federal judges that we have
confirmed with these issues have never
come up who again i held up this chart
but the majority of of the of the
decisions a percentage of sentences
below guideline range in non-production
child pornography cases in dc 80
of them are under the guidelines and and
missouri's 77 percent in iowa 62 in
north carolina 77 in nebraska 81 and so
on and so on so forth down to utah uh
alphabetical order 71
and and so this implication that somehow
your thoughtfulness
on these very dense fact specific cases
is somehow out of the norm
to me does not hold up doesn't headwater
and then you add that to the
endorsements that you've gotten from
folks that deal with victim advocacy
groups it is to me
just a a line of attack that it does not
hold uh in in in no way for me i'm sorry
in the totality of your career
what you've accomplished and what you've
done
um i just think it's unfortunate that
unlike the sort of fair arbiters of this
on both sides of the eye who've
dismissed it um i i appreciate the way
you've stood it there sat there
and and addressed all of that stuff and
and that really brings me to the larger
implication
you talked a lot about uh your your uh
uncles
one of them served in baltimore is that
right a police officer my brother was a
police officer in baltimore the
gentleman over there yes
who who who
volunteered to serve in the united
states military yes
and he you have talked about that police
work right
yes
i live in newark i love my city if you
cut me i bleed bricks
and and i i what's going with the
nickname of our city is brick city
your brother and i probably understand
something
the majority of murder victims in the
united states of america do you know who
the majority of murder victims are
i don't they're black men
i imagine in your conversations
with your brother
and your two uncles
you who patrolled some of these streets
i imagine you feel in a different way
about the anguish
of what many communities of color
struggle with when it comes to crime am
i am i am i right there you are right
senator
it is very anguishing and it is
something that
i know all too well
and
you are a person that has that same fear
that many mothers have
for their daughters
who do go out in this world my mom used
to say when you have a child it's like
your heart going going around outside of
your body all of a sudden
and
i just find it hard to believe given
your law enforcement background
you're a mom
that you take any of this
urgency to keep america safe
and and then i see that like folks i
know well
i i've worked with the fop i began
negotiating with them
i have to say i thought jim pasco
before i knew him it's a whole thing
renee brown bring people close at first
i thought he was an ogre biggest police
union in the i had some tough
negotiations with my police union he and
i sat down and we shared our stories and
i think we realized we were coming from
the same place when we were working on
police reform
fop endorsed you and they wrote a
powerful letter i won't read it again
the iacp they represent the largest
that's the rank and file the fop the
iacp represents the bosses
the managers
they endorse you
there's another group that maybe my my
colleagues don't know as well as i do is
called noble
do you know them i do
they're the black law enforcement
organization nationally people like your
brother yes who love their communities
yes who have seen like i have too many
young men lying with bullet holes
bleeding into our pavements
these are these are folks who come from
communities
like your brother knows where where you
too often see sidewalk shrines
to murder youth
i've talked to the women in men of noble
so many times
anybody ever accuse them of being soft
on crime
but they understand the complicated
factors
of crime in our country
and what they have to say to you about
you i won't read it it's just beautiful
law enforcement family mother of two
law enforcement organization after law
enforcement organization victims
advocacy organizations after victims
advocacy organizations
republican appointed judges democratic
point of judges
that's who's in your corner
we're politicians we have a sworn oath
right now
i i've just watched you with dignity and
grace
field what i can only imagine is behind
those questions is this doubt that is is
being sown
i just want america to know
that when it comes to my family's safety
when it comes to
newark new jersey or my state
god i trust you
i trust you
now i brought in your mother and i have
to go back there
my mom has a saying that is awfully
embarrassing when she talks about me she
she says
uh uh she'll introduce me and she'll say
behind every successful child
is an astonished parent
but there's something about your mother
looking at her is that she doesn't seem
all too astonished
she seems like almost just very slyly
she knew
that a day like this might come
and and so i just want to share with you
that i
have done a lot of hiring
before i was in a legislative body i ran
new jersey's largest city and i could
write a book about all the management
mistakes i made in my first year and how
it made me a really good manager and the
first mistake i made
was i was just looking for the most
talented credentialed uh uh skillful
smart people to help me run things and i
soon learned it wasn't enough i made
some mistakes in hiring
and i began to see that those skills
which you have
a tremendous amount of
i've you it's been said so many times if
stacking you up against other supreme
court justices you have more
qualifications more credentials in many
of them but i learned that you should
hire
first that's necessary credentials but
not sufficient
that you should hire for character
that's what made me hire a great team in
newark eventually and we we operated so
well
and so i believe i've gotten to know
your character over these weeks
but i want america to know a little bit
more about your character right now
and so i know my values
booker t washington said it excuse me
james baldwin said it children are never
good at listening to their elders
but they never fail to imitate them
if i want to know your character you
haven't let me do this yet but i want to
hang out with your parents a little bit
and so let's draw them into this
conversation we won't swear them under
oath but just could you share with me
what are their bedrock values
that are most a part of your values now
that you hope and pray are your
grandchildren's unborn grandchildren's
values what are those most important
values you inherited from those two folk
over there
thank you senator
i inherited a number of
bedrock values as you say from
my extraordinary parents
as i mentioned my parents grew up in a
time in this country in which black
children and white children were not
allowed to go to school together
they
persevered they were the first
in their families to go to college to
have that chance
they each went to historically black
universities
and
they taught me hard work
they taught me
perseverance
they taught me that
anything is possible in this great
country and i think it came
as i said in my introduction from
the sea change that we had in this
country
from
the 1960s when congress passed two civil
rights acts
and african americans
finally had the chance to
become a part of the dream become a part
of the fabric
of this
wonderful nation
my parents moved to washington dc
because this is where it all started
for them in terms of
having new freedoms
and i was born here
on that hope and dream i was born here
with an african name
that my parents gave me
to
to demonstrate their pride
their pride in who they were and their
pride and hope
in what i could be
and it seems to me
as a guy whose parents came here
and and
you and i both were born here months
apart
i would hear my parents tough stories at
the dinner table
about facing bigotry here in the city my
father told me stories about his early
jobs but i never noticed a hint of
bitterness
or or
that hate he saw never generated hate
with him in fact i
he just loved people all people that is
correct senator and i i would say that
my wonderful parents
went on
to become extraordinary public servants
they
had new opportunity they could have done
you know
other things but each of them
decided
to give back to the community my mother
was in
the public school system she was a
teacher and then became an administrator
became the principal
of a magnet school for the arts in miami
a new school that had started up and
became the sort of beloved principal
uh of new world school of the arts and
so many of her students
uh continue to see me meet me and they
know me for my mother which is fantastic
and she had diverse students she had
extraordinarily and she loved on all
those children everyone black white
everyone
well let me let me ask you this because
i want to push you a little harder
because i again i have some people i
really respect on the other side of the
aisle and they do
my friends and i talk about religion
sometimes faith is important i was
teasing lindsey senator graham earlier
but
um i don't want to ask you anything
specific about your faith except for
this because you brought it up in your
opening statement
and
i have to tell you i don't think black
women have any providence over struggle
people from all backgrounds in america
struggle
um
but i do know often as the trailblazing
black women they they have often faced
many challenges being the first or being
a a trailblazer or breaking glass
ceilings but i know on your journey to
this moment right now
you have faced
very tough moments
probably you've been knocked down by
life i always say if
if america hasn't broken your heart you
don't love her enough
you you've been heartbroken by something
circumstance
you've been like zora neale hurston who
says i've been through sorrow's kitchen
and i licked out all the pots
you've been like langston hughes to
that's that poem mother to son life for
me ain't been no crystal stare
could you talk to me maybe about one uh
moment or what you do when you get
knocked down like that where do you get
the grit and the guts
uh to get back up
and keep on going
well senator i think that too is
something that i learned
from
my grandparents who as i said
didn't
have it easy
my grandparents
[Music]
who didn't have
a lot of formal education but who were
the hardest working people i've ever
known and
um
who just got up every day and put one
foot after the other and provided for
their families and made sure
that their children went to college even
though they never had
those opportunities
i um
i reflect on them in the context of
this historic moment i stand on the
shoulders
of people from that generation
and i
and i focus at times on my faith when
i'm going through hard times those are
the kinds of things that i learned from
my grandmother who used to have those
family dinners and bring us all
together
and i think that's a common experience
of americans that when you go through
difficult times you lean into family and
you turn to faith
and that's part of my experience as well
it's i think the experience of
uh my colleagues on both sides of the
aisle leaning on that faith and that
family
i want to give you uh there's one thing
about your opening statement and i have
to say uh i i haven't actually shaken
your husband's hand yet but yesterday i
was mad at him because when he started
tearing up at your remarks about him it
triggered i don't really have it but it
triggered a sympathetic cry in me
as well so um i'm a little upset at him
but i will uh i will deal with him
individually um
but uh
you said something that i found
provocative
to use that word one more time
and i felt afterwards i reflected i even
talked to my staff about it because i
thought that statement it didn't
seem congruent to me and it was i don't
know if it was a a profession of
humility
or or um overly critical critical of
yourself but i want to end in my last
five minutes
giving you space to explain yourself to
me because
um much to my mom's chagrin i am not a
parent yet
and i want to i'm looking at somebody
that i
admire
but you said
something that
struck me
because look my mom was a working mom
and god
it was tough
i i i my colleagues will will not
believe this but there was a time i was
very melodramatic and i was in in a
bathtub of oatmeal bathtub and my mom
was getting ready to go on a business
trip and i look at her with these sad
eyes and i say mom if you leave me i'll
die
and she looked at me knowing that you
don't die from the chickenpox but i
still remember her going to the phone
having a long conversation taking off
her business suit and changing into her
sweatpants she would tell me later that
that was not a sign of love she loved me
but a lot of women who love their kids
can't stay home
because we don't have paid family leave
in this country
so you said in your opening remarks
that
you haven't been as good of a parent i
think if i'm paraphrasing right a good
as a mom as you'd like to be
and i looked at your two girls
and i look at you and i do i don't
understand that statement
could you could you maybe explain for me
what you meant and
maybe take one more beat and explain to
me
what it means to you to be a mom of two
young
women growing up in america today
thank you senator um
what i said in my statement was that
that i had struggled like so many
working moms to
juggle
motherhood and career
and
it takes a lot of hard work
to
become a judge to do the work of a judge
which i've done now for
almost 10 years
you have a lot of cases you don't have
all that many resources comparatively
speaking and it's a lot of
early mornings and late nights and what
that means is there will be
hearings
during your daughter's recitals
um there'll be emergencies
on birthdays
that you have to that you have to handle
and i know so many
young women in this country especially
who have small kids who
have these momentous events and
have to make a choice
you talked about your mom making the
choice to
make sure that she cared for you in that
moment and there are times when
obviously you have to care for your
family members there are other times
when there are events that you wish you
could be a part of but
here's the emergency case that you have
to deal with and so i said in my opening
um that
girls you know you've had to deal with
me juggling motherhood and
uh job responsibilities and i i didn't
always get the balance
right
and so i would
hope for them
um
seeing me
hopefully you all will confirm me seeing
me um
moved to the supreme court that they can
know that you don't have to be
perfect
in your
career trajectory and you can still
end up doing what you want to do
that you just have to
understand
that there are lots of responsibilities
in the world and that you don't have to
be a perfect mom but
if you do your best and you love your
children that things will things will
turn out okay
well i i'm sure your mom
probably feels she wasn't perfect
but but things have turned out okay
and i will tell you this um
i'm sure they've said it if they haven't
i'm sure they will uh the older i get
the more i appreciate my parents
uh i know they're proud of you but as a
as a guy who does have faith
and i sit at home in a room of my
ancestors where i have generations
of my ancestors pictures up and they're
black folk and white folk
i have a very interesting family tree
i sit there to feel my ancestors
sometimes and think about them
i hope right now
in this
questions in blistering that you know
that at that desk there are a whole lot
of spirits around you with their hands
on you
not only your children your parents
proud
but so are your
ancestors mr chairman thank you
thank you very much senator booker and
judge jackson
a lot of politicians on this committee
22 of them there's only one cory booker
and when he does his cross-examination
on the human side i always wait to see
can you yeah can the witness get through
this without little emotion
there was little there as there should
have been as he talked about your family
and your parents and your children
corey you're one of a kind we love you
we have three more to ask questions
tonight senator kennedy senator padilla
senator blackburn
we're going to break for 20 minutes
grab a bite to eat
freshen up come back for the last round
thank you senate stance
thank you sir
well some incredible moments here some
truly incredible moments and a lot of
different things uh going on you you
might be wondering what's with the two
more three more people rather
senator marsha blackburn
who i actually suspect despite what we
saw from tom cotton
ted cruz
um
who else has been crazy all of them
i suspect
that marsha blackburn may actually be
the craziest of them all
um so that may be a wild
cap
to the night i mean it could be
literally you know like
batshit level
excuse me uh for lack of a better term
all right let's chat about what's been
going on yeah she's a complete loon i
mean it's it's um
it's just it's extraordinarily
disturbing extraordinarily disturbing
okay we're going to momentarily get to
uh some of your voicemails
let's get
an update we are now into the 12th hour
12th hour
of this
stream
and it is extremely disturbing for many
people almost as disturbing as this
image of phil spector which i don't even
know why is on the screen to be totally
frank
let's look at some of the things that
we've got here
um
let's see
rand paul on the hearings you know
when i need moral clarity
and crystal clear insights
i think of two people i think of what is
tulsi's opinion
and what is rand paul's opinion mind we
will watch the hearings unfold but i
promise you this we will not be rude and
we will not be inflammatory and we will
not attack her in a personal way the
democrats have attacked justice
kavanaugh literally every republican
other than ben sasse
interrupted judge jackson
relentlessly let's put together a tweet
every republican
save ben
sasse
relentlessly
interrupted
judge jackson
vile
um
okay here's marjorie taylor green with a
gun
[Music]
we just saw that so we don't need to
look at that
oh this was weird this came up earlier
senator mike braun
brown braun
he um he said he'd be okay leaving
interracial marriage to the states
there's an idea particularly
sickening
given that
the person being considered is black and
married to a white guy so you would be
okay with the supreme court leaving the
question of interracial marriage to the
states sure
yes i think that that's something that
uh if you're not wanting the supreme
court to weigh in
on issues like that
you're not going to be able to have your
cake and eat it too
about griswold versus connecticut yeah
you can list a whole host of issues when
it comes down to whatever they are
i'm going to say that they're not going
to all make you happy
within a given state
but that we're better off having states
manifest their points of view rather
than homogenizing it across the country
as roe versus wade did
wow
uh these these people are pretty bonkers
uh let's see what else we've got from
the hearings
yeah we okay we looked at that earlier a
lot of the i'm not going to review
things we just looked at in the last
couple of hours
um
but let's see if we have any sidebar or
commentaries
a picture of some kind of seafood
platter
this is a list i maintain on twitter of
people who tend to post like clips and
and this sort of thing
uh we're just kind of looking through it
oh hillary has coveted
hillary writing well i've tested
positive for
covid
donate plasma today please i've got some
mild cold symptoms but i'm feeling fine
i'm more grateful than ever for the
protection vaccines can provide against
serious illness please get vaccinated
and boosted if you haven't already apply
light and heat to cure supposing we hit
the body with a tremendous
very powerful light supposing you
brought the light inside the body
maybe you can maybe you can't i'm not a
doctor right
well absolute best wishes to
hillary clinton who has tested positive
for covid positive for covid i want to
say a huge thank you here
to jacob who has buoyed today's 12-hour
stream
with a 100 super chat pac-man why didn't
i get a notification when you first went
live i've heard others got one i don't
know i genuinely have no idea about that
um
yeah i just don't know
it is unusual it is unusual but i
appreciate the super chat
uh
oh this seems funny dj and you know
you've covered a lot of hearings we all
remember when john roberts was asked
about racist babies
nicely done there nicely done there by
uh
by ari melber i like that one
um
this is the moment that was being
referred to by the way
do you agree with this book that is
being taught with kids that the babies
are racist
senator
i do not believe
that any child
should be made to feel
as though they are
racist or though they are
not valued or though they are less than
i gotta cover that tomorrow i'm just
gonna email that to myself sort of doing
some show prep in real time so this is
for my cruise
racist babies file
this is how the magic happens this is
normally what i'm doing at this time of
the day
uh all right so that was that was pretty
weird
um
let's see what else we have here
oh i like this
represent our clients and that's what
you are doing with regard to the
detainees
and i just want to note that some of the
very senators who are openly questioning
you for representing
uh defendants or detainees have in the
past made the argument that judicial
nominees should not be opposed for the
arguments they make in the course of
representing clients yeah but that was
when it was other people
i'm going to quote one of my colleagues
i've been a military lawyer for almost
30 years i represented people as a
defense attorney in the military that
were charged with some pretty horrific
acts and i gave them my all the system
of justice that we're so proud of in
america requires the unpopular to have
an adequate and an advocate and every
time a defense lawyer fights to make the
government do their job that defense
lawyer has made us all safer
do you agree with that
uh i do senator
yeah
uh so that was a couple hours ago
did this one already
we've got a lot of uh this stuff covered
questioning your judgment
yeah so anyway an eventful day a very
very eventful day
here's a picture of josh hawley horrible
person
uh
here is dana perino weighing in
all the things that amikoni barrett went
through where that was unnecessary yes
yes what do you think
this was a powerful uh
powerful hearing um i didn't watch it i
didn't see a single
moment of it i had no desire to now is
this comedy or not
you know with fox it's hard to tell when
you're watching the news versus opinion
sides
it's also hard to know whether you're
watching the comedy side
here's i mean we know what happens with
these things if you're a republican
nominee you'll be accused of being a
rapist if you're a republican
questioning a democrat nominee you will
be called a racist so either you're a
racist or you're a rapist and these
smears only go one way the worst thing
republican really really
important
uh really a profile in courage that uh
that that commentary
um marjorie taylor green referred to the
ruble as the rupee just a few months ago
president putin made a deal with china
a 17 point no i'm sorry
117.5 billion deal to sell them oil and
gas we just had india do a deal with
russia where india is buying um oil and
gas and they're paying in rupees they're
paying in the russian currency just a
few
okay yeah uh wow wow so a lot a lot
happening there certainly a lot
happening there geez that's that's
really something else
um okay let's listen to a couple of
voicemails here
um
let's see what we've got here
hey david uh sir i'm just giving you a
call today because uh i heard on your
show that you were willing to listen to
arguments for recreational cocaine use
and while i'm not a recreational cocaine
user
i do find that no i so again i never
said i was interested in arguments for
recreational cocaine use
what i was looking was arguments for the
legalization of cocaine just to be you
know able to go and buy it the way you
do
cannabis at a pot shop so i think that
unfortunately a misunderstanding of what
i was uh she's asking about
but what what can you do it's uh
it is what it is i guess
um thank you to blue box did i thank
blue box for the twitch prime
subscription already i think actually i
think i did yeah i think i did
um
yeah
i did thank you
so um
i won't thank them again
let's look at a couple of other things
they are set to resume very soon they're
taking a very short dinner break a
couple of the things that we'll have
tomorrow oh we looked at these clips
earlier but it was literally 12 hours
ago uh so maybe i'll show them to you
again donald trump tried to counter
program the uh confirmation hearings
yesterday and he did a bit on the n word
hope to god you never have to use it
because it would be that would be the
tragedy of all tragedies but if we
didn't have it we couldn't talk but i
listened to him constantly using the
n-word that's the n-word and he's
constantly using it the nuclear word
and we never
talk if we say oh he's a nuclear power
very very strange interview here was
trump asked a policy question
there's this discussion about whether we
should send jets mig jets to help the
ukrainian air force would you send in
that kind of help
well maybe even more to be honest with
you and um
mr president stayed out i'm the one that
would have stayed out let me just
explain that
putin is saying things like
don't you dare send anything in in the
meantime he's killing thousands and
thousands of people
so he's acting like we're an aggressor
if we send in some old 44 year old flame
that probably gets shot out of the sky
pretty quickly
and he's acting like we were terrible
people if we do that
but he's killing tens of thousands of
people far more than they're reporting
you don't knock down those buildings and
blow up those buildings and they say two
people were injured slightly and
thousands of people are being killed so
completely incoherent interview here's
something different that i think you
will actually like this is extraordinary
extraordinary uh video
this is video of dr karen berg
explaining to a bunch of kentucky clowns
kooky kentucky clowns
uh how
like women's health actually works in
the context of the abortion debate this
is very very good explain my novo yes
ma'am
you know i'm a diagnostic radiologist
and diagnostic radiologists
historically and in many places in this
state still
do all of the first trimester ob
ultrasound
so i am
extraordinarily personally familiar with
the development of a fetus in the womb
and for you to sit here and say that at
15 weeks
a fetus has a functional heart a four
four-chamber heart that can survive on
its own is fallacious that is not true
there is no viability you know it it
i look around at my colleagues on this
committee
i am the only
woman on
this podium right now i am the only
physician sitting on this podium
this
bill is a medical sham
it does not follow medicine it does not
even purport to listen to medicine
and for each and every one of my
colleagues
to be so willing
to cast and i vote
when what you are doing is putting your
finger putting your knee
putting your
a gun to women's heads you are killing
women
because abortion will continue
women will continue to have efficacy
over their own body
whether or not you make it legal
i vote no and i really
really apologize to the people in
kentucky that we are spending this much
time and this much energy when we have
families in poverty we have single
women heading households in poverty at a
higher rate than any other group in the
state
and you all are not addressing that you
all are making it worse
thank you
very very powerful stuff so we're going
to look at that tomorrow
um
this is weird kid rock appeared with
tucker carlson
and seemed to be saying
seriously that trump would go to him for
foreign policy advice which is uh scary
to say the least
doesn't take it too seriously yeah you
know he's engaging
so it's just you're just cutting it up
just open with politics and i was there
with him one day when he ended the
caliphate
he wanted to put out a tweet yes the day
the caliphate fell
it was like
i don't like to speak out of school i
hope i'm not but it was something like
he's like
tell him like yeah the tweet was that
i'm paraphrasing but it's like you know
if you ever join the caliphate you know
and try to do this you're going to be
dead he goes what do you think i go
awesome right yeah tweet that out i was
like i can't add anything better than
that but then it comes out and it's very
it's reworded and more political and
like you know politically correct and
i'm like just being pretty you know
we're looking at maps
i'm like you know i'm like am i supposed
to be like you know
what a riot huh guys
i make dirty records sometimes but
i do it here you didn't think you'd have
a hand what do you think we should do
about north korea i'm like
what
i don't think i'm qualified to answer
this wow
wow wow wow wow
uh it's not exactly funny that the
former president
was a complete and total
um
but i guess it's funny to talk her
i don't know here's a little bit more
from this
trump let me trump oh
god at the white house it was sarah
palin in the white house now sarah palin
asked him to uh it was friendly with her
and
early right when he got elected he
invited her to dinner to bring some
interesting people
so she said she called me and ted up to
nugent and was like hell yeah
we end up becoming buddies and spend a
lot of time on the golf course now and
it's really weird get phone calls from
and stuff it's just kind of mind blowing
what's he like to play golf with
awesome
so much fun really why
he just knows how to have fun doesn't
take it too seriously yeah you know he's
engaging
so it's just you're just cutting it up
just open with politics matt was there
all right so anyway that's the section
we heard we'll skip ahead a little now
what
i don't think i'm qualified to answer
this
how does he how does he so you're still
playing golf with him down in florida
yeah yeah how's he seem what's that
how's he seem
he seems great
he seems great you know after the
election it was you know a little you
know a little different there and
but
he's still the same guy very important
interview on tucker this is the
exclusive kid rock interview he sits
down he just cuts it up
just starts cutting it up it's just how
sharp he is it's incredible and you can
see now if you watch
a joe biden interview and you watch a
trump interview you're just like there's
there's no comparison
and god bless
the united states take a look at the
oranges of the investigation
then he went donald trump yeah donald
trump
suffer hide
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times fresh vegetables the noise causes
cancer if ivanka weren't my daughter
perhaps i'd be dating her exactly really
no comparison that's absolutely accurate
um dear god uh we are we are really
really screwed
um okay uh haley from georgia says in
the discord server we are currently
reading on tyranny by timothy snyder for
our book club for all of those
interested in joining yes
my new nickname according to one of our
callers is book boy and uh yeah
sometimes i read books and right now on
the david pakman show discord the book
of the month i guess is on tyranny
what gives you hope in the current
political climate oh dear
um
[Music]
not much not much to be perfectly honest
i'm going gonna have to think about an
answer to that right it's looking pretty
damn grim right now pretty grim i mean
listen at least trump lost although i
think he'd win if he ran against biden
in 2024
uh
yeah it's it's not it's not great right
now
uh what non-fiction am i reading right
now i'm reading a book called normal
accidents about um
different types of accidents i mean it's
not super exciting it's it's by charles
pirro it is actually fascinating and one
of the things that it talks about it
talks about systems you know complex
systems and uh
one of the interesting things is
the idea that sometimes adding safety
mechanisms to systems
doesn't actually make them any less
likely to fail
because you add more complexity where
like the prototypical example is like
okay you've got airplanes right
and sometimes airplanes have fires and
that's like really really bad if you
don't put out an airplane fire you've
got a major problem
so you add
a smoke detector to the airplane
but now you have both the plane which
works if it's not on fire you also have
a smoke detector which might work or it
might not work so now you've added
complexity great
also usually when you add
a safety mechanism
you are more comfortable
designing the system in a way that
relies on that so whereas like before
the smoke detector you might say i need
everything that could be on fire to be
within five feet of me
the smoke detector gives you the comfort
to say we can have stuff that's a
hundred feet away from us on the plane
that could go on fire
because
we've got the smoke detector but
sometimes the smoke detector doesn't
work so then you go okay well let's add
a backup smoke detector system and let's
add a fire suppression system well now
you've got four different systems okay
this is this is the idea
and um the other point that the book
makes very interestingly this is by the
way only the first page everything i'm
telling you no i'm kidding it's like the
first hundred pages
um
people also tend to you it like you make
cars safer with like seat belts and
airbags and people will then drive them
to to the a further limit which makes
them effectively equally safe now in
reality the rate of fatal accidents has
gone down over a long period okay but do
people get the the concept here so
that's the book normal accidents very
good so far
i'm also reading the 1995 book that the
mind hunter netflix series is based on
which is really interesting really
really interesting so those are my books
right now and then for
fiction
i just finished up
slaughterhouse five by the great kurt
vonnegut
and i'm in the middle of a book called
constance it's a new book by
uh hold on constance
by matthew fitzsimmons the concept is
there are clones
we upload a backup consciousness and if
we die the clone is activated but some
states in the book virginia doesn't
recognize clones as people
which has very complicated things
for a number of different reasons
okay so that's a great fiction book if
people are looking uh
for a fiction book
um let's see what else we've got here
izul has just gifted five subscriptions
via twitch and his number 65. thank you
so much i really appreciate that and uh
we are in hour 12 of this stream
with total peace love and humility
i would love for you to support what is
the longest stream we have ever done
either by grabbing a membership at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code fix the court or by making a twitch
prime subscription or and i will issue
this option
make a patreon pledge and we will count
it double in our
goal to get to a thousand patreon.com
david pakman show counts double okay
very very important very very important
william asks mr pakman sir your thoughts
on the murdoch media empire in general
and its pernicious influence in the
parts of the english-speaking world
i don't have any particular thoughts
about the murdoch media empire i mean
extraordinarily damaging
uh yeah no i don't i'm i'm just i'm
unsure that i have anything uh
specific other than very vile
izul has gifted another four twitch subs
putting us at 69. now let me do some
quick math the goal is a hundred and
we're at 69.
six divided by 10 is 0.6
9 divided by 0.09
we're at 6